Welcome to this learn Python through game
development course. In this course, we've
compiled the five great game programming tutorials,
all in Python. To help you learn Python. through
creating games, you will learn how to create
Pong snake Connect for Tetris. And finally,
a simple multiplayer game. This course is
all about learning through doing. If you want
to learn Python syntax directly, check out
our other big Python course though there's
a link up here or down in the description.
The some people learn best by just jumping
around to projects, especially people who
may already have a little bit of experience
with another programming language. But whatever
your experiences, you may learn best by just
jumping into these game development projects,
a few of the tutorials use PI game, you don't
have to know about pi game already. But you
can always check out our pygame course, the
links right up there down in the description
again, you should be able to follow along,
even if you don't really know that much about
pygame. So check the description if you want
links to the code. Or if you just want to
learn more information about the people who
created these great tutorials. So let's jump
right into it.
Let's take a look at what we're going to be
building today. Classic Pong game. So we got
a paddle on the right, we got a paddle on
the left. And we've got a ball in the center.
Okay, the ball goes off the screen.
And
the opposite player gets a point and the ball
continues. Okay, so that is what we're gonna
be working on. So let's get started. Today,
we're gonna be doing this by using Python.
Of course, this is written in Python three.
But it should work in Python two as well,
I don't think there's any Python three specific
code in this particular tutorial. So we're
going to be building this on top of the turtle
module. On turtle module, it was a nice little
module, it lets you do some basic graphics,
it's great for getting started with games,
a lot, a lot of tutorials use pygame, which
is amazing. It's got a lot of great features.
But for beginners, this is a lot simpler.
And it's built in, you don't have to install
it like you do with pygame. So now that I've
got my turtle imported the module, I need
to create a window. So I'm going to call it
w n, you got wind w i n or wherever you want
to call it. And but I use w n and it's turtle
dot screen, notice the S is capitalized, it's
very important. And I'm going to give it a
title. And I'm going to call that poem by
at Tokyo edtech. That's my Twitter handle.
And do feel free to leave comments I do take
keep close eye on things. And if you having
trouble, let me know. And I want to change
the background color of the window to black
classic Pong. And I want to change the size
of the window. And I want the width to be
800. And I want the height to be 600 pixels.
I'm gonna do something called wind tracer.
And this one's a little bit hard to explain.
But basically what that does is it actually
stops the window from updating. And so we
have to manually update it, what this lets
us do is basically speed up our games quite
a bit. If we didn't do that, things would
run much, much slower. So every game meet
needs something called a main game loop. And
this is where basically all the meat and potatoes
of your your game goes to. So we're gonna
make a loop wild true. Not gonna put four
spaces there. Um, you can use tabs, but spaces
are recommended. But whatever you use, make
sure that you are consistent. You can't make
spaces and tabs, and then we'll do Windows
Update. And what that does is every time the
loop runs, it updates the screen. Okay, just
a quick note this this program is written
for beginners, so I'm not really using object
oriented programming, I'm not really using
classes, except as it relates to the turtle
module. This is basically a really straightforward,
old school style of programming methodology.
So let's run that and see how it goes. And
what we should have is we have our title,
black background. It is 800 wide by 600 tall.
00 is at the center. So plus 300 minus 300
plus 400 minus 400. Remember those numbers
because they'll come in handy in our next
few tutorials. So that's all for this particular
lesson. I just want to get you started. We
move on to lesson two, we'll add our paddle
on the left, paddle on the right and our ball
in the center. In this part of the tutorial,
we're going to add our paddles to the screen
and we're going to add the ball to the screen
as well. So let's get started with that. So
basically what we have in Pong is we have
Pat, I'm gonna call it paddle a, we have paddle
B. And we have a ball. So those are the three
items that we need to add to the screen. Now,
as I mentioned earlier, in the previous video,
we are using the turtle module to, you know,
add our graphics and to open our windows and
things like that. It's very, very convenient,
it works great for basic games, a lot of people
use PI game, which is great. But for simple
games, this is probably an easier way to get
started. So everything in our game needs a
name, so I'm going to call it paddle ng very
original. And it is actually going to be a
turtle, what's known as a turtle object. So
to do that, it's turtle dot capital turtle.
Notice the capitalization small t, because
that is our module name, capital T, because
that is the class name. Now, as this tutorial
is aimed at beginners, I'm not going to talk
about classes, I'm not writing in object oriented
style, I'm just writing it in, you know, functional
style. Although there are some objects kind
of patterns here, you'll you'll see. But for
beginners, don't worry about that stuff for
now. So then what I want to do is paddle a,
I need to set the speed. Now this is not the
speed that the paddle moves on the screen.
This is the speed of animation, this is just
something we need to do for the turtle module.
And what this does is it sets the speed to
the maximum possible speed, otherwise, things
would be really slow. We want to give our
paddle a shape.
And there are a few built in shapes. And we're
going to use square in this case. Okay, there's
Circle Square, circle, Square Triangle, a
few others, we're gonna give our paddle a
color. And we're gonna call it white, because
that's what Pong looks like. And we're going
to basically do something called pin up. Turtles,
by definition, what they do is they draw a
line as they're moving, we don't need to draw
lines, because that's not what this program
does. So we do the pet up, and I want my paddle
a to start at minus 350. That's an X coordinate,
and zero and vertically centered in the screen.
So in our game, 00 is in the middle, minus
350 plus 350. So I'm gonna go ahead and run
that and see what it looks like so far. Okay,
so this is our left pattern. Now, you know,
you've played Pong, you've seen the demo from
the first video. Clearly, it's not the right
size. So what we can do in our program is
this. Now just just for your information,
by default, that shape is 20 pixels by 20
pixels, so it's 20 pixels wide by 20 pixels
high. So what we're going to do is we're going
to stretch the shape. So we use the shape
size method, you can see I'm using Visual
Studio codes, very good program, you don't
want a Mac, and it tells you you know, what
you can do stretch with stretch length, etc,
etc. So what I want to do is I want to stretch
the width by five sets to be five times 20.
So that'll make it 100 tall. And then by 20,
wide, and stretch limb is going to be one
we're gonna keep it at the default. So let's
save that and run it. Okay, so you see now
we've got a paddle over here, 20 pixels wide
by 20 pixels high. Okay, now. So that's paddle
a. Now I'm kind of lazy guy. So I'm just going
to copy this. So what I always recommend if
something's similar, similar styles are similar,
you know, functions, you know, get it working
right once and copy it, paste and just make
the necessary changes. So now that we've done
that, we just need to change that to be. So
if you keep consistent names, it will really
help your programming. And in this case, we
want it to go on the right side of the screen.
So that's gonna be plus 350. So I'm gonna
run that and test it. And testing your program
is very, very important. At each stage, a
lot of beginners I don't know why they insist
on typing the whole program in and then trying
to test it and you'll never be able to figure
out where the problems are, especially as
a beginner unless you do it step by step like
this. So we got our left paddle, we got our
right paddle, so I just call it a said paddle
a paddle B. And then the last thing we need
is going to be our ball. So I'm gonna just
go ahead and copy this because it's basically
the same thing. I don't need it stretched.
I want to keep it the original size and I
Want to start in the middle of the screen,
and I'm going to call it ball instead of paddle.
So you see once, if you do it like this method,
if you get everything working correctly, there's
no errors and you tested it, you just copy
and paste, it really speeds up your programming.
So I'm going to run that one more time. Okay,
you can see we've got our left paddle, paddle
a, our right paddle, paddle B, and we've got
our ball, which is starting in the center,
so we're off to a good start. Okay, so we've
got our pond window, we've got our paddle
a on the left, paddle B, on the right, we've
got our ball in the middle. So in this lesson,
we're gonna learn how to move the paddles
using the keyboard. Okay, so what we need
to do is to basically, we're going to create
some functions, okay. And if you haven't ever
used functions before, a function is basically
kind of a piece of a program that does a,
something that's been defined for it. So.
So in this case, we want to move paddle a
up, we want to move paddle a down, we move
paddle B up when we paddle B down. So to use
functions, you first need to define your function.
And I'm going to call this first function
paddle a up.
If you recall, in the last video, we talked
about doing one function at a time or one
piece at a time, getting that working perfectly,
and then you can copy and just make the necessary
changes. So that's what we're gonna do here.
Okay, so paddle a up. So to move the paddle,
what I need to do is I need to know the current
y coordinate. So what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna say y equals paddle, a dot y core. Okay?
Now this part here, paddle A is the name of
the object we created here, we call it paddle
a. And the dot y core method is from the turtle
module. Okay, what that does is it returns
the y coordinate. And so we're just assigning
that value to a variable called y, which makes
sense. Okay, so we've defined the function
using the def keyword, you notice we have
a, I guess, the tab, in this case, whammies
space, we'll see might get an error there.
And I'll explain that a second if we do. And
it's supposed to be set to automatically change
the spaces, but I think it's not set that
way. So I'll leave it the way it is. So then
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to go up on
the screen, it's this way, so up. So why increases
as we go up, it decreases as we go down. So
we're going to do is I'm going to add 20 to
why this is the way you do that. You say y
plus equals 20. So that will add 20 pixels
to the y coordinates. Okay, so now notice,
we've just calculated the y's, then what we
actually have to do is paddle a set y to the
new y. So now having a function doesn't actually
do anything until we call the function. So
the function has just been defined, but we're
not using it. So what would you do is you
do something called a keyboard binding. Okay,
so in the turtle module, we need to do w n.
So that was our window. And listen, this tells
it to listen for keyboard input. And we're
going to use the on key press method. Okay,
and watch what I do here, paddle a up. W.
Okay, so let me explain what that does. So,
this line here, it tells the program to listen
for keyboard input. This line here says, when
the user presses W, notice that's a lowercase
W. So if you have caps lock on, it won't work.
Call the function, paddle a up, here's our
function, paddle a up, paddle a up, says get
the y coordinate, add 20 to the y coordinate,
and then actually set the y of the paddle
to the new y coordinate. Okay, so let's test
that and see what happens. Okay, so I'm going
to hit the W key. Okay, so you can see how
it is moving up. Okay, we actually moved off
the screen. So now that we've gotten that
working, okay, what I can do is I can copy
that and I'm gonna change this to paddle a
down. So instead of adding 20, I'm going to
subtract 20. And then I need to do a key binding
for that as well. So I'm going to copy and
paste that. So it's gonna be paddle a down
and in this case, I'm gonna use the AES key.
You can use whatever key you want, but I just
chosen those as usually swa SD on the left,
and the arrow keys on the right. So again,
I've done one thing, I've changed it, now
I'm going to test it. Okay, so w s, okay,
so everything's working exactly as expected.
So then what I'm gonna do is, now I've got
both of those working, I'm gonna copy it,
and I'm gonna do paddle B. That'll be, that'll
be. So if you keep your naming consistent,
it makes it very, very easy to do what I'm
doing, which is to be lazy. And just use copy
and paste. And then here. Now for paddle B,
I'm going to use the arrow keys. And then
for the up arrow, it's it's a little bit different
use up this capitalize and down is the down
arrow. So again, I made a couple changes,
I'm going to test my code.
Okay, so w s on the left, up and down on the
right. And voila, there you have it, moving
the ball. This is really kind of the meat
and the central kind of part of the program.
This is where we actually get the ball to
move. So we need to get to move, we need to
get to bounce off the top and the bottom.
And we need to get it to bounce off of the
paddles. And so I'm going to show you how
that's going to work. Because we have our
paddles can move. And but the ball does not
yet. So let's get started with that. And so
what I want to do is with the ball is I want
to separate the balls movement into two parts,
an X movement and a y movement. So we're going
to call that I'm going to say ball dot d x
d means delta or change. You can even call
it XP or whatever you want to, but dx works
very, very well. Now on my computer, I found
that two number two works very, very well,
my computer at home, actually, it was like
0.1, it's much, much faster, I don't know
quite know why. So you might have to play
with the numbers here to get it to where you
feel the game should be. So So dx and dy y
equals two. So what that means is every time
our ball moves, it moves by two pixels. So
since x is positive, it's going to move to
the right to and since y is positive, it's
going to move up to so it'd be kind of moving
up and diagonally. Okay, so to get that to
actually happen, we have to go inside the
main game loop. Okay, and in here, I'm gonna
say move the ball. So what we need to do is
ball dot set x. And what we want is the current
x coordinate. So I'm just basically kind of
combining what I did up here into one line,
plus ball.dx. Okay, so the ball starts at
00. So 0x. So the first time through this
loop, it's going to go to an x times the loop
is gonna go to two, so depending on your computer
speed, it could just fly off the screen, or
it could, it can go a little bit slower. So
again, you have to play around with that a
little bit. So that when I say ball dot set
y and basically the same thing I could have
copied and pasted, but I should have done
and ball dot d y. So I'm gonna say that and
I'm gonna test and see what happens. You see
some red lines here. I think there's gonna
be maybe we problem. Yeah. So I'm gonna run
that and explain why it's not gonna work.
Okay, so you see here, I've got an error.
And this is something again, beginners, I
don't know why do not want to read error messages.
The error messages basically tell you what's
wrong. CCR says tab error, inconsistent use
of tabs and spaces. Okay, so I mentioned this
in an earlier video. So here, I use four spaces.
But here, it's a tab. Okay, you got to use
the same thing each time. So I'm gonna go
with four spaces, that's actually the preferred
method. Now I can set my editor up. So when
I hit a tab, it changes the four spaces automatically,
but I'll do that another time. Hey, so I'm
going to run that. And hopefully we'll see
the ball move. Okay, so plus, plus and right
off the screen. All right, which is what we
expected. Okay, so that's, that's good. So
now what we need to do is we need to do some
border checking. So what do we want to happen
when the ball hits the border? Okay, so since
it's moving up into the right, we'll do the
top border first. Once you get the top border
working, then it's easy to get the bottom
we're working. So all we have to do is we
have to compare the balls y coordinate Okay,
so once it gets to a certain point, we want
it to bounce. So if you recall earlier in
the program, we set the height of the window
to be 600. So so that means that the, the
top y coordinate is plus 300, and the bottom
is minus 300. Okay, but the ball itself is
2020, high by 20 wide. Okay, so what we'll
do, then is what kind of split the difference,
so we're gonna say if the ball dot y core,
so if the current y coordinate is greater
than 290. colon, and I gotta use spaces, it's
telling me if it's greater than 290, what
we do is we we set it back to 90.
This avoids certain types of problems. And
then what we need to do is we say ball dot
d y times equals negative one. And what that
does is it reverses the direction. Okay? So
if d Y is two, so d y minus negative one is
negative two. Okay, and that should reverse
the direction of the ball. Let's run that.
Let's watch it and we're good. That's exactly
what we wanted to happen. Okay, now, since
this is working, correct, exactly as we want
it, I'm going to copy and paste that and just
make some changes. So on the other end, it's
less than negative 290. We set it to negative
290. And that is that so let's test that.
To test that we'll need to start the ball
off with a negative DUI for now. And again,
notice how I'm making a change testing making
a change testing. Okay, it's working. That's
about what we wanted it a little bit off screen,
bear. But we'll we'll let that go. So that's
the borders. That's the top and bottom borders.
Now, the next thing we need to do is the left
and right border. So this is where it gets
not more tricky or anything, but you got to
think about what we want to happen. So in
this case, because we're looking at left and
right. Okay, we're not looking at the y coordinate,
we're looking at the export. And now what
we want to do is if the x coordinate, basically,
if it goes off the right side, so if you remember,
we said the width was 800. So that means it's
plus 400 on the left minus 400. On the right.
So let's say if it's greater than, we'll say
290. Or sorry, 390. That tells us basically,
it's gone past the paddle and it is off the
screen. Okay. Okay, so, if that's the case,
basically, we're gonna put the ball back to
the center, zero. And then what I can do is
I can, maybe ball.dx may have it reversed
direction. Okay, so let's take a look at that.
Again, I'm testing to make sure it works.
And if it does that, I can copy and paste
and do the other side.
Okay, so we got an error. Okay, so it says
we got a lot of weird stuff here. That was
a really long one. And
say here, if you see it says line 87. So here's
the line where it thinks the error is. And
there's a lot of different weird stuff. But
basically, what I forgot to do was zero comma
zero. So let's test that again. So it shouldn't
go off the screen and went back to the center
and reverse direction. Okay, so we know it
works. So let's copy that
and paste it. And again, we're just gonna
reverse it. So if it's less than negative
390, and that's all we got to do. So, again,
let's test it. Hopefully it will come back.
Okay, so that's basically, that's exactly
what we wanted to happen. Okay. So in this
lesson, we're gonna learn how to get the ball
to collide with the paddles. So let's see
what we have so far. So we've got our ball,
it's bouncing off the top of the screen, and
it's at the edge of the screen, it goes back
to the center, which is what we want. So what
we got to do is we got to make it so that
when it touches the paddles, it will reverse.
And how we're going to do that is basically,
what we're going to do is we're compare the
x and y coordinates of the paddle and the
ball. So if we look at our code, we put paddle
B at 350. So the x coordinate of the center
is 350. If you recall, the center, it's Sorry,
it's 20 pixels wide, by 100 pixels tall. So
we need to basically look at, we need to make
sure that the ball is basically between here
and here. And that it's basically between
here and here. If it is, then we'll call that
a bounce. Okay, so let me kind of play the
math a little bit on that and give that a
shot. So let's, let's again, as I mentioned
before, we're just gonna try and get the right
paddle working. If we get the right paddle
working, then it's easy to get the left paddle
working. Okay, so I'm going to say so paddle
and ball collisions. Okay, so if the ball
dot x core, so if the balls x coordinate is
greater than. So we said 350, it's 10 wide.
So it's greater than c 340. And the ball?
Well, should I leave it at that? I'll leave
that No, we'll come back and fix it in a bit.
So that's one condition. And the balls, y
coordinate is less than paddle b dot y core,
plus 50. There's a lot of stuff in here. And
there's a lot of different things here. Ball
dot y core is greater than paddle. b dot y
Cor. Minus 50. Isn't glad that scrolling over
from explain that real quick. So if that's
the case, either.
If that is the case, basically, we just want
the DX, same thing we did at the top times
equals one of those is x naught y, sorry,
negative one. So if it's going this way, the
dx is positive. It's gonna balance and go
back this way. So what we want to see is the
ball x coordinate greater than 340. That means
the edges are basically touching. And is it
between the top of the paddle and the bottom
of the paddle actually used to be 50 is probably
40. Because of the size of the ball. Let's
Let's play with that. Let's test out see what
happens. So I'm gonna run that. Okay, so do
you see what happened there? Which is not
only one. Okay, see it bounce there. Watch
what happens. If I miss it. See, there's like
a little bit of a glitch there. It's because
even though it's behind the x coordinate is
greater than 340. And it's between here. Okay,
so you see how that's kind of acting weird.
So we need to do is I want to add this condition.
And ball that x score is less than we'll say
350. So that gives it basically to the middle
of the paddle.
So we'll say ball dot set x to 340. So that
moves it back to the left a little bit. And
then it reverses the direction,
which is what we wanted. Okay, so let me test
that one more time. Make sure it's working.
So bounces Which is good. Hopefully to get
past and see. Okay, so you see how it did
not get stuck that time. So that's basically
what we wanted to happen. Let's just test
it one more time. Yep. So that's, that's where
we wanted it. Hey, so I'm just gonna basically
take this, I'm going to copy it, paste it.
And we're gonna do the same thing on the other
side. So minus 340. greater than minus 350.
And the top and bottom doesn't matter. But
in this case, it's gonna be paddle a, not
paddle B.
That will give you some definitely some weird
glitches. And then same thing, we're gonna
reverse the ball. So let's test it again.
Okay, so over here, he's the up and down arrows,
he bounced. Over here, we're going to use
the W and s keys. That's it. Okay, so something
went wrong there. So I know what I did wrong.
So I had set x here to 340, it should be negative
340. So again, notice, because I'm testing
it, you know, after every little bit of code,
I knew that the problem had to be in here
somewhere, because that's the only thing I
changed. I just I can't emphasize that enough.
Because my students, like I said, they always
want to type the whole thing in and then debug,
which is never a good idea. Okay, so let's
test it one more time. So you see this process,
we're iterating, we're testing and just making
sure everything is working as expected before
we move on, okay, so that is that for that
section. So now we've got collided with the
paddles, it's going off the screen, the next
thing we need to do is to add some sort of
scoring mechanism. So here's what we have.
So far, we've actually got a functioning Pong
game. The paddle on the right is moving using
the up and down arrows. paddle on the left
is moving using W and s, the balls bouncing
is doing everything and he's due. Next we
want to add a scoring system. So let's go
and take a look at that. So basically, what
we do is we want to draw the score on the
screen. And here's how we're going to do that.
In Python using the turtle module, so we're
gonna do is we're actually going to create
a pen, okay, it's called a pen, but it's actually
just a turtle, just like the ball like the
paddle. But the turtle module gives these
turtles objects a lot of different abilities.
So I'm gonna make a pen. And it like the other
is a turtle dot turtle. And I always spell
that wrong. And keep an eye on the capitalization.
So small t for the module name, capital T
for the class name, which we it's happening
in the background. Same thing as before, so
pin dot speed. And again, this is the animation
speed, not the movement speed that we're going
to move, but we're going to give it a color
pen color, the shape doesn't matter because
we're not going to see it. If we want to print
in white on a screen, like classic Pong style,
and pen dot pan up. This is because we don't
want to draw a line. When the pen moves, every
turtle actually starts out at the dead center
of the screen, then we move it somewhere.
And if we don't do pen up, you'll see a line
moving between those two points. And then
here we want to hide the turtle because we
don't need to see it. Now with the ball and
the paddle paddles, we didn't hide it because
we want to see those on the screen. But the
pen we don't want to see, we just want to
see the text that's going to write. So pen.go
two, and zero comma, I think 260 I think and
I played around with the numbers, that's why
no 260 is number one. If you remember, again,
the screen height is 600. So that means zero
to 300 here, so we want the score to be right
around this part of the screen. And then it
gets pretty easy at this point is we use the
right method. So we want to write and when
the right player a. And now when the game
starts the score, of course is 02 spaces,
Player B, zero, comma, anywhere align equals
center that will center the text force around
that point. And then we want to choose a font.
You know, watch here, I've got an extra set
of parentheses here. Okay, don't forget that.
And I want the font courier that's kind of
old school techie. choose a font size of 24.
And normal I think normal I think you choose
bold and italics I'm 100% sure on that one.
So be very careful. Again, we've got a set
of parentheses here. I've got an extra set
of parentheses here for the font. So because
there's three arguments we got to send there,
okay, so now, test your code. Make sure This
is working. So I run that. Okay, so that's
what we wanted to see if red little space
after Player B. Hey, but yeah, that's that's
basically what we wanted. Okay, so that's
how we get the default score on the screen.
So what we got to do is we need to keep track
of the score. And so what I'm going to do,
and I'm going to put this up here, and score,
so I need to create a couple variables, I'm
going to call it score a, and we start the
game with a zero and score. B
is going to be zero. Now, down, down here,
okay, so we get a score when the ball goes
off the screen. So here's the right sides
of the ball goes off the right side, think
to yourself who gets a score, of course, that
is going to be Player A. So what I can do
is score a plus equals one that adds one to
player A's score. And by the same token, on
this on the other side, if the ball goes off
the left side of the screen, Player B, gets
Okay, so let's run that.
Oops. Okay, so nothing, we don't see any change.
Can you guess why? Okay. Now, if you said,
Well, we didn't update the score on the screen,
you'd be 100%. Correct. Okay, so what I'm
just going to do is I'm going to copy this
line here. And I'm going to put that into
here. And you'll see, what I got to do is
instead of the zeros, this is just print,
you know, basic printing, you know, one on
one, if you're not sure how to do that, I
do have a video on that somewhere. I'll try
to remember to link that below. But how printing
works. So we use the format method on our
string, and we want score a and score B is
what that does is put score a here and score
B there. So I'm going to make sure I'm using
spaces. I'm gonna copy that. And I'm pretty
sure this is correct. So basically, every
time I update the score, I need to update
the actual printed score on the screen or
the show's displayed spruce score, I should
say. So run that. Now, watch what happens
here. Okay, so you can see it did update.
Okay. But clearly something is wrong. Because
basically what it's doing is it's just printing
on top of itself. Okay. So what we have to
do is, before we do that call the right method,
we say pen clear. Now actually clear what's
on the screen. You know, it happens so fast
that you don't see it. But it actually it
does. So take my word for that one. Again,
if you're using pygame, or some other, you
know, framework or method, you might not have
to do this type of steps. But for the turtle
module, this is what you need to do. Okay,
so I'm going to run that. And let's watch
what happens. Okay, so Player A just got to
a point where we just got to a point, and
so on, and so forth. So, yeah, so basically,
we've got a pretty well working game here.
Again, the game never ends, you just go until,
you know until you give up and get bored,
which is pretty easy with Pong. So I've got
Yeah, I got another tutorial coming up on
this series, I'm gonna show you how to add
a little bit of sound, which is interesting,
especially depending on the operating system
that you are using, I'm going to show you
how to add a little bit of sound to your game.
So just basically, you know, what you need
to do to get started with that is you need
to have a sound, you need to have a sound
file. And what I've done is I have downloaded
this file from I forget the site now, but
it is balanced dot WAV and it's like kind
of a classic old school. Bouncing sound. You'll
hear it in a minute. Now, Python is generally
pretty cross platform. Basically everything
that we've done so far, it doesn't matter
which operating system you're using Linux,
Mac or Windows, everything works, the same.
Sound is one of those things where it doesn't
work the same. So right now I'm on a Mac,
and I'm going to show you how to do it on
a Mac and then I'll talk about how you would
do it then on Linux or Windows? Okay, so it's
a bit different. Okay. So the first thing
I had to point out is that the sound that
I found bounce dot WAV, and WAV files generally
are more compatible cross platform compatibility
isn't the exact same folder as my Python file.
So right now, I'm on Pong, seven, and Pong
sevens in there. So they are in the same folder.
That's a really important point. Now that
you can you work around that if you know what
you're doing. But for beginners, this is probably
the easiest way to do things. And so basically,
it's really simple. When do I want to play
a sound. And so I'm going to play a sound
when I having to put when I when the ball
either touches one of the borders, or bounces
off of the paddle. Okay, so in Mac, okay,
so I'm going to use something called the O
S. Module. And what that lets us do is basically
interact with the operating system through
text commands. And so I've imported o s, so
I can use that module. And then down here,
so what I can do is I can say, oh s that system,
that will do a system function call for us.
Now on Mac, it's a play
bounce.mp bounce dot w Av. So this is it.
This will play the sound when it hits the
border. Now there's, there's a problem here
and I'm gonna show you that in a second. But
again, let's test it. See what happens. Oops,
one throw away. The wait till it's the top.
I'll turn my volume up. Oops, sorry, my bad.
A play is for Linux, a f play is for Mac.
Let's try that again. Got that backwards.
I had a 5050 chance and I blew it. Okay, let's
listen. Now, did you notice that everything
stopped while that sound played? So watch
it again. Okay, that is not what we want to
happen. Okay. So to get around that, at the
end of this command, we need to add an ampersand.
That's the end symbol. Okay, so let's test
it.
And watch it will not delay. It says a little
bit, it's a little bit off. But that's you
know, neither here nor there, I suppose what
to do with that. Okay, I think actually, what
I would probably have to do is edit this,
this WAV sound is probably a little bit of
a blank space at the beginning of it. So that's
that's it on Mac. Okay, so let me copy that.
And let's say we want to play it when it bounces
the top, bottom and when it touches the paddles.
So we need to put, do that. Okay, so let's
test it. So again, I got it working once now
I just copy and paste. So it should bounce
here.
I'm terrible at Pong, apparently. Okay, now
you can choose different sounds, you have
one sound for when it bounces off the walls,
one sound for when it bounces off the paddle,
et cetera, et cetera. Okay? Now, if you are
a Linux user, the the system is very, very
similar. Instead of AF play, it's a play.
That's all you have to change. Okay, and for
Windows is a little bit different. Now, I
can't test it for you, but I can explain how
it works. And I do have a video that explains
this. And I'll try to remember to link that
down below. And basically, in Windows, instead
of importing o s, you import wind sound, which
is a little module that only exists on Windows.
And then when you want to play your sound,
instead of this oh s dot system stuff, you
would type win sound. dot play sound. Again,
pay attention to the capitalization, okay?
Small W, capital P, capital S, then in parentheses.
So don't need the ampersand here. But you
do need a comma, and then when sound not SMD
async. So what that does is that same thing
as adding the ampersand. that'll stop you
if it's asynchronous, it will play the sound
in the background. If it's not a synchronous
program, we'll stop. Again, I can't show it
to you because this is Mac but that should
should do it. So I'm gonna undo that and get
back to my system. Oops, somebody wanted to
Oh yeah. Keep going, Yeah, a play and it's
AF play, let's leave that. I'm gonna test
it one more time. And that is our Pong program.
Not the most exciting thing in the world.
But you know, you learn a lot of different
concepts, you know how to put objects on the
screen, how to move them with a keyboard,
how to detect collisions, update the score
on the screen, gaming loops, sounds. So basically
all the basic elements that you need to make
a game are included in Pong. That's why it's
one of the classics. And I remember playing
this as a child, it brings back some memories.
So let's just go ahead and get a look at what
this final product is going to look like.
So on like an x by x grid, so whatever you
want it to be, you have little snake moving
around, there's a snack is what I want to
call it that shows up and as you collect it,
it increases the length of the tail. And then
obviously, if you run into yourself, and I
just did that by clicking the back us going
forward, it gives you a little error message
here says, You ran into your tail, your length
was nine dot, whatever. And then you can continue
and play as long as you want. Anyways, what
I'm gonna be doing in here is I'm going to
be coding everything object oriented, I know
that there's a much faster and easier way
to do this doesn't really teach you that much.
This way, you're gonna learn a bit about objects,
but classes, how we can kind of work with
them. And you'll see like how the flow of
my program goes, and you should learn quite
a bit, especially if you're someone a beginner
programmer, what we're going to be using to
make this is module called pi game, if you
don't know about pi game, and you want to
learn about it, before you do this, I would
recommend that. Alright, so let's start coding.
So pretty much what I've done is I've just
set up the flow of the program, all the classes
and the function just to remind myself what
I need to write. And while I'm talking here,
it's probably good ideas, if you guys copy
this down, so we're gonna have, you're gonna
have two main objects, we're gonna have a
cube object and a snake object, and our snake
object is going to contain cube objects, if
that makes sense. So each one of those little
red squares it was moving around is a cube
object, and the whole thing is our snake object.
We're gonna have a few functions here, draw
grid, redraw window, random snack, messagebox,
and main. So let's get started with our main
function here. And this is what's going to
be our main loop. So essentially, what I need
for the main loop to start is we need to make
a surface so in pygame, to do this, we do
when equals pi game, dot display, dot set
underscore mode, and then I'm going to set
it. Let's see here, what do I want the height
to be? I say, width, and height like this.
Oops, that's fine. And I'm just gonna make
a variable here called width equals, height
equals, and we'll just set this to 500 by
500, like so. Now we need another variable,
I'm going to set this as rows can delete this
down here, it's gonna do something, we'll
do that later. And this is how many rows you're
gonna have what rows or columns, whatever,
you can set this to whatever you want, just
make sure it divides 500 evenly, otherwise,
you're gonna have like weird looking rows,
if you know what I mean. So I'm just gonna
set mine to 20. That's what I'm using the
other one. But if you want to make it harder,
set it to something like 10, and there won't
be as much room for the snake to move around,
and the games will go faster, pretty well.
Okay, next, what we need to do is we need
to set up a snake object. So I know that we
haven't even created like anything in the
snake class yet, but I'm gonna do s equals
snake. And I'm just gonna give it a position.
So in this case, we want to use a color Sorry,
just gonna be red, because red, green, blue,
255 for red, and then I'm gonna give the position
we're gonna start in the middle. So I'm going
to start at 1010. Now let's move into our
main loop. So I'm just gonna say, well, flag,
create my variable here, flag equals true.
And then we're just gonna start by doing a
pygame tic, so pi game dot time dot delay.
50, like so. And that's just gonna delay us,
I want to say, like point five or 50 milliseconds,
every time so that our program doesn't run
too fast. I'm also going to create this clock,
tick on to put that at 10. And what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna create a clock object up here.
And this is a built in thing in PI game. And
what this is going to do is I'll explain in
just one second once I finish typing it pi
game, clock, I believe it is, oops, time clock,
like so. So what this clock tick is actually
going to do is it's going to make sure that
our game doesn't run more than 10 frames per
second. So that would mean essentially that
our snake would be able to move like 10 blocks
in one second. And again, we don't want it
to be that fast. So that's why we're also
delaying by like a few milliseconds here.
If you put this too low. Then again, it's
going to move to Oh, you can play Round with
the speed, this is kind of what I found was
the best speed. And it may vary depending
on what machine you're on, it shouldn't, it
might. So you might want to just change these
numbers. Again, the lower this goes is, the
faster it's going to be. And the lower this
one goes is, the slower it's going to be.
So they're kind of inversely proportional
like that. Alright, next, what are we going
to do here, I'm just going to call redraw
window.
And I butchered that so bad, oops, redraw
window like so I'm just going to give it a
surface, which is in this case going to be
when that we've created up here. And for now,
that's all I'm going to put in my main loop
here. And we'll move more into that once I
start coding some other stuff. Okay, so now
that we have our redraw window being called
here, I'm going to go and I'm going to start
coding our redraw window. So what this is
essentially going to do is we first need to
update the display. So pygame display dot
update, like so. And we also need to draw
the grid. So we're going to do draw grid,
we're going to pass it out same surface that
we were given, and move on from that, we're
also going to fill the screen. So when Phil,
in this case, I'm just gonna use block 6000.
And there we are, that's all we need to do
right now. But essentially, we're also going
to need to draw the snake, we're gonna need
to draw a few other things on the screen.
That will we'll get to later. Okay, so draw
grid, let's move into this one. Now, what
we need to do here is draw a grid, which is
pretty easy to do. So what we do is we were
given rows and surface. So it's probably a
good idea, if I actually passed in the rows
and the surface. So I'm just going to global
them here so that I can reference them, I
think this is going to work well the global
rows and width, like that. And here, we also
need to make these global just because I don't
want to pass them. And every time I draw a
grid, we're just gonna say width. And rows,
and this height variable is actually not necessary,
because we are just gonna draw a square, like
a square surface every time. So we can just
make this the same, we don't need two variables
for width and height width are going to contain
the same number anyway, so global width and
rows, I go here, draw a grid, given with rows
and surface. So now we're gonna put in, well,
first we're gonna put our rows are oops, width,
row, and surface like that. Okay, so that
should be working. Now, in here, what we first
need to do when we're drawing a grid, is we
want to figure out how big each square in
the grid is going to be. Because what we're
going to do is we're going to just draw lines
going down and across, but we need to figure
out where to draw those lines. So we have
to figure out kind of like the gap between
each of the lines. So the way we do that,
I'm just gonna create a variable here size
between is equal to our width, integer divided
by our rows. This is just so that we don't
get like large decimal numbers, because that
we cannot pass into our draw line method in,
in Python. Okay, so now I'm just gonna create
X variable, and Y variable. And I'm going
to set these to zero, let's say for L, in
range. And this just standing for line pretty
well, in rows, like that. Now, what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna increment my x by the size
between, I'm going to increment my y by the
same, so y equals y plus size between can
get rid of one of the spaces here. Okay, there
we go. And now we're simply just going to
draw two lines. So to draw a line in pygame,
all we have to do is pygame dot draw dot line.
And the argument that takes is a surface,
we need a color in this case is going to be
white. So you 250 by 255 255 foot white, we're
going to draw x zero comma x w, and I'll go
through this in just one second. What this
does, and I'm just gonna copy this and draw
one more and then explain how this is going
to work pretty well. Okay, so now we need
zero, y, and
w, y. Okay? So what this is going to do is
this is going to draw two lines for us every
loop of this for loop. And these arguments
here is the start position of the line and
the end position of the line. So the first
line that we want to draw is going horizontal,
which means we don't want to change the y
value at all. So what we need to do is we
need to find the x and then we're going to
put y at zero, because we're going to be at
the top. I think that's right at least Oh
sorry, this this line is being drawn down
not being drawn to the right, I was getting
confused. Okay, so we're going to change the
x, but we're going to keep the Y at zero.
And then we're going to stay at that same
x and we're going to keep the Y at the width
of the screen so that we're going far enough
down then same thing here, this one is going
horizontal, excuse me, I messed that up before.
So our x is always going to stay at zero.
And our y is going to be what's changing as
we draw a horizontal line across the screen.
I hope that makes sense to everyone how that
works. Anyways, I'm going to move on from
that. And that's all we need for the drug
grid function. So just go ahead, I probably
made a mistake here, but we'll run the program
to see if everything's working. Good now named
when is not the find window fill. So I've
called this when one really needs to be surface
like that. So let's try now. And there we
go, we get a nice little grid on our screen
like so 20 by 20. grid. There we are. So now,
let's move into another function, or actually,
let's start coding on the classes here. So
like I was talking about before, we're gonna
have a snake object, which is going to contain
a bunch of cube objects. So essentially, what
we're gonna do is we're gonna have a list
of cubes. And that's going to be known as
the snake body. So let's go ahead and write
that in. Now, what I want to do for that is
just create a list. So we're just gonna say
body is equal to and then a blank list. I'm
also just while we're already up here, in
creating a class variable, I'm going to create
turns, is equal to, and it's just gonna be
the set of squiggly brackets here that we'll
we'll get into in a bit. Okay, so now that
we're already in the snake function, what
we need to do is we just need to define our
parameters here that were passed. So we're
just gonna say self dot color, equals color,
self dot equals cube, which I'll get into
in a second, given the position, say self
dot, body, dot, append our head, self dot
head, like this. So what we're doing here
now is we're saying Okay, so the head of our
snake, which is going to be important, because
we need to know where that is at all time.
So we can move accordingly, is equal to a
cube at the given position. And the given
position is what we pass in here, as like
the starting position of our snake. Or we
create a new snake, like we'd have multiple
snakes moving around. And anyways, that's
the position. Now we're saying we're going
to append to the body, this head. So now this
is in our list here. And then we can go through
that list. And we can draw things, we can
move it, we can check things, we want all
of our cubes to be ordered within this list.
So that's why I'm putting that in first. Now,
I'm just going to give this one which is called
turn x is equal to zero, and turn y, which
is equal to one. So what this is going to
do is we have a direction for x and a direction
for y for moving our snakes, obviously, these
are going to be a value like negative one,
one, or zero, and that's going to be the same
for y and x. If y or x is equal to one, negative
one, then the other one is going to be equal
to zero because you can only be moving in
one direction at the same time. And this is
just going to keep track of what direction
we're moving in. And we'll use this in the
next function that we're going to code, which
is our move function. So moving is pretty
straightforward, at least in terms of just
if you have one object moving around the screen,
getting it to go left straight, right, but
when you have the snake object, it has to
turn at certain points. So when I click left,
the rest of the snake is still moving forward,
once it reaches the point where the head turned
left, then it has to turn left. So that's
where things can get a bit complicated. Anyways,
to start, what I'm going to do is say for
event in PI game, by the end of my typing
here, pi game, dot event dot gets like so.
And that we're just gonna say if events dot
type equals equals pi game, dot quit this,
and this is the first one we always want to
code in. Because we want to make sure that
if they click that little red arrow, it actually
works. And we can quit going to pi game dot
quit like that. And I'm just gonna say if,
actually, we don't even need another F, because
the way I'm going to do this is this other
way you might have seen in PI game before
to move things around use, like if event dot
type equals key down, and then you just check
which key was pressed and move to the left.
This is a similar thing, but it works smoother.
I've used both of them a lot. And this is
what I prefer. So I'm just going to use this.
So pygame dot key dot get underscore press.
So this is going to do is it's going to get
a list. Actually, I think it's like a dictionary
or something like that, that has all the key
values. And then if they were pressed or not.
So that way, if you press more than one key
at once, when you're looping through, it'll
adjust to that. Whereas the other one, you
can only click one at a time and you couldn't
move like per se diagonally if you're moving
like a character at the screen. Doesn't matter
too much for this, but this is the way I like
to do it. So now I'm gonna say four key in
keys. Because remember, this is going to give
us all of the keys and then like one or zero
value if they were clicked or not. So we need
to loop through all of them and check if keys
and then pygame dot key or uhq stuff dot k
underscore left. Thought it was key there.
And then we say keys by game dot k underscore
rights Like that, and we can continue down
here with up and down. And then we'll get
into exactly what is going to happen when
we click these keys. So last one here.
Alright, and there we go. Okay. So now what
we're going to do is we're going to change
the direction according to what key we click.
So for going left, that means that our x has
to be negative because the way again coordinates
work in pygame is in the top left hand corner
of your screen is 00. So if we want to be
moving left, we should be making our x negative
to move more towards zero, right? If we want
to move right, though, you make our x positive,
which would be one in this case, because we're
just gonna move one cube at a time to go further
to the right. Same thing with the Y, it's
kind of weird in pygame, how the Y works,
because the more y you add, the further down
you go. So what do we say for x, we're gonna
say self love journey, x equals negative one,
again, because we left and we're gonna set
our journ y equal to zero. And this is because
again, we don't want to be moving in two directions
at once and be going diagonal. Now, this is
what I was talking about, it's we need to
remember where we actually turned. Because
if you just have one cube in the ground, that's
fine. But when you have multiple cubes, we
need to be to turn left, right, we need to
remember where we turned, so at the tail of
our cube can turn at that point. So that's
why we have that self dot turns list up, you're
just as turns, I want to say, dictionary or
set, whatever. So we're gonna add to that,
itself that turns, and we're gonna give it
a new key. I'll go through how this works
in a second self dot pause here, is equal
to, and then we're gonna give just a list
of self dot exe, and self dot dir and why.
Okay, so you might be kind of confused on
what's going on here. So I've created a new
dictionary up here, that's what I'm going
to call it officially, you could think of
it as a set as well. And pretty much, we're
going to add a key, which is the current position
of the head of our snake. And then it's going
to be set equal to what direction we turned.
So we're saying we have a new turn at this
position, and our character where our snake
moved left, so it's gonna say we have self
doctrine y, which is right here is negative
one self.or surf, don't turn x or then turn
y is equal to zero, so we know what way we
actually turned. And I hope that makes sense.
That's, that's how we're gonna do that. Now,
I'm just gonna copy and paste these and then
change these values. So when we're going right,
this is going to be one. Oops, same thing
here. So put that in, this is going to be
zero, and turn y we're going off is going
to be negative one. Now when we're going down,
we need to change this to one and this to
zero, and I'm just gonna get rid of that.
And there we go. Okay, so that is pretty much
how we go about doing this. And I can also
just put LS here as well, because we don't
want to be able to move in more than one direction.
So we're going to prioritize the left arrow
key. If they're not clicking the left arrow
key, then we'll check they're doing the right
otherwise up otherwise down, because we don't
want them to be able to click More than one
key at once. Okay, so next, we need to actually
move our cube. And this is where it gets a
little bit more tricky in terms of looking
where our cube is. And if it's at that turn,
then we're going to turn it. So I'm just gonna
start coding and I'm kind of going to go through
exactly what I do. So before I see in a numerate,
oops. And I spelt that wrong. Like that, and
the version, say self dot body, because we're
going to look through the list of positions
that we have in on stake and then say, P equals
seat up position. And I'm just going to copy
this. By the way, that's what this little
arrow does here, it just makes a copy so that
we're not changing the position of our snake.
When we do things, it's just just follow along
with it's not super important. Okay, so we're
gonna say if p is in self dot turns, like
this, because remember, what we did is we
added the position of our head, two turns.
So now we're going to say, Well, if this position
is in the turns, then we're going to move
or we're going to turn right, so let's say
here, when say, turn, oops, equals self dot
turns. Like that. So now we've seen that it's
in there. So now it's in there, we can find
the index of it and we can grab the direction
value so we know what way we're gonna be moving.
And average can say C dot move, like this,
and turn zero, turn, one, like so. Okay, now
Next, I'm going to say if i equals equals
the length of self dot body, minus one
Oops, then I'm gonna do self run away, that's
capital stuff, but turned dot pop. Okay, so
I know I just did a lot of coding here. And
this probably doesn't make a lot of sense
to you guys. So I'm going to kind of run through
exactly what I just did. It's, it's pretty,
it's a little bit difficult to explain. So
anyways, what we start off by doing is we're
gonna say, we're gonna get the index, and
we're going to get the cube object in our
self dot body, because remember, our self
dot body is made up of cube objects right
here, that have these properties, right, they're
gonna have a direction y direction, x, a start
color, so on, and we're gonna get, we're gonna
get to coding cube in just a second. So there
are cube objects. Now all of these cube objects
have a position. So I'm saying for each object
here, I'm going to grab their position. And
I'm going to see if that position is in our
turn list. And we create the term list and
add to the turn list. When we turn right,
when we click left, center, right, so on,
and then we're gonna say, Okay, so the actual
turn, so where we're actually going to be
moving is equal to that all the turns list
at that index, right, so we grab the turn
direction, x and direction y, which we stored
there. And now we're gonna just gonna say,
our cube dot move, which is another method
that we're going to code, and we're giving
it that direction, x and that direction y,
so it knows what weight it needs to move pretty
well. And then I say, if i is equal to the
length of self dot body minus one, so that
means if we are on the last cube, we're going
to remove that turn. So once that last cube
hits that turn, we're going to remove it,
because if we were just to leave that turn
in the list, that would mean any time you
hit that position on the screen, regardless
of if the snake was turning there or not,
you'd automatically change directions, if
you don't remove it from the list. hope that
makes sense. Okay. Now, also after this, if
you were gonna say if the, what do you call
it if it's not in the list. So if our position
is not in the list, we still need to move
the snake, because it's constantly moving.
So what do we do to this? Well, we write an
else. And I'm just gonna copy this in, because
it's going to take a second to type because
I have another file open. And I'll go through
what happened, how this works, okay? No, it
looks like a lot. But pretty much. What this
is doing for us is we're checking whether
or not we've reached the edge of the screen
for saying, if we're moving left, and the
position, so the exposition of our cube is
less than or equal to zero, then we're going
to change that position so that it goes to
the right side of the screen. So the way that
we can do that is by saying c dot rows minus
one, because again, if you start counting
at zero, and computers, so if our rows is
like 20, then the last cube would be 19 in
a list, right? They see that rows minus one,
and we're gonna be at the same y value. So
we'll leave that there. Okay, and then we
say, otherwise, we're gonna check if we're
going right for moving right. And same thing,
if we're at the edge of the screen, move back
to the left side by putting zero here. And
the next one, if we're going down, what we're
going to be doing is, again, checking, are
we less than rows minus one or greater than
rows minus one? No, we're not. Or if we are,
then let's move us back up to the top of the
screen by changing our y value. And then same
thing here, if you're moving upwards. Now,
if none of that's true, so we're not at the
edge of the screen, we're not moving up left
down to whatever I just said, then we're just
simply going to move our cube at the direction
x and the direction y of that cube already.
So if that cube is moving upwards, and it's
not turning, and it's not going to the edge
of the screen, it doesn't need to be changed.
Just keep moving it in whatever direction
it's going. And that's why I'm simply referencing
the cubes already existing direction, x and
direction, why we're not changing anything,
we're simply just saying, Okay, let's move
you forward one, like that. I hope that makes
sense. That was a lot and that's probably
one of the hardest things in this program
is figuring out the movement of the steak.
So if you guys understand that, then that
is the hard part kind of over with and we're
gonna get into this cube objects, you're gonna
understand what all this means and how our
rows and columns kind of work and stuff. Okay,
so I'm just gonna forget about resetting od
q for now because we'll worry about those
later. But let's get into the draw method
because want to see if there's actually working
and put this on the screen. So simply for
I see a numerate plug in outselling numerate
today, like that. Same thing, self dot body,
like that. We're gonna say if i equals equals
zero, c dot draw, and you'll see why it is
in a second. True.
Else c dot draw surface. So the reason I'm
doing this little check here, rather than
just drawing every object is because when
we draw the first snake object onto if you
remember my other program, it had eyes. So
what I would simply want to do is make sure
That when we draw that first object, we add
eyes onto it just so we know where the head
of the snake is. We don't get confused, like
what directions are having. And although you
shouldn't we, I want to add a little is maybe
just for aesthetic as well. So what this true
does optional parameter simply says draw eyes
if it's the first one in our list like that,
if it's the head, and then in this draw method,
you can see I have is equals to false. But
when you make it equal to true, we're going
to do a special thing in here that's going
to draw eyes for us. Okay, so now that we've
coded this, this whole mess of stuff in the
snake class, let's just run the program quickly
and see if anything's happening. So currently,
we just have the grid, we don't have any errors
or anything. That's because we haven't drawn
the snake object onto the screen yet. So what
we need to do is we just need to do simply
do s dot draw it within our redraw window
here. So I'm just going to type I'm going
to global s here on global it down there as
well. Because say s dot draw, like that. And
we need to give a surface. So let's give it
a surface, and I'm going to global s so that
we can reference it there. And is there a
reason why we aren't being drawn to the screen?
Let's just have a look quickly. Start draw.
Start draw Oh, it's because yes, we are indeed
trying Yes, but we haven't drawn any of the
cube objects yet. And it is calling the draw
method on all of our cube objects, which we
haven't yet created. Hopefully, that makes
sense. But we'll go ahead and do that now.
So we have to code a little bit more before
we can see everything. So let's just go ahead
and get into the cube object. And let's just
say self dot start, people start, except I'm
actually just gonna change this to position
because I believe this is what it's supposed
to be. And we're gonna say self, during x
equals one, self dot y is equal to zero, and
self color, is equal to color. And the reason
we have this is because we're going to be
drawing later what I want to call it a snack
for the, for the cube to collect for the snake
to collect on. So we want to change the color
with that. And I've spelled it wrong, like
three times during extender and why the reason
I have done x your set to one initially, is
because I want to make sure that we start
moving in a direction. If I had this at zero,
you'd have to click a key before the snake
starts moving, but I want right when we run
the program for the snake to just start moving,
so I'm setting it already with a direction
x. And the reason these are optional, again,
is so that when we create a new cue object,
we don't have to implicitly say direction
x is one direction y zero, because it's assumed
that it's always going to be like that, unless
otherwise stated. Okay, let's have a look.
What else do we need to do here, we need to
now code this new function, which actually
really easy I'm gonna do is we're gonna say,
since we're changing the direction x in the
direction y in our snake class, we need to
do that in here so that it stays with the
object, let's say during x equals
x.
And then same thing, so thought, during y
equals getting y, like that. And then we'll
go down here, and all we're going to do is
going to change our position. So self dot
position, is equal to self dot pose zero,
which is our already existing position plus
self dot, drag x. And they're saying self
dot, part one, which is our already existing
y value, plus equals self dot journey one
like that. And just in case, I haven't mentioned
it here, right, we're working with a grid
system of 20 rows in this instance. So when
I say something like, if our self deposition
is like one, three, or 1010, I'm saying we're
in the 10th row and the 10th call, I'm not
saying the x value is equal to 10. And the
y value is equal to 10. Because it's not in
the case of drawing on the screen, because
our screen is actually a width of 500 pixels.
But just where we are in the grid, which is
most important to us right now, is equal to
like that values like 1435. So on that just
just to make that clear for anyone who might
have been confused. Okay, so now for drawing.
So a little bit harder, just because of what
I mentioned as well, is the fact that we need
to figure out the distance between each x
value and each y value. So when we're drawing
something in pygame, it draws in the top left
hand corner of the object. So if we draw a
cube, we're drawing that in the top left.
So we need to figure out what that x and y
value is going to be for each cube when we're
drawing to the screen. So I'm just gonna call
this gap here that is gonna be our distance.
And then we have same thing self dot w, y
self dot rows. And we're gonna change W and
rows down in our program later, but we can
actually just type it in now. Like this 502
100 just so we have that set. Okay, so self
dot w, answer divided by self dot rows. Again,
that's the same thing we did when we were
drawing the grid to figure out the distance
between our x and y values. Okay, we're gonna
say i is equal to self dot pause. Yeah, I
was gonna say is a bit of typing in our function
here, or in our method, just say j dot self
dot paws one. So we're just saying I, which
stands for row j stands for column, like a
classically convention for it, so that we
don't have to keep typing pause zero plus
one when we move. Okay, so the next one, next
thing we need to do is no draw rectangle,
you're gonna say pygame dot draw dot rect,
like this. And then we need a surface, we
need to cover so self color, and then we need
a rect. And here is a little bit of math.
I'm just gonna type it and I'll go through
exactly what what it goes j multiplied by
this plus one, dispose to this question. Okay,
so the reason I have these little plus ones,
and these minus twos here is just so you can
still see the grid when we draw the rectangle.
Because if we were to draw with exactly the
dimensions of this distance, then what would
end up happening is we'd cover the white lines
of the grid, and it just looks kind of weird
if you can't see the white lines. So that's
why I have plus one, added here and minus
two just so we're drawn inside of the circle,
or inside of the square a little bit. And
you'll see that in a second. So what I'm simply
doing is I'm multiplying my I value, which
is going to be my current like row column
by the distance that we need to get to the
next one. And then same thing for J. And then
this will add ones minus twos, it's just to
make sure that we stay inside. So a quick
quick example, if you don't understand is
say we're in a position 00. so r is zero and
r j zero. We're going to say, I multiplied
by distance, let's say distances, like 40.
Okay, so zero multiplied by 40 00, multiplied
by 40, zero, so our position is 00. And that's
correct. Because if we're drawing in the top
left hand corner here, and we're in position
00, then that's where we should draw again,
if you go something like zero 10, and you
are you move down, I guess so 10, you moving
wide down, you're gonna say zero miles distance
zero, and you're gonna say 10, multiplied
by distance, let's say it's 40, then we move
to that correct position down the screen.
So this is rectangle x, y, width, height.
Okay, make sense. Now, the next thing we need
to do is when to draw the eyes. Now you can
skip this part, if you want, I'm just going
to copy it in because it's a little bit of
math to make it them like perfectly aligned
on the square.
But yeah, so we say, if eyes are saying our
center is equal to distance modulates two,
because that's going to be the center, obviously,
or much. So we're saying divided by two is
gonna be the middle of our cube. And we're
saying the radius, that's how big the eye
radius is going to be. And then we go through
a little bit of math here. So circle middle
is going to be high multiplied by distance
plus center minus radius. And then we're finding
out the x. And this is just like a random
x that I'm setting by just putting it eight
pixels up, like every time because I don't
want to calculate the X. I don't feel like
doing that. And then I'm drawing two circles,
based on circle, middle one, circle, middle
two, and then the radius and a color of black,
or color of white, actually, sir, or no, that's
black. I'm confused. Alright. Anyways, with
all that being said and done, and you guys
probably pretty confused, right? Now, let's
just run and see if anything's actually happening.
And you can see we have a cube in the middle
of the screen. Yeah, so that's all we've done
with all this coding. so far is drawn a cube.
So actually, not quite, because we still,
all we have to do now simply to start having
that queue move and seeing our key presses
work is just do a little bit in the main loop.
So let's move down to the main loop now, and
have a look here what we need to do. Okay,
so what I'm going to do is I'm simply just
going to call a stop move, which is our snake
object every time this main loop runs. And
what this will allow us to do is I want to
call this before I read your window is it's
going to go up to that method and snake, it's
going to check every time that we run the
loop, if a key has been pressed, if it has,
we're going to move accordingly. And remember
that in this move loop here, it moves all
of the objects for us. So it moves all those
cube objects. And then we're just drawing
the grid redrawing everything in this redraw
function, so it'll just display that and update
that to the screen. So let's see here. And
we get an error tuple object is not callable.
self dot pose. 0% that there next. Alright,
one second guys. Oh, it's because I used curl.
Okay, so apparently, I'm an idiot. And I forgot
to add an equal sign here. So the issue was
simply that this looked something like this,
that I changed it to square brackets, when
all I needed to do was put an equal sign like
this. And now we should be up and running.
So to reiterate, the line here is that the
issue is, you guys probably saw this when
I coded it, to be honest, is in move in cube,
it's near the top of the program, all you
have to do is change this add an equal sign
between this like the bracket and the pause.
So now that we run it, we can see that we
have a moving object, and that we can move
up, down, left, right, etc. so on and so forth,
like that. Okay. So play around with that
for a second. And now we'll get into adding
cubes. And we're actually almost done, we
just need to add that add cube function messagebox
little bit in the main loop, and that will
be finished. Okay, so what we need to do now
is, that's all great, we're moving around,
but we need to add stuff to our cube, right?
Like we need to progress the game. So to do
this, we are going to generate what I want
to call a random snack that we're going to
place on the screen that our snake can eat.
So the way that we do this, I'm just gonna
say, positions equals item, dot body. And
this item, oops, shouldn't be items should
be item is just going to be a snake object.
I don't know why I'm calling an item, but
that's what I'm calling it. And we're simply
just going to set like a new list equal to
that list. So okay, so now we're gonna say,
well, tree,
capital T,
we're gonna do x equals random dot random
range. If you haven't imported random yet,
make sure you do that. And y equals random
dot Rand range. rows. And rows, again, should
be global. So let's make sure that this works
global rows. And after this, we're gonna say
if I don't know how I just typed that, but
the length of and I'm doing something fancy
here, and I'll explain what this does in a
second.
Okay, so I know I just typed this stuff that
probably makes absolutely no sense, you guys,
if you haven't been using Python for a little
bit, but pretty much what this is going to
do is we're going to get a list of a filtered
list. And we're going to see if any of the
positions are the same as like the current
position of the snake pretty well. So what
we're doing is we're saying that, we want
to make sure that we're not going to put a
snack on top of the snake. Because if we have
a really long snake, the chance of that happens
is actually somewhat high. And I didn't do
this when I first coded the game. So what
happened is, when you have your snake moving
around the screen, all of a sudden the snake
could pop up, but it's like on the tail of
the snake, which you don't want. So what this
is doing, and just type it out, you don't
really have to understand it is we're saying
this, this means a function, Zed, and we're
just checking if this Zed dot position is
equal to x, y. So if it's equal to x, y, which
is the position we just generated, here, by
getting two random numbers, x and y, then
we're gonna have to do this again. So we say,
continue. And else we break like that, and
then I'm just gonna simply gonna return in
the tupple, or to go where you want to call
it x, y. Okay, so this is confusing. But um,
you can do this in like a much longer way
with a for loop, where you pretty much loop
through every position in this list, you check
it against x and y, you see if it's the same,
if it's the same, then do this loop again.
Otherwise, you break and you return x, y,
that's all we're doing in there to generate
a random set. And it messagebox you gonna
leave that and in here, now, what we're good.
Okay, so now that I've created this, this
random snack function, what I need to do is
I need to use it. So I'm just going to create
a new object, and we're going to call this
snack. And it's going to be equal to another
cube, right, because we want to have the same
functionality want to build, draw it, possibly
move it around, right, so we're just going
to create a new cube object, we're going to
give it a position of a random stock, which
is going to select this random stack. And
the random stack, I believe, oh, it takes
a row in an item. So what we're gonna do is
we're gonna give it row rows, and we'll just
give it our item, which is gonna be s. And
then after that, what else do we need for
cube, I don't think we actually need anything
else, I think that's all we need, oh, I'm
gonna change the color. That's what I want
to do. But I changed the color equal to green.
So red, green, blue, 255 for green. So that
shows up and is visible on the screen. And
now what I'm going to do down here in this
while loop is I'm going to say, snack, I'm
going to check if our the head of our snake
has hit the stack. And if it has, we're going
to add another part to the body of the snake.
Otherwise, we're not going to do that right,
and then we're going to generate a new snack
and so on, we're going to just gonna say if
s dot body zero dot pause, and this is going
to be the head, right, because we haven't
ordered I don't need those brackets is equal
to snack dot pause. And remember, these are
both cube objects, that's works fine because
we're going to be tuples. Then what we're
going to do is we're simply going to say s
dot add cube, which is a method that we have
there that we haven't actually written yet.
And we're gonna say snack is now equal to
well, a new cube. So I'm just gonna copy this
and paste it here. So All we're doing is now
generating a new cube for snack, I'm sure
I could put something in that, like change
it, but this is just the way that works. Okay,
so now that we've done that, we should be
able to move around the screen and get the
snack. But we need to code in the Add snack
method here, which I believe I have here or
add cube. So the odd cube is pretty straightforward,
we just have to figure out where we're adding
that snack, or wherever adding that cube,
I don't know why I keep calling it snack to
the list. So what we're gonna do is we're
gonna figure out where the tail is. And we
want to add it after that tail. So tail is
equal to self dot body, negative one, the
last element in that list, we're gonna say
dx d y, which again, is going to be a direction
extraction, I'm just shorting it, shortening
it here, it's gonna be tailed during x, and
tail dot during y, like this. Now, again,
you could do this in two lines, I'm just doing
it like this because it's faster. And now
I'm going to copy something in and we're just
go through exactly what this does. Okay, so
pretty much this looks complicated. But all
it's going to be doing is checking what direction
that we're currently moving in, like the head
of the keyboard or the tail actually, of the
cube is moving in. So that we can then make
sure that when we add that cube, we know where
to add it. So for adding it like to the right
of the cube to the left of the cube above
it below it, and we can give it the correct
direction to be moving. So pretty much
what we do here is we just say we're going
to append a new cube to our body. And its
position if we're moving to the right, which
and here we are, because the x equals one
is one less than the x position of that tail.
So whatever the last cube is one less than
that. And that's so that we don't add a cube
per se to the right when we're moving to the
right. And then we're just going to have overlapping
cubes and you're not getting to see them right.
Same thing down here, for moving down. That
means are not down sorry, for moving left,
that means we need to add the cube to the
right side. So one plus the tail of the expedition
of the tail of the cube or of the snake sorry,
so that we can have it in the proper position,
right and same thing here with x and y, or
with y so that we're moving up or moving down
when we add it above. Otherwise, we move we
put it below. So I just stumbled through that,
because there was a lot of different words
are very similar. Anyways, what we need to
do now is simply set the direction for that
cube so that we added it in, if we just left
it like that, you wouldn't be moving any words,
we just need to change that to the current
direction of that tail. So whatever the tail
is moving, that's where this new cube is going
to be moving in that direction. So we're going
to say self dot body, negative one dot x equals
dx. And then same thing down here, except
we're just gonna change this to y, then y
equals d y, and not again, it's just the where
our tail is moving at the current moment.
Okay, so now that we've got all that done,
it's time to see what syntax error we get.
Next name, Rose is parameter and global. One
second. So I've actually never even ran into
that error, oh, global rows as, okay, so let's
just make this our, and let's change this
to be one second, we can just get rid of this.
And this should work. There we go. So now
move around like this, the only issue is our
snack is not being generated on the screen.
And I don't know why that is exactly happening.
Oh, it's because we're not drawing the snack.
That's what so now, global snack up here believe
that's what I called it. And I'm simply just
gonna say snack dot drop, like that. And I
gotta give it a surface. So let's give a surface
Let's run. And air named snack is not fine,
because I didn't global down here. So let's
go with that.
Okay, so now we have the slack on the screen.
And you can see that when we collect it, we
have that cube added to the end of our snake.
And that pretty much is almost the game done.
So all we need to do now is right, that reset
method. And then we need to just simply check
like when we lose a great another snake can
go through each other through itself. And
you can see we have a huge error when the
snake can cook through itself. So we need
to make sure that when we hit ourselves, we
like end the game and we need to write that
message with this method as well. So to do
this, again, I'm just gonna copy in this for
loop, and then we'll kind of go through go
from there. So let's move in here. Okay, so
for x and range, the length of s dot body,
we're gonna say s dot body x, which is going
to be we're looping through every cube in
our snake body. We're checking if the position
is in a list of all the positions. After that
works. That's how we're checking the collision.
If you want to do it. Your Own Way, go ahead.
But this is the way that I like to do. Okay,
so now what I'm going to do is I just want
to print to the console, like their score,
just so that I would just say score. Oops.
And that will say plus is the length of s
dot body. But this is going to have to be
converted to a string unless I put a comma
like that. So let's just do it like that.
And then I'm going to simply display a message
box will say, message box, like this message
underscore box, we have a subject and we have
content. And we'll, we'll do that in just
a second because I haven't yet actually coded
that. And then we're going to reset our snake
by just doing str reset, and this is going
to take a position, which is going to be our
starting position again, 1010. And then we're
going to break out of this for loop. Because
if we collided once, we don't really care
if we collide it again, and go back, and we
continue the game with a snake that has length
one. Okay, so our reset on this is pretty
straightforward. All I'm doing in this reset,
is I'm just gonna get rid of our terms, I'm
gonna get rid of our body. And I'm just gonna
change like the direction x and the direction
y. So maybe it's faster by just copy down,
and you guys can just copy this out. So pretty
much all I'm doing is I'm setting a new head,
which is going to be equal to, again, like
whatever position we given because we can
move it at a different position if we wanted
to. I'm clearing self dot body, which is again,
a class variable here. And then I'm adding
head, I'm setting turns equal to blank direction
x zero direction, y is set to one against
that we start moving. And you can see, it's
pretty much exactly what I have typed out
here, except I'm just resetting the turns
list. Okay, so now that we've done that, all
we need to do code is messagebox. So this
one's pretty easy. Um, you can see up here,
just in case you haven't looked yet, I import
t kinter, st K, and then from G kintra. Import
message box. Now this is how you create a
message box in pygame. And this is how you
create one that actually shows up on top of
the screen. And that doesn't like float kind
of below it or doesn't show up right away
if you want to see that. So just watch this
is extremely useful to use in other programs
too, if you if you copy up this function,
and then you just drag it into other
attributes.
topmost column true, what this simply does
is we're creating a root oops, which is not
root dot t gates route equal to tk.tk, which
is going to be a new TK enter window, we're
making sure that this window is going to be
on top of anything. So if we have like a bunch
of different windows open, it just comes up
on top, which is what we want. I'm just going
to simply make this window now invisible.
And I'll explain how this works in a second.
And then from this message box, what do you
call it method, class, whatever. It's gonna
say message box dot show info. And then we're
gonna do subject and content. And this just
takes it takes a few more parameters as well
if you want, but pretty much this just shows
info, given whatever subject we type in and
whatever content we have. And now I'm going
to say try
group dot
destroy like that. Except groups. And don't
ask me what this does, because honestly, I
don't know. But it just works. So pretty much
it shows his message books. And I'm actually
pretty sure the way that this works is it
constantly keeps trying to destroy the message
box until eventually you click the X button
and then it actually can, I think it's like
something like that. So anyways, that's how
you create a message box. And with that we
all we need to do is add a subject and contents
on inside you lost. And our message will be
play again. Let's run the program for the
last time and make sure everything's working.
So there we go. I just need to get my snake
to a length that is large enough to the point
where I can actually hit myself. Okay, and
there we go. So pretty much we ran into an
error. What is the error I spelt attributes
wrong? That is lovely error to run into. Let's
run back up here. Attributes attributes attributes.
Where'd I even make this function? I must
have scrolled path it there we go. And I believe
that's correct. Let's try this go so I'm actually
just gonna go see if I can There we go. Okay,
so we get a message says you lost plugin and
the reason I died there by the way is because
while I was moving right, I moved left So
technically, the head of my snake actually
ran into another part of it so it says you
last play again. And you can make that say
exactly what you want and then we can see
that our guy just continues to move so on.
So anyways, if you guys want to see more content
like this, go check out my channel it is named
tech with Tim and I'd have a bunch of videos
teaching stuff like pygame and doing a bunch
of Python tutorials you guys will definitely
learn a lot falling through some my videos
and I would be very grateful if you guys went
over there and like some My videos and subscribe.
What's up guys, in this set of videos I'm
going to show you how to program Connect for
in Python. By the end of these videos, we'll
build something that looks like this. It's
a simple two player Connect for game with
graphics, I think this is a really good exercise
for your beginner to intermediate level Python
programmers who want to build their skills.
I'll just finish up a game real quick, just
so you can see how this fully works. As you
can see out of the diagonal, and it says player
one wind school. Alright, so more specifically,
In this first video, we're going to do something
a little bit simpler, and then build up to
that graphic based Connect for game. So by
the end of this specific video, you'll have
something that looks like this. It's a command
line Connect for game where you actually manually
type in numbers to drop your pieces, you see
the one there, two, etc. Alright, so let's
start building that. Just quickly, I want
to mention that I'll be programming in Python
three. And then using Sublime Text two as
my editor, I posted a link to a video on how
to set up these things in the description.
So one of the first questions I asked myself
when I was writing this game is what is the
best way to represent the board. So if I drag
in a Connect for board real quick, you can
see that it is six rows by seven columns.
And to me, this looks like the perfect structure
to represent as a matrix in Python. So that's
what we'll do. So we'll define a function
called create board. And that's going to accept
any inputs. And then we're going to make a,
a matrix of all zeros with the dimension six
by seven. And to help us do this, we're going
to import a package called NumPy. And if you
haven't already installed this, you can open
up a terminal window and just type in pip
install NumPy. And as you can see, I already
have it. So we're going to use this as follows
we're gonna say board equals NumPy dot zeros.
And that's gonna make a matrix of all zeros,
which is good for initial state and then the
dimension six rows by seven columns. Cool.
And then we just need to return that board.
And we can test to make sure that worked by
doing the following create board, and then
print board. And as you can see, if I run
Oh, no what happened. As you can see, if I
run that, we, we do in fact have this six
by seven matrix of all zeros. So that looks
good, we're going to begin writing the main
game loop now. So we're going to write a loop
that says while not game over. And so our
loop is going to be running as long as this
game over variable is false. And the only
way it becomes true is if someone has a foreign
row. So we need to initialize the game over
to be false to begin with, equals false. And
the only way that's going to switch to true
is if someone got a four in a row. So now
we're going to need to we're also going to
want to real quick make our board initialize
before we start the game, just so we have
something to put pieces into. So we have our
board, we have our game over variable. And
now we're going to want to be able to ask
for player one input. And then we're also
going to want to eventually be able to ask
ask for player two input. So this kind of
leads us to the problem of Oh, how do we differentiate
between whether it's player one or player
two's turn, so we're always going to define
another variable here called turn, that's
just going to initialize to zero. So what
we're going to say is, if turn equals equals
zero, then we're going to want to ask for
player one input. Alright, so in Python, there's
a function a built in function called input.
As you can see, it highlights blue for me.
So we're gonna say, selection equals input.
And then we're gonna say, player one, make
your selection. So this is what the player
was going to say. And then the way we're going
to initialize this game is we're going to
just say they can type in between zero and
six. So this is what the player one should
see. So if I build this, you see we run into
this error. So this is because Sublime Text
doesn't accept this input function. So my
workaround for this was I installed a package
in sublime called sublime RPL. I'll put a
link in the description of how to install
this. And I can run the input function through
that. So now you can see player one, make
your selection three, and doesn't do anything
with that input right now, but you can see
that it's asking me that and I can type in
enter. Alright, cool. So we also just want
to make sure that it saves our selection properly.
So we're going to print selection. And I also
just want to see, you know, if I type in a
number, does it actually give me the number?
Or does it give me a string that represents
the number. So I'm going to also printing
type of selection, I just want to see what
we're getting. So I'm going to run that again.
And as you can see ever again, but we're going
to go to splice mrpl. And the link is in the
description, as I just said, run current file.
So to and as you can see, it gets to, but
it says it's a string, so we're gonna want
to make sure that it's actually a integer.
So we can just surround this with an input.
And this should work. So let's see, run that
again. And you can also run this through the
command line. So if you run this in your terminal,
go to the directory that the file is in and
type in Python, and then file name, it will
also run it just as I'm running it in this
sublime RPL. Player One, make your selection
three, cool analysis says three, and it says
the class of that is an int. So that looks
good to me. So now you can save some sort
of selection from the user. And you can also
edit this so that it requires you to make
a specific number type in a specific number,
but we'll just leave it as like, we'll imagine
our players are following the directions right
now. Alright, cool, we have that. And then
we're always going to want to be able to ask
for player two's input. So that's going to
happen else otherwise have The turn is not
equal to zero. Then we want to ask our player
to input so selection equals, and we'll just
copy this from above. And we'll just have
to change this to say player to make your
selection. All right. Cool. And now at the
end of the turn, no matter whose turn it is,
we're gonna want to increase our turn by one,
so turn plus or plus equals one. So I'll make
it incremented by one. And then we'll also
what we're going to also want to do is we're
gonna just make this odd even. So we're going
to use mod division, so it's going to be turn
mod to turn equals turn mod two. And this
is just basically making it go take the remainder
of whatever our turn is divided by two. So
this is just gonna alternate between zero
and one. So it will alternate between player
ones turn and player two's turn. So let's
just see if this works properly. So we're
gonna run this build Python current file,
player will make your selection to player
to make your selection for player one, make
your selection to Oh, that looks good. It's
alternating between our player one or player
two. Cool. Okay, and now we're going to want
to start building our actual functionality,
we're going to want to be able to make this
selection right here, actually drop a piece
into our board. So I'm going to define another
function up here called definition drop piece.
And we might define a couple functions. So
maybe have dropped piece and I will just do
pass for now, maybe we'll also have like,
is valid location. So that will check whatever
number that the player typed in, we'll check
to see if that's a valid location.
We'll also define a function called get next
open row, and how all these functions are
going to work together as as follows. So it
all begins with the player making a selection.
The zero to six here represents the column
that they want to drop their piece in. So
maybe a more appropriate title for this would
be co l representing column C. Well, next,
we're going to take this column and the current
board we have and pass it into this is now
location functions aboard comm individualize
how we can check to see if the column they
selected is a valid location, we will print
out the board real quick.
So as you can see, imagine this is the zero
throws the first row, second row all the way
up to the fifth row here. And then this is
the zeroeth column, first column, second column,
etc. We're starting at zero as our first index.
So if we wanted to check if the column that
the user selected, let's just assume that
the user always typed in a valid number zero
to six, we wanted to check to see if it's
valid, all we need to do is make sure that
this top row for that specific column is not
been filled. So let's imagine that we're putting
ones in for player one going in twos and for
player two guys. So if this top row is still
zero for the specific column we selected,
then we know that it's okay for us to drop
a piece in that row, or in that column, it
hasn't been filled all the way to the top.
So do that. So this is the fifth row. So all
I'm going to do is just check to see whether
or not the position at the fifth row. And
let's say, you know, whatever column we select,
is zero. And if it is, that means a column
is still free, if it's not, then that's not
an allocation, we'll have to have the user
try something else. So to do that, let's just
do board. So we're going to return board.
And then the, the row is five. And the column
is whatever the user selected. So here, so
and we're going to make sure that's equal
equals zero. So if that's true, then we're
good to work good to let them drop the piece
there. If that's not true, that means a column
has been filled up all the way. And one thing
I'll note that will probably change in a future
video is that it's kind of getting messy my
code a little bit with just throwing these
random numbers here all the way all over the
place in programming, this is a called magic
numbers, you kind of don't know where they
come from. So I'll clean those up in some
of the future videos in the series. So return
board five, column equals equals zero. And
that is just checking to make sure that that
column has an empty slot. Okay, so now that
we've gotten the valid location, let's get
the next open row in that column. So if we
think back to our board, that's just checking
to see when we drop it in that say, the zero
column here on the left, checking to see which
row of these, the piece will fall on. So to
do this, we're going to write a quick little
loop. So we're going to do
four.
And we're going to set the past in the board
and the column into this one. So the loop
we're going to write here is for our end range.
And I'm actually going to start getting rid
of some of these magic numbers. So I'm going
to initialize a global variable called row
count. And often Global's are capitalized
just to show that are static variables that
don't change or capitalized just to show that
they're non changing variable. So the number
of rows we have is six, and the number of
columns we have is seven. So I'm going to
do for our so for row in range, so the number
of rows we have, so row count. And we're going
to check the board position, we're going to
see, if board our position, or so the column
equals zero, then we want to return that row.
So basically, if the row is equal to zero,
so imagine we're filling this whole board
up with ones and twos. If the slot is still
zero, that means it's empty still. So we're
going to return the first instance that it's
empty. So this R is going to count from zero
to row count minus one. And we're going to
return that first case where it equals zero.
Okay, so now we got the next open row. And
then finally, what we're going to want to
do is drop the piece. So this is going to
take in the board, the row and the column.
And then we'll also add something, we'll just
call it the piece. So whether it's player
one or two going, so all this is going to
do is go board, row, column equals equals
piece. So we're going to make it fill in the
board with whatever piece that the player
just dropped. So let's put this all together
in our loop. So first, we got the column.
And now we're going to check if is valid location
of the board in the column. And then we can
start getting the next empty row. So row equals
get next open row. And that takes in the board
and column as well. So get next input in row
board column. And then we're gonna finally
drop piece. And we're going to take in the
board, the row, the column, and then for player
one, the pieces just a one. And we're going
to copy this in to player two as well because
player one and player two, the functionality
of what they're doing is the same, but we'll
just have to change the piece here to two.
So now and then finally, after the player
goes, we'll probably want to To print out
the board, so we'll print the board here.
And let's see what happens now. So, tools
build sheet, sorry, supply more IPL Python
run card file. So player one selection, we're
gonna drop our piece right in the middle.
So at 0123 is the third column. So three.
What happened? Why did it not fill in? Let's
figure out what exactly went wrong there.
So should have updated the board, but for
some reason it did not. So let's see. Okay,
I see what I did wrong here. So I accidentally
put in two equal sign here. And what we're
really trying to do is an assignment, we're
not trying to set C of the board row column
position is equal to that. So I didn't assign
it. So now it should work. So we'll rerun
this. So tools, primary PL,
Python, on current file, player one, make
your selection will say go to the middle three,
player to make your selection, we'll do three
as well. Play one, make your selection. And
as you can see, one issue we're having right
now is that the pieces are starting at the
top and going downwards. And so the reason
for this is, our convention was to say that
this was the 00 index, but in the actual lumpy,
they represent this right here as the 00 index.
So I'm just going to add an additional function
real quick called print board. And all that's
going to do is change the orientation. So
that what we're seeing is actually the day
flipped over the way we're expecting to see
a Connect Four board kind of be building from
bottom up. So print board, and we just need
to pass in the board. And all we're going
to do is there's a command in dumpee. So the
command is I mean, just remember it, it is
NP dot flip. And when to do board, and then
you have to flip it over, you have to specify
the axis of the zero the axis, we're going
to flip the board over the x axis. So that
should get it upside the right side up again.
So instead of doing print board here, we're
going to now call our new print function.
So print board, and board. And we can also
do that down here if we want to print doesn't
matter, I guess to start with print, or whatever.
Okay, now let's run it again. Tools, primary
PL Python, on current file, player will make
your selection 333. And as you can see, now
it's building up from with ones and twos.
Just how we expect. Okay, that's all I'm going
to do for this video. In the next video, I'm
going to kind of build in the functionality
of actually checking for wins with these ones
and twos. And then in the next video, probably
after that, we're gonna actually add the graphics,
so make sure you stick tuned for those videos.
Thanks for watching this one guy's seen a
bit. What's up guys, and welcome to the second
video in the programming Connect foreign Python
series. At the end of last video, we had something
that looked like this. It's just a simple
command line based Connect for game. And the
one problem with this is that if I actually
won this game, so as you can see, I just won
with player one down the bottom. The game
doesn't let me know at all that I won. So
we need to implement that functionality. So
we're going to define a function called
winning move.
And we're going to have that taken the board
and then the last piece that was dropped.
So winning move, there's a bunch of different
ways to implement this. And the way we're
going to do is not the most efficient method,
but it's probably the easiest describe in
a video. So that's kind of why I'm selecting
it. But we're going to manually check all
the different possible places you could win
and connect for. So all the horizontals all
the verticals and all the diagonals, and check
to see if there is a winning combination on
the board. And because we're doing this after
every turn, we're going to pick up the first
instance of that winning combination, so we'll
know who won. Probably the more practical
way would be to just check around the spaces
where the last piece was dropped. But that
code got a little bit messier when I was doing
it before so I'm going to just do it this
way. So we're going to first check all the
horizontal locations and To do that, we'll
have a loop that iterates over the columns.
So for see in color range, column count. And
so we defined a column count up here. And
that's seven. And one thing, I think would
be a cool challenge for you guys to try that
I don't think my game is going to be able
to do at this point in time is a very well
designed like Kinect for game, you'd be able
to change these numbers. So like I could change
it to say, like 12 or something. And this
to like eight in the game would still be able
to work, you still have like a Kinect for
game, but just a bigger board. So that's a
kind of a cool way to make sure like you've
designed things in a smart way, where you
don't have just these random like magic numbers
popping up all over the place, I'm actually
going to change this real quick to row count,
and column count, just because I'm going to
try to eliminate the magic numbers where I
can and will clean this up to row count, minus
one. So this is the last row, the left index
of the last row. Okay, getting back to winning
move. So we want to check horizontal locations
for the win. So we're going to first loop
over all of the columns. And then we're also
going to have a loop over all of the rows.
And what this loop is going to be over is
not every single position but over all the
possible starting positions for a horizontal
when. So if we think about our board a horizontal
when can start this spot, this spot, this
button this spot, it can't start here, because
you can't go for over from this location.
So this is our last column, the third column
in terms of indices, and then upwards, we
can go all the way to the top vertically,
because it can so this half sorry, you can't
really see, but we're making a box around
that half is where our starting locations
can be for this first. This first check, so
we're iterating over the columns. So it can
only be the number of columns, and then we
have to subtract three, because three of those
columns couldn't actually work. So we're subtracting
three off of that one, and then all the rows
could work. So that's totally fine. So now
we're going to check all the foreign row locations.
So this is gonna look like something like
that. So if board row, column, so this is
just indexing the matrix equals equals piece
and board, row, c plus one. So this is taking
the next one to the right, so we're checking
horizontally, so we're only changing the columns
equals equals piece and board, our C plus
two equals equals piece. And then finally,
and board, this is the fourth piece in row
board, c plus three equals equals piece, then
we're going to return true. So we want to
return true the first time this happens, we're
not going to return this expression, because
that would return that would break out of
this loop before we wanted it to. Okay, and
so what read it right again, this is not the
best way probably to write it, you know, we
have these magic numbers popping up. But it's
just a very simple way to check for all those
horizontal locations. Right. So let's do the
same thing with vertical locations.
locations for when. And actually before I
do that, let's just check to see if we can
get some functionality on this. So if falsification
and we're gonna also write a if statement
that says if winning move. And so we're gonna
say, Ford and then the pieces one. So if it's
winning move, we're gonna just print out.
player one wins. Congrats, yay. Okay, let's
just see if that works with the horizontal
real quick. And then we're also going to want
to set this game over variable to true, because
the game is in fact over if the move is winning,
so let's just run that real quick. Python
on current file. Okay, everyone make your
selection three.
Yay. It says player one wins. And we I guess
I accidentally printed the board at one extra
time. But you know, we did get that functionality,
it did check that horizontal line. So I think
that looks good. Obviously, you'd want to
test these like very thoroughly. But for the
sake of the time of this video, I'm going
to just start going to the horizontal, the
vertical location. So think about where vertical
locations can start. can start, you we need
four up so it can start, it's pretty much
the opposite of the horizontal. So vertical
could start all this bottom section, because
we need four up, but it can be in any column,
so it's gonna be pretty similar to the last
loop, but we're gonna have to change the row.
So we'll see in a sec, Shift Tab, we're gonna
have to change instead of the column count
doing for C and column count minus three,
we're gonna have to do row count, minus three,
because we can't start at the top row. And
then we're gonna have that add these pluses
to the rows actually, row plus one, row plus
two. And the last one is rho plus three, and
then write it once again, like, see if you
could figure out how to manipulate this, these
equations to work for any length of a board.
And also, let's say maybe we want to make
a game that was like Connect six, like, it'd
be a cool challenge for you guys to try to
build these functions so that they could be
any number of columns, any number of rows
and any number of pieces for the winning length.
Okay, so let's check to see if the vertical
locations now we're gonna run this again,
real quick. So tools, Python, and current
file, three. Cool, it works again. So we see
have the foreign row with a one right here,
and it says player one wins, congrats. So
that looks good. Now we have to get to the
little bit of the trickier
things run out the check for the first we'll
check for the positively, slopes, diagonals.
And we're also going to make a separate method
to check for the negatively sloped.
And you'll see why we need to do this in a
sec diagonals. Alright, so let's think about
it. We're gonna think about it the same way,
where are our possible starting locations
that we could have a positively sloped diagonal?
Well, we can start here and go up, we start
here and go up here and go up. So I think
the last piece, we can start here and go up.
So this is going to be the top row. And we
can't go any farther than this piece right
here. So that looks like we're doing row count
minus three and column count minus three.
So
right, so we're going to, we'll just copy
this code, see, oh, no, what happened? See,
and I'll paste that in right here. Alright,
so we're going to have to subtract three from
column count and from row count, and then
how this is going to increment as you start
with that initial starting location. And then
we need to plus one to both things because
it's a slope. It's not just a horizontal or
vertical now, so with do the addition step
for both of these. Okay, cool. And as we've
been doing, let's just check to see if we
can get a diagonal when here. So player one,
make your selection. I'll just start in the
right, we're almost there. So close. Don't
screw this up. Now, Keith. Okay, and we'll
check here. Cool, the diagonal there worked.
So that looks like it's working too. And then
finally, we need to do the negatively sloped
diagonals. And so if we think about negatively
sloped diagonals, they can start at the top
and go downwards. But they couldn't start
any lower than this right here. This is the
last one they could start at, because they
have to go down four. So that looks like it
would be the top rows and then also the columns
minus three. So we're going to Start the rows
at three. And we're going to have to start
the columns in the normal, normal location.
So this is going to start from three to the
row count. And so it's three, because if you
think about it, z, this is the zeroeth row
is the first row, second row, third row. So
even though it's actually the fourth up, it's
third index. So that's why we're starting
at three. And that's going to go all the way
to the top, and the column counts actually
good as it is. And so this is going to have
to now go, it's going to go positively over
in the column direction, but it's going to
go down a row, so negative one here, native
to here, and this is just a negative slope,
you you know, you have one direction, positive
one direction negative, and this will be negative
three. So let's test to see if this works.
Come on. or have your Python file. Okay, just
build up the left side first.
Okay, to
okay.
Okay, okay. Okay, we're almost into the negative
diagonal there. So player one, you can go
three, and then player two, to then do cool
the native diagnose work now to Okay, so that
looks like we have all the possible winning
directions, you should more thoroughly test
to make sure the all the edge cases work.
But to me, that looks pretty good. So we're
also going to implement the functionality
for player two in this main game loop. Okay,
so this is player two, Player Two Wins from
grads Game Over true. Okay. And if you wanted
to, you could just break out of the loop,
if you didn't want to see this board, and
the turns changing at the end. Okay, so that's,
we've now finished the command line version
of the game. So we'll start building out,
probably in the next video, we might clean
up the code a little bit, and then we'll build
out the graphics. Okay, see you in a bit.
What's up guys, and welcome to the third video
in my programming Connect Four in Python series.
In this video, we're actually going to implement
the graphics for our game. So at the end of
the last video, we had something that looked
like this, it was a fully functional command
line base Connect for game. So we're going
to take this game, and we're going to expand
on it to actually make it look nice. So the
first thing we're going to do to do that is
import a library called pi game. And just
like the NumPy library, if you don't have
pi game installed, just open up a new terminal
window and type in pip install pi game. As
you can see, I already have it. Cool. Alright,
and now what we're going to do is we're not
to start out by initializing pot pi game.
So there's you have to do in any pi game project.
So before our game loop starts, we're gonna
do pi game.net.
Okay, and then what we're going to have to
do is define our screen size, how big do we
want our game to be. So if I real quick, just
build the finished version I have, you can
see that, you know, it's pretty, you know,
you can kind of break this game down into
squares, I would say you have squares that
represent each column in each row. And then
I had this one extra row at the top. So we're
gonna define each one of those squares as
100 pixels. So the sizes we're going to talk
about right now are all in pixels. So the
square size is going to be 100 pixels. And
then our width for our screen is going to
be the number of columns, so the column count
times the square size. Cool. And the height
is going to be the row count times the square
size. And actually, if you saw my, the game
I just dragged in, I'll drag it in over time.
I actually added one additional row because
I wanted this spot where I could display this
circle that I'm dropping. So we'll actually
make this row count plus one times square
size for the height. And that will be packaged
together nicely in a variable called size
which will be a tuple of width, comma height.
And then to get pygame to actually read that,
we need to type in the following screen equals
pi game dot display, dot set mode and then
We'll have it read in the size. And if you're
wondering where I'm kind of just magically
getting these functions from, I'm looking
at the documentation on the PI game site.
So if you go to pi game.org, slash docs, you
can find all the kinds of functions that I'm
using, I'll post a link to that in the description.
I'm going to real quick test to see our screen
is actually working. So you can just run Ctrl
B. And as you can see, the window popped up,
and then it disappeared. We'll handle why
it's disappearing in a second. So it looks
like though is reading in that screen. Cool.
So let's now create a function called Where
do a couple things. So I think first we'll
define a function called draw board. And this
will just be like print board that we defined
up here. But now we're actually going to draw
it with the PI game graphics. So draw board
is going to have to take in the board, and
that's about it. And I'll actually pass this
for now, because we're going to make some
changes to our loop before we do this job
board. So the first major change we're going
to do to our loop is pygame is an event based
game library. So pi game kind of works and
allows you to function in the game. By just
reading all of your movements of your you
know, the keys, you press the mouse buttons,
you click the mouse, like how you move your
mouse, it reads those all in as individual
events. So that looks like something like
that. So for event in PI game, dot event dot
get. And as I just said, events are like mouse
motion, mouse button down, key down, etc.
So we're going to read in, we're going to
drop a piece by clicking down. So that's one
of the important events we'll have to get.
So we're going to first do just kind of follow
me on this one, event type, event type equals
equals pi game dot quit. So this is just something
you want to handle in all of your games that
you make, just allowing your game to properly
exit out, if you click the button here in
the top right that x out, x is out of it.
So if that happens, we have to do a system
exit just so it properly shuts down. And to
get this sits right here, we're gonna have
to import that into our project goes well
that means system. And that comes to fall
in any Python installation. Okay, system makes
it now to get to the more interesting stuff.
The event that we really are going to care
about to start is mouse button down. So if
event dot type equals equals pi game, dot
mouse button down and all the different events,
you can also find on the PI game website under
the docs. The game is going to run by us clicking
down on a specific spot in the screen where
we want to drop the piece. So instead of reading
in the column, we want to drop it in as we
did previously. Now this column is going to
be populated by where we click. So I'm going
to real quick, put all of this all of this
behavior into this mouse button down event
type because now the events of us dropping
the piece always happen when we click the
mouse button down. So we don't want to tap
in otherwise we don't want it to be asking
for this input. Alright, so column equals,
and this is going to be where we click on
the screen. So just for now, I'm going to
just kind of comment out this stuff, just
so it doesn't run on us while we're testing.
And let's just real quick, see if this fixed
our error of the screen disappearing right
when it pops up. What happened? Prince as
you can see, now we have this screen and it's
not, you know, it's staying here. So that's
because we actually added in this event loop
here. And knows kind of continue while these
events are happening. And the exit out will
be handled properly by this this system exit
cool. Alright, so we have our screen looking
pretty good but doesn't have any graphics
obviously.
So we're going to implement the draw board
function now. So we think about it. I'll drag
in the finished one I have again, we're gonna
draw some sort of rectangle for each of these
slots, and then a black circle inside those
rectangles. And then we'll have to draw this
afterwards. This piece So we drop and then
whenever we do drop a piece, the the one or
two that's in our command line based game
on to become like a red circle or a yellow
circle based on what we're doing. So let's
implement this. So first, we're going to iterate
through kind of every spot in our board. So
for our refer, we'll say see in range, column
count. And then we'll do the same thing for
our in range row count, just as we did above
here, and when we're iterating through all
the spots, well, we need to initially just
draw it as like an open, you know, a blue
blue rectangle, and then in that blue rectangle,
we want a black circle. So we're going to
do a pygame dot draw function. So first, we're
going to draw a blue rectangle. So that looks
like kind of our game board, and then the
black circle inside of that will be the open
slot. So we're going to draw that on the screen.
And I'm going to drag in again, the light
the library, so I can see exactly what I'm
doing. So as you can see here, pygame dot
draw rect, we need to take in the surface,
the color, the rectangle we want to draw,
and then the width. So the screen is the surface,
we're gonna draw it on the color is we want
a blue color. So I'm going to define blue
as a global variable, global static variable
up above, this is going to be an RGB value.
So we're gonna say it's 00, comma 200. And
that means are 255 or so. So that's gonna
be a very blue RGB value, because this means
red, this means green. And this means blue.
And the only color that's actually has some
value is the blue here. So the color we're
going to say, is blue, we just defined that
that's the RGB value. Now we need to find
our rectangle. So our rectangle is going to
be there, you need to have four different
things to define your rectangle, you need
to have the size of the width and height,
and then also the position. So the position
is going to be this might be take a little
playing around with to get this, but it's
going to be school see time. So these are
numbers zero to, you know, the column count
and zero to the row count, there's gonna be
see Times Square size, because we want the
actual is the top left corner of it. And that's
going to the
and then our position on the y axis is going
to be our times the square size. And our height
and width, are going to be the other two parameters
of this, what they make up a rectangle object,
and that's just going to be it's gonna be
a square, so it's square size, square size,
height and width are the same. And the width
argument that I showed was in the documentation,
as you can see it defined as zero. So that's
optional. And think that's just the outline
like the line that surrounds the square, so
we don't need to implement that. Alright,
let's test to see if just these rectangles
draw properly. So down here, we'll just do
a draw board, taking the board as we did here,
and then what we have to do whenever we want
to update our display is do pygame dot display
dot update. And I'll make sure that we actually
see what we're supposed to see. So we'll build
that real quick. Oh, and as you can see, we
have this giant mound of blue. And the one
problem I see right now is it's not actually
opening up the I wanted the top to be open,
so we could have a piece that swings around
it. So it shows us where we're dropping it.
So I think the problem with that is because
our axis starts at 00, we actually need to
shift down by one square size to kind of account
for that offset that we left for that space.
So we're gonna have to add a square size here.
Now I build this again, as you can see, it
looks proper. Now we'll need to fill in some
circles to represent the, the slots. So we'll
do that by drawing a circle in PI game and
that's also in the documentation. So pi game
dot draw dot circle, and that's going to take
in the surface of a screen, and now we need
a color. So I think a good color would be
just black. So we'll define black up above
two, and black in RGB is just Zero everything
000. Okay, so this is black. And then let's
drag in the documentation real quick to see
how we're gonna finish off this circle. So
Circle Circle Circle,
okay position
and then radius. So this is going to be the
position of the center of the circle, as you
see in the documentation, and the radius will
probably want to be a little bit smaller than
our square size, just so there's, the circles
aren't touching. So let's define a radius
too. So our radius is going to be fun to find
that under the width and height and whatnot.
So our radius is going to be a little bit
less than the square size. So we'll do I'm
going to make this also they have to be integer
values, I believe. So once we start getting
into division, it might get a little bit messy.
So to me n square size divided by two, because
it needs to be the radiuses half the diameter
and the diameter would be the full square
size, and then we'll just minus an arbitrary
like, integer value off of that. So now we
can draw our circle with that radius, we'll
have to do the position first. So the position
where is it, I forget, oh, it's in job board,
the position is going to be so if this the
top left of the rectangle, our position for
the center of the circle is going to have
to be that then with some offset, so square
size, then are Times Square size, plus square
size. And the offset is going to have to be
like half of it because we're talking about
the radius. So half of the rectangle is going
to be adding an additional square size divided
by two. Adding a square size divided by two.
All right, let's see what happens now. Oh,
and then I'm actually going to do the actually
specify the radius. So the radius is what
we defined just a second ago.
Build
What happened? Yeah, integer argument expected.
Okay, so it looks like this division causes
us to have some floats in our code. So we're
gonna have to actually make this and pygame
it seems like only accepts integers. So make
sure that everything you every position and
radius value, you make a integer. Come on,
baby, let's go. Cool. Yay, we got a board.
All right, I think that's where we're gonna
end this video will actually animate the dropping
of the pieces and then the kind of the pieces
hovering over here and the text saying you
won in the next video. Alright, see in a bit.
What's up guys, and welcome to the fourth
video in my programming Connect for in Python
series. In the last video, we implemented
the background graphics for our game. But
if I click around on this screen, nothing
actually happens. So in this video, we'll
finish implementing this graphics will implement
the piece dropping and then a nice little
piece follow up here. Just a few quick notes.
Before I begin, if there's a feature you wanted
to know how to implement, but that I didn't
actually cover myself in these videos, feel
free to leave a comment down below, and I'll
try my best to get back to you as quickly
as possible. Also, if you enjoyed this series,
please please, please leave me some suggestions
for future programs that I can write make
tutorials on, we're always looking for new
content. Alright, let's get started. So to
start this video, navigate down to the main
game loop. before when we are selecting which
column we wanted to drop a piece in, we manually
typed in a number between zero and six to
specify this. Now that we have a graphic,
we want the column that we dropped the piece
in to be dependent on where we click. So if
I click on the left side of the screen, we
want it to drop a piece in the left column
if I click the middle, the middle column,
etc. So where we dropped the piece depends
on the x position of our mouse pointer. So
luckily for us pygame makes using the getting
the exposition of your mouse, super easy.
So if you go to the PI game documentations
under the events, it lists all of these events,
and then it lists the properties you can get
on these events. So for us, we care about
mouse button down and we care about the position
so position gives us an x comma y tuple of
where we clicked. And I can use that as follows.
So I can do print event dot position. And
then I can rerun our game. And so as I click
on the screen You'll be able to see in the
bottom left, he positions where I'm clicking.
So I click in the top left of the screen,
it's about zero comma zero, that's where our
axes starts. If I click in the bottom right
of the screen, that's the, the full dimension
of our game. And we specified that to be 700
700. So these are the pixel values of where
we're clicking. To develop a kind of way to
select the column based on where we click,
we need to try to find a pattern on clicking
in these different columns. So I'm going to
do that real quick. And if we will look at
all these clicks I just made, we can see the
first click is between zero and 100. Second
click is between 102 100 200 300 cetera. So
the last column is between 607 100. So we
can somehow round these numbers down to just
give us zero to six, or back at where we were
when we mainly typed in those numbers. So
we're going to do that real quick. So let's,
we can go ahead and uncomment all of this
code. And actually, this is supposed to be
a comment. So we can uncomment this code right
here, and we can just comment this out for
now. So column, so we want that to be we'll
say that the exposition, so this is a tuple
on the x values first, so the position of
x is equal to event dot position, and then
it's the zeroeth element of that the column
now is going to be so this is between zero
and 700. So the column we can get using, we're
gonna also just to make this our lives easier,
we're going to import a library called math,
this comes default in any Python installation.
So we are going to get what we want to drop
it by doing
position x, then we're going to divide everything
by 100. Because this would give us a range
between zero and seven instead of zero in
700. So the first thing we're going to do
is divide it by 100. And 100, remember, is
what we define our square sizes. So to make
our code a little bit more robust to changes,
we're going to do position x divided by square
size. And then we want this to be a whole
number, an integer value, so we're gonna have
to take the floor of this division so that
we'll round it down to the nearest integer.
So we're going to do math dot floor. And then
the final change we're gonna have to make
is we just need to make sure that the column
is an integer. Because we don't, we can't
take the index of float value of decimal value.
So we'll just ensure that it's an injury by
just surrounding it with an int. And now we
should be able to see when we click on the
screen, we should see our board building up
and we can copy the same thing for player
two. And we'll uncomment this.
Comment that
uncomment all of this. And then we'll make
player to be able to select the piece in the
same way. So we'll say position x equals a
bench that vendor position zero, and then
the column now, my god messy. Okay, we'll
delete this line. Cool. So let's see what
happens when we build game. So now we have
this, where's the actual game window, what
happened? Oh, like didn't pop up for some
reason. clicked down the middle. If you can
see over here in the bottom right, our game
did pick up that click. So I click on the
middle again, keep clicking on the middle.
And it keeps reading that I'm dropping the
pieces. And so that looks really good. Now
we actually have to just represent that on
the screen. So to do this, we'll just make
a small change to our draw board function
that draws the graphics. So navigate to draw
board. And we'll just do a if statement here.
Just say so the rectangles always drawn the
blue rectangles that make up the board. The
black circle represents the empty square.
So if
board
right now, board row, column equals equals
zero, then we want it to be a black, we want
it to be empty.
If
elsif board our row column, so this is just
indexing our matrix equals equals one. So
that's what we see here. Player One dropped
it in the middle. Then we want to draw a circle.
So we Just copy this line because we know
that this is in the right position, where
we're just gonna have to change the color
up. So we don't want it to be black, we'll
just use red and yellow, player one will be
red. So this is going to be red. And this
is not a built in thing, we're gonna have
to define red. So we'll define red right below
black. These are RGB values, so our needs
to be have a value and the other two can be
zeros. So this will give us a nice bright
red. And then while I'm up here doing this,
I'm also going to define yellow. Yellow is
both red and green is combination of both
red and green in RGB. So 255 255, zero. So
now we have red and yellow for player one
and player two.
Ch,
Where was that? Okay, yeah, it's red. And
then one last line, which will be the else
condition lbf. Board our common our C is two.
So that's going to be pi game, or actually,
I'll just paste this in, again, pi game, and
then instead of black, we'll make this one
yellow. And then one thing that might not
be intuitive is that whenever we make changes
to our game board, after this is all done,
this loop has been iterated through, we're
going to want to call pi game dot display
dot update that will rerender the screen with
the new changes. So let us let us and also
we're going to have to add the drop board
resort, we are printing board on every turn,
but we're going to draw a board here as well.
Okay, moment of truth, clicking right here,
know what happened. So it looks like it's
populating, it's just populating it in the
wrong spot. And the reason for this is because
of how our axes is set up. So as you recall,
when I clicked down on the top left, this
is the 00. And this is the 700 700 space.
So in our game, though, this is the 00 piece,
but it just kind of flipped. So when we printed
the board, we call that NP dot flip function.
So we're just gonna have to figure out a way
to offset this to actually be in the bottom
of the screen as opposed to the top. So to
do that, we can just use our height smartly.
So what we really need to do is, we're starting
at the bottom, so we need to subtract whatever
we're actually trying to build up from the
bottom from our height. So height minus this
height minus this, let's try running this.
What is happening, alright, so we still are
having an issue. And the reason we're now
having an issue is because this piece right
here is still filling in the old fashioned
way. So they're kind of like filling in black
and red and yellow tiles, all on different
axes. So what we're going to do to make our
lives easier, is we're going to take out these
two lines into a another loop. So I'm going
to delete those real quick. And we're just
going to do a whole nother loop of, so just
try to bear with me here, I'm going to copy
this stuff, we're going to iterate through
everything. Again, this might not be the smartest
way, but it's just going to be very clean
for us to deal with. Because we're always
going to build our we're always going to build
our background and then fill in the piece
afterwards, as opposed to like try to fill
in our pieces as we're building the pack round.
So I'm thinking this will work well. This
spacing is just messing me up. And these lines
are so long. Here we go. Okay, so if board
RC is one, we're gonna fill it with that,
and then we can just delete this line.
bring us back.
Okay, so now we have two loops running but
this will kind of fix our problem of them,
building our board out on different accesses.
So let's try running it again. What the heck.
If board RC equals one, we're gonna have to
have make this an elsif. Otherwise, it's gonna
fill out the board for all the empty spaces
at the start of the game equals two. Right?
Cool. Let's see what happens now. It looks
like it's working properly, but it's just
offset by one square. sighs and that's because
of this, right here we are initially account
when we're building downwards, we're initially
accounting for this. But now that we're building
upwards, we can delete that from it from the
height. So we're gonna delete this square
size here. We're gonna delete this square
size here. And we should now fully have it
working.
Build.
Yay, looks pretty good, huh? All right, cool.
So now that we've pretty much fully implemented
a game with graphics, we're going to add a
couple additional features. So the first feature
we're going to add is add this little scroll
wheel so that before we drop a piece, we can
see what color the pieces in where we're going
to drop it. So to do that, we're going to
add a new event, we're going to track a new
event. And that's going to be the event type
equal to pi game dot mouse motion. And once
again, all the different events you can use
are listed in the the pygame documentation.
And just like mouse button down, the mouse
motion also has a position property. So I
can do position x equals event dot position
zero. So this is gonna get me a lot more events,
though, because it's always tracking whenever
making any motion. So this is going to be
constantly updating. So now we're going to
use this position and draw some circles based
on where that position is. So if the turn
equals equals zero, that's a player one's
going, then we're going to do pygame dot draw
dot circle screen, the surface color is red,
because it's player one. The next thing we
need to put in the circle is the position.
So the exposition This is the center of the
circle, it's going to be at position x wherever
our mouse is, then we just want it to be offset
enough so that the full circle can draw, so
we'll just make this square size divided by
two. And then finally, we need to specify
the height of or the radius of the circle.
And that's just the radius we've been using
for all the tiles. Else is means it's turned
equals equals one, it's player two's turn.
And we'll just copy this and draw it. And
now it's going to be actually yellow. So let's
look what that looks like if we build that.
Alright, build.
Okay, I forgot to get the display update,
just like we did in the draw function. So
pygame dot display dot update, build. It looks
good. It's just not ever deleting the circles.
So what we're going to do to fix this is right,
before we actually draw the circle, we'll
just draw a rectangle that's black, that will
black out any previous circles that we have
drawn. So pygame dot draw dot rectangle, surfaces,
the screen, color is black. position is going
to start at the top left. So that's 00. It's
going to have with the hole with the screen,
and then the height will be a square size,
because that's how big that buffer bar kind
of at the top is. And that should be good.
I think I might have one extra. No. Yeah,
I have one extra parentheses there. Yeah,
it looks good. So now we have this game over,
Drop. Drop, drop, drop, drop. That looks good.
Cool. And so one thing that you also might
want to change is that if I win the game,
so I'll win the game real quick with red,
it automatically closes right away. So one
thing we can do is we can add a weight pygame
has a built in weight function. So what we
can do is if the game over condition is true,
so if Game Over, we'll call pi game dot time
dot weight. And this is the milliseconds you
want to wait. So 3000 would equal three seconds.
So if I run this again 123 and I'll shut down
automatically. Cool. And then right before
it shuts down, we want some notification that
the player actually won. So initially, we
were printing it, but now we'll actually render
the print function on our screen. So that
will look something like as follows. So we're
going to delete the line this is player one
wins. And we're initialize a font up top so
that will look like we'll do it right below
the the first update. So we'll do my font
equals pi game dot font dot system. font.
This is all in the documentation, just copying
some previous code I wrote. And the last time
I wrote this, I use a font called monospace.
But there's other options, you can look at
the documentation for all the details. And
we'll do font size 75. That's just an arbitrary
number that I found worked. And then if we
go down below, to actually render that on
the screen horizontally, I can type the following.
I can say, label equals my font dot render,
player one wins, explanation. And then I believe
this one right here that I just put in, specifies
the axes that it's on, I'm not actually sure
I might play around with that to check. And
then we want the color to be red, because
it's rendering that text red, because player
one one, and then what we have to do to get
that on the screen, do it quickly, we can
also use the PI game display dot update function,
but I'm going to do something a little different
here. I'm going to do a screen dot blit. And
that just updates that specific part of the
screen. And I toyed around with these values
before I found that the XY pay or where this
will start at the top left hand corner of
this text starting at 40, comma 10. worked
pretty well. So let's see what happens when
I run that we're going to have read when
player one wins. And one thing is that tile
gets in the way. Well, we could potentially
do, we could potentially draw another black
rectangle if we wanted to.
I don't know I'm not too bothered by it, we'll
fix it in one sec. We're gonna copy this for
player two. And also Player Two Wins in the
colors gonna be yellow now. Build. So what
happens if yellow wins. Making this so hard
on myself. 32 wins, yay. All right. And maybe
what we'll do is at the start of the mouse
button down, we will draw that black rectangle
as well. So we don't have that annoying. Annoying
tile getting in our way. So right wondering
when we click the mouse button down, that
will make the thing disappear on it one more
time.
Ah,
player one wins, it looks good. And you can
mess around with that as you see fit. Okay,
I mean, that's like a pretty good game. I'm
pretty happy with it.
So this is going to be Tetris in Python with
PI game. Now this is a pretty advanced tutorial.
A lot of the stuff I do in here assumes that
you already have a basic knowledge of Python,
you kind of know some of the syntax, and you're
not a complete beginner. That being said,
if you are a complete beginner, feel free
to watch through, see what you might understand,
you're probably going to learn something along
the way. It just might be a little bit confusing,
because I'm kind of going to speed through
a few things that are I would consider like
trivial right now. Okay. So first step for
this tutorial series is you guys have to download
and install pi game because that's the module
we're going to be using. Okay, so let's give
a quick preview of what our game is going
to look like. So this is Tetris, I didn't
go too fancy with the graphics, I pretty much
just want to make sure that we get everything
functional here. And then you guys can play
around and change stuff later on, if you want
to. But yeah, this is a fully functioning
game. You can see it just like standard Tetris,
we have different colors, shapes are falling
down the screen shows us our neck shape. And
there we go, the road just cleared. So that's
all I'm going to show you right now. Because
I want to get into actually coding, okay.
So, pretty much what we're going to be doing
in this first tutorial, is we're going to
be working a bit in the main function, we're
going to be creating the grid, we're gonna
be talking about formatting shapes, all the
basics of just setting up for the rest of
the tutorials. So the first step, and what
I need you guys to do is you're going to download
kind of like a starter file, okay. And that's
just because if you see here, I scroll through
my file, I got a lot of lists, I got a few
things set up here. And you know what I could
go through and type them all out. But that's
just a waste of video, because it takes a
long time. So to save yourself time, and to
save me some time, what I'm going to do is
just put a link in the description as a paste
bin link, click that link and download this
code. It's just going to be all this it just
has all the functions that we're going to
need for this. And then it has these shape
formats, which I'm going to talk about in
just a minute. So go do that if for some reason
Paceman is not working, let me know in the
comments. And I'll find another way to give
it to you but I'm also going to put it in
the pinned comment, so that you can just copy
and paste it from there as well. I do recommend
you check the indentation on it though because
sometimes it messes up on paste bin and in
the comments. Okay. So now that you've got
that downloaded, we're working on that I'm
gonna be working in PI charm. If you don't
know about pi charm, don't worry about it,
you can just use it ideally, but it's just
going to save me a bit of time because it
autocompletes variables, and it does some
cool stuff. So that's what I'm going to be
working in, feel free to work in PI charm,
feel free to work in whatever text editor
you want, just know that that's what I'm using
doesn't make a difference. But some of the
stuff I do in here you might not be able to
do And ideally, or Sublime Text or whatever
you guys are going to use. So we've got that
all the way. We've got everything set up.
And now we're ready to actually start coding
and understanding what's going to be going
on. So Tetris is a fairly complex game, you
have shapes moving down the screen, they're
rotating around, they're moving left and right.
When they hit the bottom, they freeze in whatever
position they're in. And then if you have
a full row complete, like cubes, that not
row clears, and you keep going. And obviously
you lose the game, if you stack up too many
blocks, and it goes up or above the top of
the screen. Okay. So this first variables
we need to set up is our screen width and
our screen height. So we got 800 700 here,
the next ones are play with and play heights.
Now this is the actual red box that you guys
saw. That's what these are representing. So
since in Tetris, we have a 10 by 20 grid,
we need to make sure that our play with is
exactly half of our play height, so that we
have perfect squares, right. So doing the
math here that makes it 30 width and 30 height
per block. So that's our block size of 30.
Okay, so now this top left and top left x
and top left y, this represents the top left
position of our actual play area. That's so
when we start drawing blocks, and we start
checking for like collusion and stuff like
that, we just have these already set up, and
we don't have to deal with that. So the math
is pretty straightforward. You guys could
probably figure that out. You don't need me
to explain that. Okay, shape format. So these,
and this is the longest part is why I got
you guys to copy everything is this is what's
going to represent our shapes in Tetris. Now
you see that I have multiple lists inside
of lists, in most cases, this is because each
shape has possibly more than one rotation,
right. So this is the standard rotation of
the S shape. And that's actually what they're
called in Tetris, like s said, I, oh, whatever.
And this is the second rotation. And these
are the only two rotations or whatever that
s can have. So that's why we have them in
here we have a five by five grid of periods,
and then whatever, there's a zero that represents
where the block actually exists, okay. So
that you can scroll through, you can kind
of look at them. And you can see for some
of them, for example, the square, well, it
doesn't have any rotation, if you flip it,
it's gonna look the same. So we only have
one list here, for J. However, though, we
have four, right, because we can rotate in
different ways L, we also afford T, we have
four as well, okay? After this, I create a
list. And it just holds all of my shapes.
So as I said, I just saw that That way, I
can really easily select shapes, just by indexing
them in the list like zero through six. And
shape colors here is the same thing. It just
corresponds to like for example, if I did
shape zero, and I did shape color zero, then
that's going to be the color of shape zero,
okay? Same thing with like, six. So shape
six, well, color list, or shape, color six
is the color of that shape. So just makes
it really easy. We don't have to deal with
dictionaries or anything like that. Okay.
All right. So now, we've kind of gone through
the like starter file, I'd say. And you can
scroll down here, you can look at the function
names, I'm not going to explain them, because
most of them are pretty straightforward. And
I'll talk about them when we start coding
them anyways. But we do have a class here.
Now this class is going to be the main kind
of data structure, if you want to call it
for our game, and this is going to represent
or this class is going to represent different
pieces. So the reason we have the class is
because we're going to call this a bunch of
times, and it's pretty much just going to
hold the information like x y width height
for our piece. So let's actually start coding
this now. So I'm just going to create my initialization
function or method. And this is actually the
only method that I'm going to have. So I need
another underscore, just butchered that. And
pretty much, what this is gonna have is gonna
have an x, a y, and then it's going to have
a shake. Okay. And that's the only information
we need for this. And I'll show you why. So
we'll say self dot x equals x, self dot y
is equal to y, self dot shape is equal to
shape. And then what we're gonna do here now
is want the color, and we want the rotation.
So self dot color. Well, I was already talking
about this self dot color is just equal to
whatever the index of this shape is, in this
color list. So what we can do is we can do
shape under short colors, square brackets,
and then shapes dot index, and whatever shape
we were given. So if we're given the shape
s, well, let's just find it in the shapeless,
whatever index that is, well, that's the color
of our shape, pretty straightforward. And
then we're going to do a rotation. So rotation,
this is going to set default to zero. And
this is so that whenever we click the up arrow
key, we can just add one to this rotation,
and that will represent what shape we're actually
going to be showing because again, remember
the shape list is a multi dimensional list
it has, you can see here, in this case four
lists within it. Okay. Alright, create grid.
I don't know if we want to do this one yet,
you know what, actually, let's go. Let's go
ahead and do this one. It's not too complicated.
So the way that I'm going to represent the
grid in Tetris, so that 10 by 20 grid, is
just by creating a list full of colors. Okay,
so we're going to have a two dimensional list.
And within that second dimension, it's going
to represent a bunch of colors. Okay, so I'll
show you just by coding and kind of talking
about after, say, grid is equal to, and then
another square bracket here, for x, and range
20. And don't worry, I'll explain this in
one second. And it will say for x in range
10. Okay. Except here, we're just gonna use
000. Okay, so what I've just done here, this
is pretty this is like, the Python way to
create lists k list comprehension, we're going
to create one list for every row in our grid.
So since we have 20 rows, we want to create
20 sub lists, and each of these like sub lists,
or whatever two dimensional list is going
to have a bunch of colors in it, how many
colors is gonna have? Well, it's going to
have 10 colors, because we have 10 squares
in each row, we have 20 rows. So that's the
way it works. These X's you could replace
with underscores, because we don't really
care about the actual variable, we just need
to do this that many times. Now. 0000, or
000. Like that's right. Anyways, that's just
block stands for block. And the way we're
going to draw the grid is simply by looping
through this grid, which we're going to return
and just draw on each color. So it makes it
pretty straightforward. Okay. Now, the only
thing that we have to do here, though, is
we have this locked position. argument now,
locked position will right now we've created
a blank grid. What if there's already blocks
that have been placed in our grid, so like
they've already fallen, they're static, now
they're not moving? Well, we need to also
draw those. So to draw those, we're going
to check if any of the positions in locked
position are not like or whatever positions
are in locked position, we're going to get
that color and we're going to change the corresponding
value in the grid. I'll show that just by
kind of coding here. So for I, in range, I'm
going to do the length of grid. And again,
this is going to give us 20. Because the length
of grid will that it's 20 of these, right?
Okay, so for i in range, one of grid for j
in range, and then we'll say the Len of grid
I, because now we're in this list. So now
we're going to do whatever the length of that
list is, okay? Alright, say if this if j comma
i, because j is our x value, I is our y value,
because rows are represented by I and the
columns represented by J in a locked position,
and just you know, locked pause stands for
locked position, it's also a dictionary. So
you can see that it's a blank dictionary here
and each position. So like, for example, if
we had like one one, is going to be set equal
to a color, and the color could be something
like 255 00. Okay, and we're going to talk
about that and create that later. But that's
just something he needs to know for now. Okay,
so j is in locked position. So if that key
exists, let's figure out what that key is.
So that key is going to be equal to well lock
position, or what the value is sorry, associated
with that key J. Now we're going to change
whatever the current grid position is here.
So for grid, i, j, is equal to C. Okay? I
know this might seem kind of complicated,
but pretty much we're just looking through
this grid, and we're gonna find the corresponding
position to the locked position, and just
change the color in the grid so that later
when we draw it, we get an accurate grid.
Okay. And you guys will see how this all is
kind of plays out later if it seems a bit
confusing, okay. And we're going to return
that grid to wherever we're calling. Okay,
so that's one part done. Now we can move down
and we can go into draw window, which is the
actually let's do get shaped. This one's really
easy. Okay. So this is literally a one liner,
return random dot x, actually, what is it
called here, I got to have a look, I think
it's random dot choose random dot choice.
That's what is random dot choice. And then
we're going to be given a shape list. So say,
shape. Actually, let's just, we'll call it
up here. Sorry guys shape.
random choice shapes. All this is going to
do is it's going to pick one of these shapes,
and it's just going to give it to us. So that
when we need to create like a new shape falling
down the screen or whatever, that's all we
have to do. Okay, so good shape. random choice
down really easy. Okay. Next one drug raid.
Alright, so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
be past a surface, and the surface is obviously
what we're going to be drawing on. So we're
gonna start by just changing the surface surface
that when surface dot fill with color this
case the code is going to be blocked. Okay,
surface dot fill 002. Alright, next thing
we're going to do is we're just going to draw
like a title on things. So the way we have
to do this, we first have to start by initializing
font objects when we do pygame.font.net. Okay,
this just means we're setting up font, and
we're getting ready to draw to the screen.
We're going to create a font, a font is equal
to pi game, dot font dot, s, y s capital,
as well as font. And then we need the font
name on the Comic Sans guy. So I'm gonna use
Comic Sans size of the font, I believe. Yeah,
so the fight Randy's 60. Okay. So the way
you want to set up your fight, you want to
change this, just change this to any font,
you can look up fonts on the pygame website,
and then just give it a size, if you know
the name of the font, type it in here, it
probably exists in, in PI game. All right.
So now we're gonna need to set up a label.
So I say label is equal to font dot render.
And then in here, we need the text that we're
going to render, in this case, I'm gonna call
Tetris, need our anti aliasing of one, and
I believe we need a color. In this case, I'm
going to make it white. Okay. So text, anti
aliasing, just set this one, I don't know
why you need to set this one. But just so
that one, and then whatever color you want
your label to be, okay, now that we've got
the label, we need to draw this label on the
screen. So let's pull it it's not when I'm
used to typing when surface dot Blitz. And
then in this case, we're going to put the
label, where do we want to put it? Well, now
we want to figure out where the middle of
the screen is. So we could just hard code
this in. But if we ever want to change the
dimensions of our screen, we want this just
automatically kind of adapt to that. So we're
gonna do top left, x plus play width, over
two, okay, and that's going to give us the
middle of the screen. If you don't understand
that, let me know and I can explain it to
you in the comments down below. Okay, now
we're going to subtract this sorry, this isn't
actually done yet, by the width of the label,
because this is gonna matter. Depending on
how long the label is, we're gonna determine
where we place it on the screen. So we're
gonna get the width of the label, and we're
going to divide that by two. Okay, so now
we need to do the Y. While the Y is pretty
easy, we can just statically type this in
because it's from the top of the screen. So
I'm just going to give it unclick 50 is what
I typed in 30. Okay, and that should put it
in the middle of the screen. And I can explain
that to any of you guys that might not understand
it, you just leave a comment, because I don't
want to waste too much time because I think
a lot of people might understand that. So
for i in range, now, the length of grid, because
now we're gonna start drawing all the grid
objects onto the screen. So we created a grid,
we know how that kind of format works, we're
gonna say, for J. and range, the lun of grid
is same as before. And we're going to pygame
dot draw dot rectangle, and then this guy
is gonna draw on the surface. And then we're
gonna go grid, i, j, okay, and then top underscore
left, I need to put this in. What do you call
it, brackets, your top underscore left search
need to scroll over top left, underscore x
plus j multiplied by 30. And I'll talk about
this one in just a second how this works.
And then top left, why Plus, I multiplied
by 30, another bracket, and there we go. Now
we just got to deal with this grid thing.
So that means that we just now need to pass
grid as well into our drop grid. Okay, way
this works, we're a loop through every color
within our grid. So this is the color grid
ij. Alright, this is the surface we're drawing
it onto. And this is the position in which
it's being drawn. Now, we also just need to
add two things here that I realized I forgot,
because we need the x, y, we need a width,
and we need height. And so for width and height,
well, that's go to the block size, and block
size once again. And you know, we can even
multiply this instead of by 30. By block size
in case we ever decide to change that. So
let's do that just to keep this nice and dynamic.
And then if we keep going over here, the last
thing we need is a fill. So we're just gonna
put comma zero to make sure that we fill in
the shape, we don't just draw like a border
for it. Okay, we this works, we get our top
left x, and we're gonna figure out wherever
we are. So which column we're in, multiply
that by block size, and that's our exposition.
Same thing works for the Y with the starting
y position plus, whatever row we're in, multiplied
by the block size will give us the correct
position to draw our cube in. Okay. After
we've done all that, we just need to update
the screen. So pi game dot display to update.
And there we go. So there's actually one last
thing we want to draw. And it's a red rectangle
that you guys saw in that kind of represented
like the play area. So to draw it out, we
do pygame dot draw, dot rect and then surface.
And then in this case, we're just gonna actually,
let's see here, do we want do I want to dynamically
type this in? Or do I want to just statically
draw it. So let's give it a color first of
all, of red series 00. Okay, and we're actually
going to type it in dynamic, just in case
we decide to change anything later. So top
left, x, and topless, why. And then the width,
we actually already have all these variables.
So we have the play underscore width, and
the play underscore height. And in this case,
we're going to give it a border size of four.
Okay. And that's all for drawing the grid,
we might come back to this later, but for
now, that's it. Okay, so this just draws the
actual grid, draw grid, and I've added this,
okay, we're just gonna copy this part of you
guys that says draw grid. So surface, I'll
put this label and I'm just gonna move this
in, because I realized I have another function
called draw window. So in draw window, what
I'm going to do is surface stop, fill, whatever.
Okay, so, um, take surface and a grid. So
I've just copied some of it from there. And
then instead of updating the screen here,
we're gonna update the screen over here. And
we're just going to call our draw grid. What
do you call it? function like this. Okay,
so now what if we want to draw the grid and
we want to use this in another program, we
could just copy and paste this function, we
wouldn't have to kind of take it out of here.
We wouldn't have to like dissect it. Alright.
Okay, so draw grid. Again, this takes surface
and this takes grid. And there we go. I believe
that's working well. Okay. Now that we've
done that, we're going to start coding in
the main and in main menu, and this is what
we're going to finish off with this tutorial,
because I know we're almost at the 20 minute
mark. Right. So what we're gonna do in main
now is we're going to set up a few variables.
So the first variable we need is this locked
position. locked position, okay. And again,
this is what we're passing up here into create
grid, it's equal to a blank dictionary just
to set in case we don't pass it then we don't
need it. Okay. So lock positions equals blank,
we're going to say grid is now equal to well
create grid because we already created that
function with lock positions passed to it
and create a variable called change underscored
piece, it's gonna be equal to false, we're
gonna make run equal to true, this is just
for our while loop that we're gonna use, we're
gonna say current piece is equal to get underscore
shape. Okay, we're gonna say, next piece is
equal to get shaped as well, we're gonna set
up a clock object and clock is equal to pi
game, dot time dot clock. And we're gonna
set a variable called full time equal to zero.
And those are all the variables that we need
in our main function already coded for us.
Okay, so now we're gonna set up our while
loop is our main game loop here, say well
run. First thing we need to do in our loop,
sorry, for event
in PI game, dot event dot get, let me say
if event dot type equals equals pi game dot
quit. Well, that means we need to quit the
program. So the way that we can do that is
just simply hitting run equals false. It's
going to break us out of our while loop, and
then we can deal with that afterwards. We're
also going to add another event. This is a
key down event. So if event dot type equals
equals pi game dot key down like that, then
we're going to check what specific key is
actually hit. So let's go ahead and do this
now. Kind of get it over with so I'm just
going to type all the different keys. And
then we'll go in and code that after. So we'll
say if what do you call it pi game dot key
equals equals, I believe, that's what it is,
or event key not plugging key my bad guys,
event dot key equals equals pi game dot k
underscore, capital K. K underscore left.
We say if event dot key equals equals pi game,
dot k underscore, right, like that. And then
same thing up and down. So event dot key equals
equals game dot k underscore down. And last
one,
up. Okay, I don't know why that keeps happening.
Okay, okay, underscore up like that. Okay,
so painfully after typing that left, right
down, up. Now we can go in here and we can
kind of code what each of these is going to
do. So for hitting left, we want to move our
block left. If we're coding, right, if we're
hitting rate one, move our block, right, and
we're going down, we're gonna move down if
we're going up, we want to rotate our shape.
That's what the main things are going to do
in here. So if we want to move our piece left,
well, we should change the Y the x value left
wise, okay. So the way that we can do that
it is a current piece, dot x minus equals
one. Now I know you guys are looking at this
right now you're saying okay, well what the
heck man, so current piece is equal to get
shape. And that's all equal Get shape, well,
what is good shape, and it's just returning
random choice shapes. Now, this actually just
made me realize the fact that our get shaped
thing needs to change. But that's because
we need to actually create a piece in here.
So we set up this lovely class up here and
we weren't even using it. So Pease random
choice shapes as the last argument takes,
it also takes an x and a y value, right? So
for the x and the y, well, the Y is pretty
straightforward. It's just gonna be zero,
the x has to be the middle of the screen,
so we're gonna give me five for y, we're gonna
give it to you. Okay? And actually, for why
we'll leave it zero for now. But we might
want to make it negative so that it kind of
starts above the screen and then starts falling
down. Okay, so we have, let's make sure this
works. looks right, x, y shape. Yep. Okay,
great. Okay, so that makes sense. Now on how
we can change this x value, same thing for
rights. We'll do current piece, dot y, or
dot x plus equals one. That's a for down,
we're actually just going to type this in
for now. But this is not exactly what's going
to work. Y plus equals one to move downwards.
And for up, well, we need to rotate the shape.
So to rotate the shape, this actually pretty
easy over into Steve, his current piece dot
rotation, plus equals one, okay? Because when
we change that rotation, well, that changes
the actual image of the shape. Okay? Now,
this is all great. But the thing is, what
if we're moving off the screen? Or what if
this is not a valid position? Well, that's
why we have a function called valid space.
Now, valid space, we haven't yet coded but
I do have it in here somewhere valid space,
and well valid space is going to do is it's
simply going to return if the current position
that we're in is a valid space. So the way
that I do so this is gonna just make life
a lot easier. If we're moving left, let's
simply just change the pieces x, move it left
one, and then check if that's a valid position.
And if it's not, well, then we can just add
one, and move it back to where it was. So
we're gonna say if not, and then valid space
and valid space. Again, take two arguments,
gonna take the current piece and it's going
to take the grid, okay? Then let's just simply
subtract or add one to our piece. So all this
is saying is we're gonna move left, but if
for some reason moving left, results in not
a valid space, well, let's just add one and
pretend like we didn't even move there. So
we're not drawing it, we're not changing anything.
So this is perfectly fine. And it's actually
a really easy way to check things that haven't
been checking if if it's below this or above
this or whatever. Okay, so now next, next
one here, we're gonna say if not valid space.
And same thing current piece. With grid. Well,
now in here, instead of adding one, we're
just gonna subtract one because we were trying
to move right. And there we go. Same thing
with moving down. Okay, so we're literally
just gonna take the exact same thing, if not,
valid space, current piece and grid. Well,
now let, instead of adding one, we're just
gonna subtract one and this is from the y
value this time she said current piece. dot
y minus equals one. Okay, so now for up. So
when we change the rotation, we are changing
the shape. Okay? So it doesn't show this yet
right now, like how we change the shape, but
we're going to do that later. So we can actually
just call the exact same thing on rotation.
Because think about it. If we're fully on
the right side with like the straight piece,
and we try to rotate, well, that could result
in our piece being moved to the left or to
the right. Or like, there could be positions
where it's on the left, or it's on the right,
and it's not in the grid. So we do have to
check for rotation. If it is about spacemouse.
We'll say current piece. And then what else
are we doing? Great here. Okay, and then this
case, we get it, we'll just we'll just subtract
one from rotation. So minus equals one. And
that should all work pretty well. Okay, so
after we do that, we're gonna make sure that
we remember to draw the grid. So in this wallet,
put such say, actually draw window. I'm gonna
give it surface.
And we're going to give it grid. Now, this
reminds me that I haven't yet created a pie
game surface. That's great. So let's do that.
So here, I'm going to say when equals pi game,
dot display dot set underscore mode. In this
case, I'm going to give it what is their screen
width and screen height. So s, width, and
s underscore height. And that's it for display.
We want to give this a caption though. So
we'll say a pygame dot display dot set underscore
caption. Yep. So let's call this Tetris. Like
that. And now we're going to just pass when
into our main menu. We'll put one in here.
And then in main menu, we're going to call
me, okay, and we'll deal with Main Menu later.
I don't feel like coding it right now. And
it's not really important to like the main
functionality of the game so we can simply
just do this. Okay. Main win. Like this, and
If I put win here, then everything should
work out the surface. change this to say,
when? In locusts Okay, so now we've effectively
done draw grid or draw window, draw grid,
get shape, create grid, we've created a piece,
we've gone through what all this stuff in
the starter file does. And we are now at 27
minutes. Hey guys, and welcome back to part
two of coding Tetris in Python with PI game.
So let's get right into it. In this video,
we're gonna be finishing a few other functions,
we're going to be doing valid space, convert
shape format, we're gonna be coding but in
the main, and we're also gonna be fixing a
small mistake I made in the last video. So
this code right here in drug grid, yes, this
does draw our grid, but this is not what I
intended this function to do. And I kind of
just realized this, when I was looking over
the video and looking over the codes, we're
just gonna copy this code from draw grid,
okay, deleted out of there. And we're just
going to paste it down here at the bottom
of draw wind. Okay, so now we just have this
after we're putting the label, we have whatever
code we had within draw grid, okay, because
draw grid would this actually was supposed
to do is draw the lines for the grid. So I
kind of got this mixed up while I was going
through the tutorial. So we're going to finish
draw grid now. And what this is going to do,
and it's going to draw those gray lines over
top of all of our different colors that can
kind of see where each block is, and we can
see the actual grid structure. So let's get
started with this. Say sx, which stands for
start x is equal to
what do you call it? Top left x. Okay, and
then as far as equal to top left y, like that,
all right. And this is just so I don't have
to keep typing top left x, top left, y just
makes it a little bit shorter for us. Okay.
Now, I'm just gonna say I'm going to set up
a for loop and I say, for i in range, and
this is going to be the length of the grid.
So how many rows we have, let's say for j,
in range, and this one is going to be the
length of grid i. So how many columns in each
row. And then here, we're going to be drawing
lines, okay. So for every row, we're going
to draw a line. So pygame dot draw dot line,
we need a surface, give it a surface, we need
to cover this case gonna be gray. So gray
color code standard is 128 128 128. And then
we need two positions, okay. So the start
position is going to be equal to sx. Alright.
And then S y plus, what do you call it, I
believe multiplied by block size. And I think
that is actually correct. Okay. Now, for the
end position, well, it's gonna be the same
x value because we're destroying, or actually,
it's gonna be, let me just check you, yeah,
it's gonna be a x value that is just equal
to the width. So s x plus whatever the play
with this, and then the y value is going to
be the same here. Because if you think about
it, we're gonna be at the same y value each
time we're doing like, we're drawing a horizontal
line, every horizontal line is gonna have
the same two y values and the x values just
gonna be changed. Okay? So I'm just gonna
copy this and paste it in here now. Okay.
All right. I don't know why that did that.
But we'll just go back like that. Okay. So
now what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
do this case with x s x plus j multiplied
by block size, okay? s, y can actually just
stay like this, okay. And then for sx, same
thing, as x plus j, multiplied by block size.
And j is, again, is our current column. And
then this one s, y plus play, underscore,
oops, we need a plus sign here, plus play
underscore height like that. Okay. And that
should be drawing us. What do you call it
20 vertical lines, and then 10 horizontal
lines down the screen, giving us a grid, and
kind of the way that works is every time we
loop through a new row, we're simply changing
the y value of what line we're drawing, and
then these x values are gonna stay static,
just at the left side and the right side of
the screen. And then the way that we do it
here is we have the x values that constantly
are changing every column and the y values
are staying static, being the top of the screen
and the bottom of the screen to draw the vertical
lines. And that's what I wanted to do within
this draw grid function. So now, that's all
kind of sorted out. And we fixed like a small
mistake, don't get me wrong, can still have
that other code up here. Like it still works
fine. But just in terms of what I actually
wanted to do with these functions. That's
the way we need to fix it. Okay. So now that
we've done that, what I want to start doing
is getting into this convert shape format,
okay? Now, this is probably the most complicated
function I want to say within our program.
And what this is going to take as an argument
or a parameter is just the shape. Now this
is what I was talking about before. So when
we have a shape, it looks something like this,
right? So we have zeros and we have periods.
Now this looks nice to us. Like we can tell
what kind of shape this is, but the computer
has no idea. So how can we get this into a
form that the computer can read. And ideally
you want to give it, we want it to give us
positions within the grid of where blocks
exist. And then we're not going to give position
if the block doesn't exist. So if there's
a period like this, okay, and you'll see what
I mean, as we start coding this function,
and that's what the goal of this function
is to do to take that information and put
it into something that's actually useful to
us. So we want a bunch of positions, that's
the goal. From these, like lists, we want
to generate a list of positions. And then
based on those positions, we can do things
we can check them, we can draw them, and so
on, I'm just gonna create a list called format.
Don't worry if it's a keyword, it'll just
override it. We're gonna say when we're given
a shape, we're actually given a piece object.
So I don't know why I'm calling the shape,
but whatever. So shape dot shape, and then
we can just do is equal to, and I'll talk
about this in a second shape, dot rotation,
modulus, youth length of shape, dot shape.
Okay, so what this does is actually gives
us the sub list that we need. So this needs
to be spelt correctly. I
don't know how I butchered that. So bad. Okay,
shape dot shape. So if we look again, here,
whenever we're past a shape, we're actually
past something like this, right, so we're
past the shape object and its shape property.
So right here, is looks something like this
looks like the variable t, which would have
a list full of lists. So we want to get the
actual sub list. So which one this list right,
that's what we want. So the way we do that,
is by getting the shape rotation modulates
the length of the shape. So for example, if
our current rotation is zero, like we haven't
rotated yet, then what's gonna happen is we're
gonna have zero modulates the length of shape,
in this case, the length would be four, so
we get zero. So we're given this first shape.
Now if we have one, we're given this if we
have two, we're given this, if we have three,
we're given this. And if we have four, then
we go back, and we get this one, okay? And
it just keeps going and keeps going. Because
modules simply just gives us the remainder.
So that's how we can tell what the actual
current shape is within that main list. Okay,
hope that makes sense. So now we've done that,
well, we want to do is want to set up a loop.
And because we want to look through every
row and every column, and then based on if
there's a zero or a period, we're going to
do something. So we're going to say for i
comma, and because we want the line as well
in a numerate, right, and then format, okay,
because format is the list that contains,
like the actual zeros and ones, okay, we're
just gonna say row is equal to list of line.
This just gives us a nice list format that
we can deal with making it easier for us,
I'm going to say for j in or j, comma column,
sorry, in a numerate and now row. So now every
row we're getting the current line, and then
we're gonna loop through the line and look
for either zero or a period. We're gonna say
if column, which is going to be, for example,
if we have some, like this gonna look like
00. Okay, so this is what our row is gonna
look like. So when we start looping, J will
be zero and column will be a period. Okay?
Just Just in case you can't confuse that.
Okay, so for if column equals equals, and
it's gonna be string zero, then we know that
we've hit like a position like this cube exists
here. So what we want to do is we want to
add the position to our positions list. Now,
it's not so simple as just add current IMG
value, we actually have to add something else
what I'll show you right now, I'm just gonna
type it out and kind of talk about Okay, so
shape dot x plus j, and then shape dot y,
plus i, okay, so this is our x value, it's
the current value of the shape, because if
the shape is already moving down the screen,
it's moving left and right, well, we need
to add that to whatever the J value is, whatever
column we're in within this list, okay? And
then same thing with the y value. So whatever
the current y value is of our shape, we're
going to add whatever column or whatever row
sorry, we're now in as for the y value, okay?
And that is the positions that we need in
these positions list. Okay, so now that we've
done that, we just have to modify these positions
slightly, we've got to give them an offset.
Okay. And I'll talk about why this why we
have to do this. So for I pause in a numerate
positions, okay, then we're gonna say, positions,
i is equal to, and then this is going to be
the current position, okay? So we just need
to put this into Tableau because that's where
we're gonna give it. Pause zero minus two,
and pause one, minus four. Okay, so now let's
break this down and kind of talk about exactly
what's going on. So we started off blank list
positions. We're just getting the actual shape
within this list. So for example, we get something
like this, okay. And then we're looping through
it. And where am I sorry, and we're pretty
much just checking if zero exists in each
Position have that shape, okay? If that exists,
then we're gonna add that position into our
list. And the way we do that is simply by
getting the x plus whatever the current column
is that we're looping through, and whatever
the current row is plus y, okay? Now we've
got that, the issue is that if we look here,
we're going to get something like for a position
list here, we'll get something like three,
one, and then we'll get three, two, we'll
get three, three, and we'll get three, four.
Okay. Now the issue with that is we're adding
the current x value, plus these two periods,
and the Oh, so we need to remove these kind
of trailing periods, right? Because that's
going to result in our positions being offset
to the right by too much. Same thing with
these y values, okay? Because when we're counting
this row, we're saying, well, this is one
lower than this row, so our current y value,
say zero, and we're adding to it, now instead
of just adding one, we're gonna be adding
two, so it's gonna, everything's gonna be
offset down. So the way that we can kind of
fix this is just by offsetting by constant
and by offsetting, I'm just gonna take every
x value that we've added and subtract two
from it. And every y value that we've added
in subtract four from it. Now this is going
to do is simply just move everything to the
left and up so that when we are displaying
it, it's just more accurate to the screen.
Okay, you guys can see what's going to happen
if you don't offset this. And you'll notice
that you kind of run into a few errors. So
just run with me on the screen and just kind
of you should see how this works later on.
Okay. Okay, so now that we've converted the
shape format, I want to go and code valid
space now. Okay, so valid space is going to
take two parameters, shape and grid. Alright.
And we're going to check the grid to see if
we're moving into a valid space. So what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to create two
lists, I'm gonna say accepted. How do you
spell accepted, accepted underscore pause.
So these are just gonna be the positions that
are actually valid, okay, is equal to and
just flow with me on this, we'll talk about
in a second for j, i, in then within this
list for j in range, 10. So similar to what
we did to did in the last tutorial, and then
for i in range 20. Okay, so this is really
similar to the way that we created the grid,
we're just getting every single possible position
for a 10 by 20. grid, okay, and we're just
adding in a tupple and accepted positions
gate. That's great. But the thing is, I want
to convert this into a one dimensional list.
So this is the way that we can do this and
make all the positions. But now how do we
flatten this list. So this is actually how
you do this. Okay, so excepted pause, is going
to be equal to and this is one way, there's
many j for sub in accepted positions. And
then one more for j in sub, okay. So what
this is actually doing now is it's pretty
much taking all the positions in our list
and just adding it into a one dimensional
list. And then we're just overriding this
list with that. So see if you guys can understand
that. If not, don't worry about it, just know
that all this does is simply flatten this
list. So we go from looking something like
this. wouldn't call it like 01. And then having
another list.
bedded stretched out example here, two, three.
So we go from that to something that kind
of looks like this. And we just held the positions
in it now. So we don't have those sub lists.
And this just makes it a lot easier to loop
through. Okay, so now we just have 0123, rather
than having these embedded lists full of other
temples, okay, that's all we're doing with
this line. Okay. So after we do that, what
we want to do is we want to get all these
positions, and we're going to get the shape,
and we're going to convert it into our positions,
right, because remember, whenever we get a
shape that looks something like this, it means
nothing to us, we need to first convert it
into positions before we can compare it against
other positions in our grid. So we're going
to use this convert shape format grid, our
convert shape format, we're gonna pass it
the shape, and we're just gonna store this
in a variable, and I guess we're gonna call
it, what should we call it? format, okay,
because I guess that makes sense. We formatted
our shapes. So now we can use this and kind
of compare it against accepted positions.
So here, we're gonna have a list that looks
like something with a bunch of positions in
it. And then this one, we're gonna have a
list that has a bunch of positions in it.
So you might see where we're going here in
terms of how to compare these things. Okay.
Okay, so now that we've done that, we've kind
of got all the data ready to check. This is
the really easy part is we're just gonna say
for position, informatics, and all we're gonna
do now is just check if this position exists
within accepted positions, because accepted
position is every position that we're allowed
to have, right? So we're gonna say, if paws
not in accepted position. And this is an important
part, pause. One is greater than negative
one, return false, and then otherwise, so
if we make it through that loop, that means
we had all our positions accepted, we can
return true Okay, so let's talk about this
really quickly. The reason I have this if
paws once the y value is greater than negative
one is because when we give this offset of
four, what ends up happening is we get some,
when we spawn in our shapes, they're going
to spawn above the screen. Now we actually
want this, because we don't want our shape
to show up on the screen wants to start falling
before it's actually seen. So typically, this
means y position is going to start at like
negative one or negative two. So the thing
is, while it's falling, we're checking if
it's in a valid position, right? But the thing
is, it's not going to be in a valid position
if it's negative. So we just want to make
sure that we're only asking if it's an invalid
position if the y value is greater than negative
one, so greater than or equal to zero, okay?
And this is a really easy way to tell us well,
are we on the grid or not? So let's give an
example. Say we're trying to move left, and
we're already at the edge of the screen. So
that means we're gonna have an x value of
negative one. Well, that position of negative
one, whatever y value is not going to be in
this accepted position. What do you list?
So when we try this, we're going to return
false, and it's not going to allow us to move
left? And that is the whole point of that.
And now, okay. What am I doing here? Okay,
so I also just want to modify this part up
here. So I have true j, i in range for j in
range. If i in range 20. I want to just change
something here. Okay, so what I'm going to
do actually the mistake if grid,
i j equals equals, and then the colored users
Yeah, okay. So this is an important part,
I was kind of waiting, I was kind of thinking
about this. So pretty much, we're only going
to add this position into our accepted position
if it's empty, which actually makes a lot
of sense. Because think about it, if we already
have a color in that position, then that's
not a valid position, we can't move into where
piece already exists. So this conduct condition
does it says, Okay, we're only adding this
position. Now, if this is true, so if i j
is true, then we're good, we can add the position.
If it's not 000, that means something exists
in there. So that's why we're not going to
add it into our accepted positions. Okay,
so I know this looks kind of confusing. So
I'm doing like a bunch of embedded for loops.
This just saves us a few lines. It's kind
of a cool way to create a list in one liner.
It's like the Python anyway, so I figured
I'd do that for most of the stuff in here.
Okay. So now that we've done that, what else
can we code? Well, you know what, while we're
here, we can code check last. All right, this
one's a really easy function, this is just
simply going to check if any of the positions
are, what do you call it above the screen.
So if we hit y value zero, then we know that
we're above the screen that we've actually
lost. So the way to do is we're gonna say
four paws in positions, because what this
is going to do is we're going to pass a list
of positions. So we're going to get every
pause now in the position, we're going to
say x, y is equal to pause, which simply you're
splitting up the tupple, because we know we're
gonna get something that looks in the form
of like, three, four, okay, and we're gonna
say, if y is less than one, so equal to zero
or greater than return true. Else, or we don't
even need an else return false down here.
So if every position is less than or greater
than y, or whatever, one, then we will return
false because we haven't lost yet. Otherwise,
we're returning true. Okay, so we're almost
getting there. Now I want to go down to the
main, and I want to finish coding up some
stuff in here. So last time, we kind of just
left it at this, like moving pieces around,
whatever. But we have these variables. Okay,
so change piece, next piece clock full time
that we're not using. So what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to show you guys how we
can actually move our shape down our screen
at like a regular time interval. So I'm going
to create a variable here actually called
false speed. And this is how long it's going
to take before each shape starts falling.
Okay, so we'll talk about how to do this,
I shouldn't gonna start coding it now. So
pretty much we're gonna say, up here. And
I didn't do this before, but follow along.
Grid equals create grid based on locked positions.
The reason we're doing this, I know we already
created grid up here is because every time
that we move, we have a chance to be adding
something to locked positions. We're going
to do that later. Because for example, if
we hit the bottom of the screen will now locked
position is going to be equal to something
else because it's going to have a new shape
and it shouldn't we need to constantly update
the grid, so that when we're drawing it to
the screen, we get like an updated version.
So that's why I'm doing that up here. Okay.
I also need to actually, I don't think I need
to do that here. We need to add to full time,
okay, so the way we're gonna add to full time
because this is going to track what do you
call it? How long since like the last loop
ran is by using this clock object that I set
up here. Okay, so before I add to that, after
here, I'm going to do clock dot tick and then
I'm going to add this and I'll talk about
After I do at some clock dot get underscore
raw time like that. Okay. So the way that
this works is this raw time actually gets
the amount of time since this last clock dot
tick. So when I first add, it's going to be
zero because we haven't yet ticked the clock
and the next iteration, it's going to see
how long it took this while loop to run. And
then it's going to simply add that amount,
okay, so it's actually going to give us real
time. This means that this should technically
run at the exact same speed on everyone's
computer at every one machine. Because I know
when I use FPS, FPS is dependent on kind of
the speed of what you call it. Your actual
computer, sometimes like the way I did it
in other games, so this is a better way to
do it. So now what I'm going to do is, since
I've now incremented, the full time, and this
is going to be given to us in milliseconds.
So like one second would be 1000. That number
and our full speed is in well 0.27. So what
I need to do is I have to say if fall time,
divided by 1000 is greater than full speed,
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna reset
full time equal to zero, and we're going to
add one to the current y value, which means
we're scrapped we're moving down the piece
one, so this is going to automatically Now
move our piece down. Another thing is what
if our piece will hit the bottom of the screen,
and what if it's moving into position we can't
move into. So this is the same thing we've
kind of done in here, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna say again, if not valid position
or valid space, whatever, given the current
piece, and our grid,
I believe at least grid, okay, then, and actually,
we're gonna check one other condition. And
our current PCE dot y is greater than zero.
So this means that we're not at like the top
of the screen, because the same thing with
negative values, alright, is greater than
zero, then what we're gonna do is we're going
to subtract one from the current piece. So
why once equal one, because that means we
moved into an invalid position. So let's move
back up one and pretend like that never happened.
And we're just going to say, change piece
is equal to true. Now, the reason I'm setting
change piece equal to true, because think
about it, right, if we're moving down, and
we move into position, that's not valid, well,
we know we didn't move left right off the
screen, because we were moving down, that
means we must have either hit the bottom of
the screen, or hit another piece. So in that
instance, we need to stop moving this piece,
and we need to change it. And what changing
pieces going to do, we're going to do that
later, is simply going to lock all the positions
what they're currently in, and then it's going
to make this next piece generate down the
screen. And I'll show you that in a second.
But this is kind of the way to check it. It's
easier way then you don't have to check like
the y values and, and all that stuff. Okay.
Alright, so now that we've done that, let's
move down here to the bottom of main. And
let's start adding a few things. Okay, so
what I want to do down here, I want to say
shape positions. So shape underscore pause,
is equal to convert shape format, current
piece, because what we're going to do now
is we're going to check all the positions
of the piece moving down to see if we've hit
the ground or see if we need to lock it, okay.
So, and we're going to add all that color
to the grid so that when we're drawing it,
we actually see the piece because right now
we have the piece, but we don't add its color
into the grid, so we're not actually going
to see it show up. So we first need to add
it to the grid so that we can draw it and
we can see it moving. So to do that, we're
gonna say for i in range, the Len of shape
positions, okay. We're going to here to say
x, y equals shape positions of i x, that's
the current iteration, the current one we're
looking through, we're gonna say if y is greater
than negative one. So this means that we're
not above the screen, let me say grid, y,
x equals current piece dot cutting, okay?
Because remember, the grid stores a bunch
of different colors. So all we're doing the
greatest giving different colors, and based
on that position in the grid, so y x, which
is going to be this shape, the all the shape
positions, we're going to draw that color.
Now the reason we're going to have this negative
one is because imagine that we're at the top
of the screen, and we try to draw it or we're
above the screen, we have a position with
a negative y value. So if we throw negative,
we're not actually going to get an error in
grade here. But it's going to end up looking
like it's at the bottom of the screen and
then moving to the top and it's just gonna
look weird. If you guys want to see what it
looks like without this, just remove this
condition. You'll see that why have it added
in. Okay, so now what we're gonna do is we're
going to check this change piece variable.
So I put it up here, change piece, this means
that we've hit the bottom or we've hit something.
What we're going to do now is we're gonna
update lock positions and this one, I'm gonna
start talking about lock positions. Okay,
so for pause actually in shape positions.
Alright, we're gonna say p is equal to pause,
zero. Pause one. All right. I don't know why.
Do this, but I think there's a reason for
it. So let's just run with it. And we're gonna
say locked positions p is equal to current
piece, dot code. Okay, so what is this? Well
locked positions is going to be a dictionary,
in a form like this, right? It's gonna have
a tough one here, that's gonna have a position
like one, two, colon, and then we're gonna
have a color and the color is going to be
another tupple. But RGB values, okay, so for
example, 255 00. The reason we have this is
so that when we passed locked positions into
our grid like this, right, we can get each
of those positions in the grid, and then update
the color of grid. So every time that we have
like a locked position in a locked position,
as simply means our piece is no longer moving,
it hit the bottom of the screen, and we're
on to a new piece, we can get the position
and we can get the color, and then we can
update the grid based on that, and we can
keep that in there. Okay. And that's the way
that locked position works. So it's a dictionary
with the key of a position and the value of
a color. Alright, that's kind of like the
data structure for now what we're gonna do
after this, after we update our locked positions,
and we add positions to it, we're gonna say
current piece equals next piece. Okay, so
we're just gonna change that. And now since
we've said, current piece now equal next piece,
will we need to update next piece. So let's
get a new shape, because we're just moving
forward with the game. And now, of course,
we got to say change piece equals false, because
we're on to a new piece that's going to spawn
at the top of the screen. Okay. And I think
that is about it. What we also want to do
actually, is we're going to check if we lost
the game, and I think I do this after draw
window. I don't think it really matters. But
we're gonna say if check last, based on what
do you call it locked positions? Okay, so
these are all the positions of the shapes,
then we're going to say run is equal to false.
And that's going to break us out of this wall
up. And you know what, while we're here, let's
indent out and uninstall pygame. dot. What
is it, I think it's display dot quit or something.
Yeah, display dot quit. So we're actually
just exiting out of our game. Now, up until
this point, I actually have not tested my
code. Now I know some of you probably think
I'm insane. Because we've already written
like 300 lines of code, we haven't tested
any of it. The reason I haven't done this
is because I wanted to test this in between
videos, figure out what the errors were so
that I didn't waste too much time fixing all
of them. So I'm going to go through a few
errors that we have now and show you what
happens when I run the code. So I'm just going
to delete that because that was the fix that
I made. And pretty much you can see a big
crash right away. And we actually get a four
Iron Range, none type has no length. Now the
reason we get this, and this happens down
in the main is because in convert shape format,
somehow I managed to forget to return positions.
So this is really important because the whole
goal of this function well was to generate
this list of positions. And we did that fine,
but we forgot to return them. So pretty easy
error to fix or return positions. Now, again,
we run this like okay, everything looks good.
Now, there's another issue, right? So just
watch. If I try to go off the screen, you
can see that we get a unsupported operand
for current piece, because I forgot to put
a y or an x here. So let's go down to main,
let's fix this. What line are we on? 262 262
current piece dot x. Yeah, that would be important.
Okay. Now I know there's a few other errors.
So this one current piece minus equals, let's
change this to an X. Current piece minus equals,
wow, I really messed up on this a lot. Okay.
dot rotation, minus equal one. Okay, so this
is rotation. And let's see anything else?
Let's run the program. See, okay, we're getting
another issue here. So if we have valid space,
okay, so I just messed up and a bracket here.
So let's go line 265.
Here, so we're gonna take this quotation mark,
or one of the same condition Mark bracket,
and just put it there. And all should be good.
Now, let's see, we go down to the bottom of
the screen. Okay, we get another. And let's
just play this for one sec, see if we can
run into any errors. Okay, so we're rotating
fine. We can't move off the screen. And all
looks to be doing okay. Alright, so that's
a good sign for now. Let's leave that. So
it doesn't look like there's any issues. If
you find any, I probably end up fixing them
in future videos. So don't stress about it.
Okay. So now that we've done all this, what
we need to do next is a few things. Alright.
So we need to deal with this draw next shape,
clear rows, draw text, middle, what are their
functions, so I think that's about it. And
we're also going to deal with Main Menu, kind
of starting the game, finishing the game,
and all that stuff. So what I first want to
do actually, is I want to deal with draw neck
shape. And then I'm going to do clear rows
just because clear rows is kind of complicated.
So draw next shape. What this is going to
do is it's just going to draw the next shape
kind of off the screen and show us what it
is because in Tetris It shows you like the
next shape the next few shapes. So yeah, now
this seems pretty straightforward, like just
draw the shape. It's actually kind of long
because we have to, once again, get this list,
turn it into positions that we can use. And
yeah, it just it gets a bit complicated. So
what we're gonna do is we're also gonna set
up a font in here, we're gonna say font equals
pi game dot fonts dot s, why is font. Here,
we're gonna do Comic Sans again, because you
guys know I love Comic Sans. Comic Sans sighs
stick 30. And let's render this font. Okay,
so label equals font dot render, text for
this is going to be next shape. Okay, feel
free to add a colon or something if you guys
want anti aliasing, one, text color white
to fit fatty food factory gate, basically
already been through that. Okay. Now we need
to figure out where we're going to draw this,
this label. Okay, so let's do the same thing
we've done before we say s x is equal to top
left x plus the play width. And then we're
gonna say s y is equal to top left y plus
the play underscore heights actually won't
play 100 we're gonna say play height, divided
by two. Okay, now what we're gonna do is this
is going to give us like, to the right, maybe
I can just run this and show you guys, it's
gonna give us where my mouse is right here,
like a position kind of similar to here. So
we are actually here. So what we want to do
is we want to add a constant to this, so we
move to the right of it. So this constant,
we're just gonna hard code in. And we can
change this and play with it, if we want it
to be like move more to the right or more
to the left. So to move more to the right,
we're gonna add 50. And then to kind of make
this look a little bit better, which can actually
subtract the 100 from the site. So we can
move a bit higher up on the screen playing
with these constants if you guys want it to
look a bit different. Okay, so now we've got
that, what we're going to do is, we're going
to once again, we're going to format written
say format is equal to shape, dot shape. And
same thing, we need the actual shape. So not
just like that main list, its shape dot rotation,
modulus, the length of shape, dot shape like
that. Okay, so this is the exact same thing
that we did in format, whatever it goes out,
yes. Know what function I'm talking about.
And I've lost myself here, okay, just to get
the actual like, sublist that we need. Okay,
so now, you might say, Well, what are you?
What are you doing here, we already have like
a function that does this for us. Don't worry
about it, just follow along. Because this
is a bit different. The way that I'm going
to do in case I'm gonna say four, I call them
a line in a numerate. All right, and then
row
four, actually, format, sorry, I'm gonna do
the same thing here, we're gonna convert row
ID into list is really similar to the other
function, except we're gonna do one major
change. And you'll see that for row equals
list line, we're gonna say for j, comma, what
do you want to call it calm in a numerate
row this time, and exact same condition, if
column equals equals zero, what we're going
to do here, instead of adding some position
to list, we're gonna draw something. And this
is why I didn't want to use the other function
that gives us list of positions because I
don't care about the position within the grid,
I just care when we should draw something
or not, because this doesn't matter, it's
not going to be moving, we just want to draw
like a constant image on the right side of
this static image on the right side of the
screen that we can just look at. Okay. So
what we do here is we're going to say pygame
dot draw dot rect. So dot draw dot rect. And
each surface we pass the surface in, in each
color, that's going to be the shape color.
Okay, and then we need our position to draw
sx. And then in this case, we're gonna have
to do since we're drawing each cube, great,
we're not just drawing the whole shape, plus
j multiplied by 30. And then we're gonna do
same thing with y. So s y, plus i multiplied
by 30. And we actually just change this to
let's change the block size to be a bit more
dynamic. Okay, so it's a 30 block size, just
in case we decide to change the dimensions
of our screen later on. And then we new width
and height, and that is going to be block
size and block size and we want this filled
in so comma, zero. Okay, so what we've done
here is really similar to what we've already
done. We're just going to be drawing these
blocks according to where they show up like
in this list, based on initial exposition
plus, like a changed kind of position or whatever.
Okay. Anyways, I think that's about it for
this. Oh, we need to actually complete the
label now. So we created this labeled we have
actually drawn on the screen. Yep. So let's
do this. As we say surface dot, Blitz. Label
changes to period. Okay. Then we need to position
what's their position going to be? Well, we're
actually just gonna do sx plus 10 and s y
minus 30. Okay? Again, play around with these
constants, guys, if you want your thing to
look a bit different, be more centered, whatever.
I again, I don't go like too crazy on cosmetics
here. I just want everything to work and look
decent. I assume you guys can mess around
with it. All right. Okay, so now we've done
that we've drawn the next shape, well, we
actually need to call this function. So within
draw window, we're going to call draw next
shape, as well. So where should we call this?
Let's see what's called before we draw a grid,
draw next shape, or actually can't call them
here, where we need to call this as in the
main because we only have next shape within
the main symbol. Right? When we're drawing
draw window, we're actually just going to
call draw next shape. Because we need to give
it the next shape. So it's going to be next
piece. And then the grid does, it takes it
takes a surface surface. Okay, so let me just
go check this to make sure our surface is
not cold surface. It's called wind. Okay,
so in draw neck shape, you have a shape and
surface case. So that that should work fine.
You know what, let's actually test this now
and see this working. And we're not showing
up, we're not drawing this surface. I believe
it is because Joe, when adrenix. Okay, so
we need to do actually, this draw next shape,
we're gonna draw after Joe and no, and we're
just gonna update the display in here. So
pygame dot display dot update. And then if
we go to draw window, just remove this display
update, and this should work. There we go.
So now we're getting neck shape. On the side,
the reason I wasn't working is because we're
pretty much drawn overtop of the next shape,
every time that we drew the window. So now
that's working fine. We have our next shape
showing up. And what else do we need to do?
I'm really delaying trying to go to this clear
rows function, because it's really complicated,
but I think we're gonna have to do this next.
Okay. So clear rows in Tetris. Obviously,
if we create a full row, we need to clear
that row. And then so that's the only way
the user can win, obviously, yeah. So way
to do this
is probably a lot easier than the way I'm
going to do it, but try to follow along, because
this is the only way I could kind of get to
work. And this is probably the hardest part
of the actual game. Okay, so we're going to
take grid, and we're going to take locked
positions. And what we're gonna do is we're
gonna set up a few things here, just follow
along with me, I'll try to explain as I go,
so when I say Inc, which is an increment zero,
for I, in range, the length of grid, negative
one, negative one, okay, and we're actually
just going to subtract one from this to, what
this is going to do is go loop through our
grid backwards, so it's gonna start at the
20th row, and it's gonna move up to the 19
through, Okay, I'm gonna say the current row
is equal to grid I. Alright, and we're gonna
say, if the color 000 is not in our row, let's
clear. Okay, so we're gonna add one to Inc.
Don't worry, I'm gonna explain this after
I just fall on, say ID equals I am going to
say, for j in range, the length of row, what
we're gonna do is we're gonna try to delete,
locked, square brackets, current position,
which can be JDI. And then if this doesn't
work, then accept. And continue. Okay. Okay,
so let's just talk about what I just did here,
because I kind of went fast. And there's another
part of this function door. So the way this
is gonna work, is we're gonna say, we're gonna
loop through the grid backwards, we're gonna
set row equal to every walbro in our grid.
So we're looping through. And the way that
we know if the row should be cleared is if
000 doesn't exist, because if 000 doesn't
exist, that means there's no plaque squares
in our row, which means it's completely filled
with shapes are completely filled with cube
objects or whatever. Okay, so we know we can
clear it. So the way to clear it now. And
don't worry about these variables, we'll talk
about that in a second is to get every position
in that room. To do that mean to loop through
j in the row. And we're already at the current
row. So we know that I just gonna stay static
change j and try to delete this from locked
positions, because now what we're doing is
the lock positions need to be removed. So
when we dealt with these, since locked position
is a dictionary, it's mutable, we can actually
just change it within here. And that's how
we delete those keys and those colors from
the grid. Okay, so after we've delete that,
all we need to do is we need to shift every
row. So what's happening now and I think I'm
actually just going to pull out a little,
I have a drawing tablet and just start using
this to kind of explain some things because
it's pretty complex. So just give me one second
Alright, so what we need to do is we need
to shift every row. So if we delete, like,
the bottom row in every row above that row
needs to move down by one. So if I go to,
let's see this, and delete this, okay, so
you can see if I have a grid. Alright, and
it looks something like this, we're just gonna
do like a very basic like three by three grid.
Okay, just to save us some time. Let's say
that we want to clear this row down here.
So these are full of colors, right? So if
we clear this row, and then what happens is
we get rid of all these and that any positions
that were above it, so let's draw something
like this. Now, this is here. Well, currently,
this is floating, right? Because if we've
cleared all these positions down here, so
we got rid of those, this is floating. So
this needs to move down one. So how can we
go about doing that. And the thing is, every
other row needs to shift down by one as well.
But now let's talk about like a potential
issue we might run into. So if I delete all
that, and let's say we have a grid that looks
like this, okay. And there's a color here.
If we delete this row, the grid actually now
in our memory, only looks like this. Alright,
it's only this top portion.
Because we've deleted an entire row out of
the grid. So yeah, we can shift everything
down by one. But now we're left with the grid,
that's one less than the other one. So what
we want to do is we need to add another row
at the top here, so that our grid stays the
same size. Because if you delete an entire
row, well, you're deleting row, right? So
you need to add back the other positions at
the top, because everything's shifting down
by one. So really, the way it works is you
delete this, and then this whole thing moves
down, and then you add a row up top like this.
Okay, so that you're back to your continual
grid. I hope that makes sense. That's kind
of the only way I can really explain it to
you guys, in terms of how we shift things,
and I'm going to do it in code, right? Okay.
So leave a comment if you guys are confused
about that, because I'll try to explain it
in a better way. But it's just kind of like
a confusing topic in general. Okay, so now
what we're gonna do when I say if IMC is greater
than zero, okay, we're going to say, so this
means that we've shifted, and we've removed
at least one row, and I'll talk about the
case in which we move to Rosa one second,
okay, let's say for key in and just follow
it this is, this is gonna be kind of confusing.
List of locked positions. So locked, because
we just, we just pass in locked there, okay.
And then you say key equals lambda lamda.
I'll explain what this does in a second. x,
x one. And I think that's about it. And we're
actually just gonna reverse this negative
one. Okay. So, for every key in our sorted
list of locked positions, based on the y value,
is what this does. So given a list that looks
like this, if you have like 0100. Okay, given
this a very basic list, this could be an example
of locked positions list, okay? What we're
gonna do is we're gonna sort this list, and
the way we sorted is based on this number
here, this y value, and this is what this
key equals lambda x x one does. Don't have
to understand that this is just really kind
of complex way to sort of list. What we're
gonna do is we're gonna now make it looked
like this 0001. And the way we do that is
that we get all the positions that have the
same y value in like the correct order. Okay?
And you'll see why we need that when we start
coding, okay, so I'm gonna say x, y equals
key because again, remember, key is a tupple.
And we're gonna say, if y is less than ind,
we're gonna say, new key is equal to x comma
y plus IMC and then locked. New key equals
locked dot pop key. Okay, let's, let's dissect
this now, right? Because this is, I told you
guys, this was kind of confusing. So what
we're doing now, if we want to shift every
single position in the grid down, because
when we delete a row, everything above that
needs to move down. So the first part is pretty
straightforward. Okay, so x, y equals keys,
we're simply getting the x&y position of each
key in locked positions. And remember, lock
positions has a key and then corresponding
with that is, okay, straightforward. Now,
what we're gonna do is we're gonna say, if
y is less than IMT, what that means is if
y is if the y value of our key is above the
current index of the row that we removed.
So if we remove for example, row 17, then
only things that are above that are gonna
move down. We don't need to move anything
below row 17 down because we didn't remove
anything after row 17. Right. I mean, shows
us an intro in just a second. Okay, so with
that happen,
In this, what we're gonna do is we're gonna
change a key, we're going to get a new key,
let's say it equals current x value, but we're
going to increment this by a certain value,
so we're going to add a head to the y value
to shift it down. And then we're going to
do is we're going to rewrite, we're going
to create a new key in locked position, which
can have the same color value as the last
key, B, and this will, this gives us the last
current color value, but it's equal to this
position, right? So I'll explain why this
works now kind of withdrawing, and why I needed
to look at this backwards, okay? Because when
we're looking at from bottom to top, there's,
there's a reason for that. Alright, and I
might butcher the explanation, but just kind
of bear with me here for a second because
this is important understand why this works.
And this is the most complex thing. And this
is actually very useful, you might want to
use this a lot like shifting positions in
a dictionary or in a list. Okay, so if I go
back to my little drawing thing here, I go
like this. Okay, so let's create a grid over
here. Let's make it a few more rows this time
just for a better explanation. So 1234, okay,
make it a four by four. And you guys can see
my fancy drawing skills. Let's make this a
row. So let's say we have a row like this
guy, so it's green, make orange. Orange didn't
work. So green can say they're orange, like
this, like this. And like this, and then we'll
add some more colors. Let's do like blue.
Up here, and up here. Okay. So obviously,
this is the row that needs to be cleared that
my mouse is going over right now. Okay, so
this is the row that needs to be cleared.
What happens when we clear this row? Okay,
so we've looked from the bottom of the list
up, and we found if we're looking at row like
four, now looking at row three, we say row
three needs to be clear. Okay, so it's cleared.
So we delete everything out of row three,
right? This row is now gone. So our grid in
memory just looks like this. And this. So
what we need to do now seem to shift these
positions down. But we don't want to shift
these positions. So that's why we're getting
that ind. So we know which position positions
in our grid to shift. So we delete that row.
And then what we're doing is we're adding
one and shifting all these positions down.
Okay, that's a straightforward example. Let's
get rid of this. And let's do this. Okay,
so let's say when we add our, I don't know
shape, whatever to our grid, we end up getting
something that looks like this. Okay, two
rows that need to be shifted down. Now what
we have to do is we have to delete this row
and this row. Now here's the thing, we delete
this row, we delete this row, how many rows
is this now needs to move down? Well, this
needs to move down to rows. So how do we know
how many rows to move this down? How many
rows and everything else above it down? Well,
that is based on our What do you call it increment
here. And that's why whenever we delete a
row, we add one to increment, because we know
that we have to now shifted down another row.
Okay. And that's kind of the way that this
works, if that makes sense. Now, the reason
that we go through and we look at things backwards
is we don't overwrite existing rows. Now,
this is another complex thing, okay. You probably
don't have to really understand this that
much. But anyway, okay, so let's just say
it's not going to let me undo. Okay, that's
fine. So we have this right. Now, here's the
thing, we started looking at it from the top
down to the bottom, what would happen is,
we would so let's actually have to add another
row for this example. That makes sense. So
if I add another row, and I say, Well, okay,
let's add a color. Let's pick yellow, right?
Let's say we have a position here. And we
have a position here, right? So that means
this position, this position, and this position
only to move down. So here's the thing, if
I move this one down by two, alright, or if
I move it down by one, or whatever, it could
possibly overwrite this existing position.
And we don't want that to happen. So what
why we have to start looking at it from the
bottom is that when we start moving everything
down, we move the lowest most things down
first, so that way, when we then change this,
there's no possible way we're gonna overwrite
this right here. Okay? Because remember, if
you in a dictionary, if you change a key and
the key already exists, will you're just gonna
overwrite that key. So that's what we start
looking at it from the bottom. If that doesn't
make sense, don't worry, just, that's for
any of you. That's why okay, because I want
to make sure I explain everything and you
guys understand, at least on some level, why
I'm doing what I'm doing. Okay. So that's
it for the explanation of clear rows. Now,
let's call it function. So when are we going
to call clear rows. Now this is actually an
interesting call. We could call this function,
every loop. But we're only going to call this
when our change piece hits the ground. Now
the reason for this is because you could possibly
be moving On the screen, and at some point,
the grid would have a full row before your
shape actually hit the ground. Now we obviously
know the way in Tetris, when you're moving
down the grid until you like land or you stay
static, we're not clearing anything. So that's
why we're only going to call this if we are
about to change the piece. So clear rows,
what is clear rows take again, I would say
it probably takes grid in locked positions,
maybe, yeah, grid and locked positions. Okay,
so passive, the grid will pass it block positions.
Okay. So then we're checking whenever we're
changing the piece, if we should clear a row,
and this can clear multiple rows at once.
Okay, I'm going to be showing you guys a few
different things. So in the last video, I
mentioned, I was going to be doing more cosmetic
stuff. So that is true. In this video, I'm
going to be showing you how to do the main
menu screen how to draw text in the middle
the screen, how to make things look a little
bit better. And I'm also gonna be adding a
little bit of functionality to the game, in
terms of making the piece fall faster as it
moves, or as time moves forward. So obviously,
you want the game to get more difficult as
time goes on. So what we're going to do to
do that is increase the speed at which the
piece falls on the screen, it's pretty easy,
I'll show you how to do that, I'm going to
be adding score, and we're going to be displaying
that score. And that's probably about it for
this game. So the first thing I want to show
you is how to add the piece falling faster.
So to do this, we need to create a variable
in our main here. And I'm just gonna make
this equal to what do you want to say, fall
or let's say level, underscore time, okay.
And this is gonna just represent how much
time has passed. And it's gonna be similar
to full time and levels, just because as we
increase speed, like the level is going up,
kind of whatever, okay, so say level time
plus equals clock dot get underscore raw time,
and we're gonna do exactly what we did with
making the piece move down the screen, except
we're just gonna change the speed at which
it moves down the screen. So what I'm going
to do here is when I'm making the if statement,
I'm simply gonna say if level underscore time
divided by 1000 is greater than, and then
you can put in whatever time you want here.
Now I'm going to do five seconds. So every
five seconds, we increase the speed, okay.
And then we can decide what we want to increase
the speed by. So I'm going to say level underscore
time, we need to first reset this back to
zero so that we continue to do this. And then
what I'm going to actually do here is going
to say, if level,
underscore time is greater than, and we want
to put like a terminal velocity here. So at
what speed do we stop increasing the time
because we obviously we can't get to a negative
false speed, otherwise, you're just going
to instantly fall. And we don't want it to
get too fast that the game is unplayable.
So we need to pick a speed. Now a good speed
that I kind of found was 0.12. Because anything
faster than that is like pretty fast. But
I mean, you guys can play with that and change
that around, it's really easy number just
fix right. And then if we're greater than
that, we're just simply going to subtract
a value from level underscore time. Now this
value, the magnitude to the size of this value
that you're subtracting is going to determine
like how quickly you increase the speed as
well as obviously the time. So I put originally
0.01. And I mean, depending on how long it
takes you to play a Tetris game, this is pretty
fast, because that means after 50 seconds,
you're already going to be down to 0.17, which
is very quick and almost a terminal velocity.
So I recommend you do 0.005. That means it'll
take about a minute and 40 seconds before,
you're going to be close to reaching this
terminal velocity, which might be good if
you're playing Tetris for a decent time. Okay,
so you guys can play with those numbers. But
that is he is going to move it down faster,
I would show you but it's going to take like
a decent amount of time for it to continue
moving faster to just play with that. Okay,
just trust me. All right, the next thing we
want to do is add score. So we need to first
create a score variable and as a score is
equal to zero like that. an incorrect score
is pretty simple, I'm going to say and you
guys can make this whatever you want. Whenever
we clear a row, I'm going to add 10 to our
score, because you had 10 pieces or 10 cubes
or whatever that you cleared. Okay, so actually,
the way that we need to do this is we're gonna
return a value from clear rows, which is going
to be equal to score. Now I'm going to go
to clear rows, and in here, I'm simply just
going to return I NC, okay. And I NC is the
increments, so how many rows that we actually
ended up clearing. So if we clear the one
row, we're going to get a value of two, we
can multiply that by whatever our score increments
going to be. And then yeah, we can just add
that to the score. So this is pretty straightforward.
If we go to clear rows, we're gonna say score
is equal to clear rows, multiplied by 10.
All right, we're actually not equal to we're
gonna have to say plus equal to clearos plus
10. Now what we need to do is we need to display
this score on the screen, somehow. The user
can see that we're actually going to save
the score as well when we lose the game. Okay,
so the way that we can display this is we're
gonna have to do the intro window, but we're
gonna have to pass the score to draw into.
So after our grid object, we're going to pass
score like that. And we're going to go to
draw window. And we're simply going to add
another parameter here score like that. Now
I'm just gonna set it equal to zero as a default
parameter. So in case we call it somewhere
else, and we forget to add that score, that's
fine, we don't need that. So what I'm going
to do now is I'm actually going to go to draw
next shape and draw next shape. You can see
if I run the program quickly here, it shows
us a little text object, okay? Now I want
to get this similar text object. So I'm just
going to copy this font, the label sx s, y.
And I'm just going to bring it down here into
draw window. Now it doesn't really matter
where you draw it, I'm going to plop it in
the middle here. And obviously, I'm going
to change this from next shape to be
score.
Now we need to obviously display what the
actual score is. So we can just say plus STr
score, like that, and that should be displaying
for us. Okay, so now we have s x and s y,
which is giving us the play area, I believe
we're no this is actually the position in
which we want it to draw it. Okay, so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to say now when
dot Blitz, or is it surface surface,
Blitz,
our text object, which is the label, and then
where do we want to draw it to draw sx s y.
Now, I'm just going to have a look up here
to see where I did it here. So that's x plus
10, s y minus 30. So what I might want to
do is, we can add plus time to this, so it's
aligned, but then we're gonna subtract, or
actually add to the y, so it's lower. So I'm
going to add, let's say like 80. Like that.
So let's test this out and see if it's working.
Score, so it's not low enough. So we'll add
this and do 120. And see where we're getting
enough score. Again, not low enough. Let's
go 160. And again, you guys can play with
these, our score equals zero, perfect. And
then maybe we'll just add 10 more pixels here.
So it's more in the center. And you know,
whatever, that's good enough for me. Okay.
Good. So that is working well. So we've got
the score, and we're moving down faster. Now,
what else do we need to do? What we need to
do now is work in main menu and figure out
what happens when we actually lose the game.
So we have this check last, and all this simply
does is just quit the game for us when that
happens. But we want to do something else
when we lose, and we want to display something
to the screen. So actually, before I go on
Main Menu, I'm going to go up here to a function
that I told you guys, I need to get rid of
that, that I was going to finish, which is
draw text in middle. Now this is going to
take a surface
text.
And what else do we want, say size and color.
Okay, so surface text size color, this way,
you can use this in another function or sorry,
in another program, and you can use them multiple
times with whatever text size and color you
want. So we're going to set up a font and
say font equals pi game, dot font dot s, y
s followed by now you probably know this,
I'm just gonna pick Comic Sans, we're gonna
make it equal to size and bold is going to
be equal to true. Now, you can make this false
if you want, or just omit it completely, and
then it won't make it bold, pretty straightforward.
Make a label label is equal to again, font
dot render. And then we're gonna say text,
one for anti aliasing and color, like this.
Okay, now we'll just simply draw this in the
middle of the screen. So to do this, we'll
say surface uplit. label, comma, and now we're
just gonna do a little bit of math here. So
top underscore, left, underscore x plus play
underscore width divided by two, not three
minus, and we're gonna get the label width.
And the way we do this, I don't believe I've
actually done this yet, is get underscore
width, I think I'm just gonna check Yeah,
get width. And then the reason I have this
in brackets, because I'm going to divide this
by two as well. And this will essentially
give us the middle position where we should
be drawing in terms of x squared, okay, so
now I'm going to give top underscore left
y plus play underscore height divided by two.
Okay, and now same thing minus label dot get
underscore height in brackets and divided
by two. I don't know why kids tab over here,
okay. divided by two. And that should hopefully
be working for us. Okay, so we can test that
in just a second. So we've got this, it's
bleeding now, whatever text we want to the
screen. So this makes it really easy for us
to draw anything to the middle of the screen.
So the first thing I want to draw to the middle
of the screen is like a you lost message.
So when it says you've lost, what I want to
do is draw obviously, you lost and tell them
so let's say draw, text, the middle. And then
what do we want to draw? Well, let's simply
draw what surface first actually that we need.
So we'll say when And then we're going to
pass it text. And in this case, we're gonna
say you lost exclamation point, size. Let's
go for AV, and color. Let's go white. And
obviously, you guys can play around with that.
Now after I draw that, and I display the screen,
or update the screen, pi game dot display
dot update, just because we haven't called
the window yet, draw window when we do this,
then what we're going to do is we're just
going to delay, so we're gonna say pi game
dot time dot delay. And I'm just gonna delay
one and a half seconds, just so once this
comes up, the user has a second to look at
it, because then we're gonna move back into
our main menu screen, which you'll see. Okay,
so I'm just gonna fast forward this until
I lose, and then you guys can see that it's
working. And there we go. So we got you lost,
and then it delayed, and then just quit because
I have this pygame dot display dot quit here.
Okay. So now what we're going to move to his
main menu, everything else is working. I told
you guys snot, like super difficult. While
this stuff in main menu, what we're going
to do now is we're just going to make it pop
up whenever you start the game. And whenever
you lose, it's just going to say hit any key
to, like, move forward to continue. Okay,
so once you set another game loop in here,
so we're gonna say run equals true. Well run,
and this is gonna be really similar to the
loop we've done above, it's just step just
a lot shorter, we're, and we're going to just
draw in here, without using a different function,
just because we're not drawing very much.
So it's not important that we would call it
like, update the screen with a defined function.
So I'm just gonna fill it with blocks, we
cover getting rid of everything, we're gonna
draw text middle. And what I'm going to do
here is I'm gonna say press any key to play,
okay. And then we'll give this a size of 60,
and a color of white once again. Okay, so
that's being drawn in the middle, we'll update
the display, so pygame dot display dot update,
like that. And then we're gonna say, for event
in PI game, dot event tickets are similar
to what we've already typed up top, we're
going to say, if event dot type equals equals
pi, game dot quit, we always want one of these,
not quit Q, then we're simply going to say
run.
Oops, run is equal to false. And then we can
tab out here, and we can just make sure that
we are actually quitting the display. So dot
quit. And we'll get rid of this pygame dot
display dot quit. And then we're gonna add
one more event, and this event is going to
be a key down. So whenever they press any
key on the keyboard, then that is going to
move this forward. And we're simply going
to call this main function where we'll play
and I'll explain how this kind of flows in
just a second because it's really nice. Okay,
so if event dot type equals equals pi, game
dot, all capitals, key down, so if they hit
any key, then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna say main, like that. Okay? And I believe
that is about it. Okay, yeah. So let's see
here. pygame dot display quit, looks correct.
Okay. So the way this is gonna work pretty
much is when we run the game, we start by
running main menu. So we run main menu, and
then we go into this main loop, where all
its gonna do is just say press any key to
play, and that's going to be drawn in the
middle of the screen. Once that happens, we're
going to check if they're hitting any key,
if they hit any key, we're going to call mate,
in which case, or let me close this, so it's
easier to see. If we hit main, then we go
into the main game loop, and we go in, we
do this loop until eventually we lose. Once
we lose, it displays you lost on the screen,
makes this loop equal to false, which means
it brings us back into this main menu loop.
And we can play again by hitting any key.
Pretty straightforward. Okay, so let's test
this out to make sure this is working. Draw
text missing one potential argument color.
Because I didn't give a surface My bad. So
let's just do win. And there we go. Okay,
so press any key to play. Press space missing
one, mate. Sorry, guys. So this is why we
tested Perfect. Okay, when. And now let's
try. There we go. And now we're playing shows
the score, and you guys can mess around, I
haven't actually tested the score. So I'll
just do this really quickly and see if I can
clear row without having to fast forward.
Which we may be able to do
not using that one.
Okay, let's see. There we go. And score is
equal to 10. So the score system is working
as well. And that's relief, because I hadn't
even tested that before I put this in the
video. Okay, perfect. Oh, when you press the
X brings you to press any key to play. If
you press it again, you can do that. So if
we wanted to change it, so when you hit the
X key in the main thing, and you want to close
the game, then in the main loop here, sorry,
what are you going to do instead of saying
runnicles false just to high game. Display
dot quit. So you can do both the and say run
equals false and then you can quit the display
as well. Okay, so what's next? So I said we
were going to save the score and potentially
display that So if we want to save the score,
we're gonna have to do something when we lose,
so we're gonna have to update, like the current
score. And we're gonna use a text file to
do this so that you can play multiple times.
So what I'm gonna do, I'm gonna say new file,
to create a new text file, I'm just gonna
call this scores dot txt. Okay, and here,
I'm just gonna put zero as a default value,
it's really important you put a default value
to start, otherwise, you might run into some
issues. So just create a new text file, make
sure it's in your directory with the mean,
with the script, okay? Now, what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to create another function
doesn't really matter where it goes from,
say, define, update underscore score, and
we're going to give it score. Okay? Now and
here, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
say, with open, and this is how we're going
to open our text file and like update and
display with open scores dot txt, in our so
in read mode, and this action needs to be
in quotation marks as well, we're going to
say,
F,
F, do this as f sorry, say F dot read lines
like this, okay. And that'll be equal to lines,
is equal to F dot read lines. So that means
our score is going to be, well, the first
line, so score is equal to lines, zero. And
we're gonna add this dot strip, so that we
remove any like backslash ends, because if
you don't know, in a text file, when you hit
the next line, the way that it actually tracks
that you have another line is it puts a character
that looks like this, on the line, it's invisible
to you in the text file when you're viewing
it. But when you read it in with code, you're
actually reading this character. So we just
want to make sure we strip that off, in case
it is there. We're gonna say score equals
this, and then we'll just set Okay, so we've
done that. And since we're tabbing out now,
it'll, it's going to automatically close our
file, what we're going to do now is we're
going to open the file again, except in this
time, we're gonna open it right mode, which
means we're going to overwrite whatever is
in the file. And we're simply gonna say, if
score is, I guess I'm gonna change this to
and score standing for new score, if score
is greater than n score, then we'll say F
dot, and we'll say write lines, actually,
right, I think, and we'll simply put in str
of score, which is this update score, otherwise,
so if that's not true, we just have to write
back the other score, because we're clearing
it when we open this with w mode. Okay, so
we're gonna say F dot write, and then we're
sorry, this is gonna be limiting, and n square.
Yeah, sorry. So I kind of messed up in this
way, it should be the other way around. But
whatever. We're just checking if the original
score is greater than the new score, if it
is, we'll write the original score, otherwise,
we'll write the new score. So this works still,
it just not the way that I was thinking about
it when I was kind of talking about that.
Okay, so update score
should work.
And then you can actually return, let's just
return actually, now we don't need to return
anything. So I haven't pre written this yet.
So I'm kind of still just going through how
I want it to work. Okay. All we'll do here,
after we start running equal to false, we'll
say update score, and we'll give it whatever
the current score is. And then it should be
working in the scores dot txt file. So let's
run this. I'll fast forward through and make
sure everything's working. Okay, so we go
they're not supported between insists of string
and int, okay, so if score greater than sports,
which means we have to convert the student.
So if we go back up to score, and where did
I make this, okay? Score is going to be int
score, like that. Okay. And that should hopefully
work because n score comes in as an int. And
we'll run a one time one more fast forward.
Sorry about that, guys.
Okay, and another issue lines, zero, Linda,
list index out of range. Okay, I'm gonna have
a look at this and come back. Okay, so this
code is actually working just fine. The issue
was that since last time, when it crashed,
we didn't end up writing anything into the
file. So we had a blank file, and then we
were going lines zero, where is it here, and
obviously, there was no line zero, so that
crashed. But if you just add any numbers like
that, add zero back in here, two squares dot
txt and save it, then this works fine. Okay,
so that's it for saving scores. Now we need
to display those same scores. So I'm coming
in to leave this up to you guys where you
want to display it, I don't really know where
I want to put my same score, like high score,
maybe on the left side of the screen. Doesn't
really matter. So if I want to draw it on
the left side of the screen, then I can do
something like, we're gonna have to first
get this max score, right? So I'm gonna have
to make a new function called define, Max
score, or last score, whatever you want to
call it. And if you call max score, what we're
gonna do is we're just gonna do the exact
same thing we did here. So we can say with
open source text, source zero slot zero dot
strip, except in this time, we're going to
return a
score
like that. Okay? Now, we actually do here
too is we can just simply replace this whole
line with Max score and just say, score equals
max score. really efficient way to do it.
And I mean, feel free to do that if you want
or leave it the other way. Okay, so now we
have something that's getting us back score.
So how are we going to use this? Well, when
we call mean, I guess when we call me or we
can call Main Menu does it like you guys,
if you want to draw it on the main menu, you
can do that otherwise, straw didn't mean to
draw it in the main, all you're gonna do is
gonna say like last
score is equal to max score, which is going
to be whatever it is stored in that text file.
And then to draw this old, we're gonna have
to pass this again, into when we're redrawn
window. So in draw window, I'm just gonna
say, last score, we can go up to draw window
again, say, last underscore score equals zero.
And you're pretty much gonna copy exactly
what we have here, with this font, and the
split. So let me just call it out this and
say, This is correct score. So I remember,
you had a comment, say, last score, high score,
whatever you want to say here. And then we
can just say score. And we can actually get
rid of this font, because we already defined
it will say, high score equals, and in this
case, last underscore score, okay? Draw that
to the screen, this is probably not where
you want to draw it, you probably want to
draw it, top left x, minus, like some value
minus 30, top left y, maybe Plus, I don't
know, like 300, or something. So now we can
see where this is actually going to draw if
we check this out. So let's run this, press
any key. So it's not obviously showing up
where we want to, we're gonna have to subtract
more from this. So let's subtract like,
I don't know
100.
And then this was plus too much c plus 200.
And high score. So again, like you got to
move it over more. So we'll move over 200
this time, and hopefully this works. Okay,
so high score zero score zero. And that's
obviously because at the current moment, we
have no, or our score is just zero in that
text file. Okay, so I think that is pretty
much it for this video. So essentially, this
is online game development with Python, which
means we're going to be using sockets and
networking to connect what's known as a client
and a server or multiple clients to a server,
where they can send and share information.
And therefore we can create an online game.
So we're going to start off with just the
absolute basics and just get shapes. For example,
like if I move a shape on my computer, it
moves a shape on your computer, like if you're
the other client, and then we'll start getting
into some more advanced stuff where we create
a legitimate game and start sending massive
amounts of information to the server, and
back to the client. So we'll start really
simply by just getting everything working
on our local network. And then once it's working
on our local network, we'll deploy that to
an external server, which will allow us to
play from anywhere in the world, not just
against people on our local network. Okay,
so what I'm showing you right now is actually
an online game that I created with Python
pi game and networking. And this is similar,
something we're gonna make obviously not as
advanced, but it works on the same principles.
So essentially, I have what is known as two
clients. Now if you don't know, the way that
any online game works is we have multiple
clients connecting to one main location, which
is known as a server. Now right here on my
screen, we have two clients. So this client
on the left that my mouse is kind of going
over that has this red highlight the way the
rook is, or where I just didn't vote to move
this night is client one, and then this block
one over here. So like your block, where I
just moved this pawn is client two. Now you
can see in the background, I have this command
line thing going and it's sending and receiving
information. And this is essentially how a
online game works. And you might see, whatever
you guys playing online game, it says waiting
for server we're connecting to server. And
that's because it's doing exactly that. It's
waiting to get a connection to the server
and then grab information from that. So that's
the way that we're going to be doing things
is using the client and server. Now I'm not
going to be using any frameworks that are
pre created, like, I know there's like twisted
and some other frameworks for Python, the
only module we're going to be using the external
is pi game and that's just to create some
very basic graphics. Okay, so let's close
this, I just want to give you guys an example
of what an online game looks like. And you
could see when I was moving something on one
client, it would move it on the other. So
let's close that up. And let's actually get
started with the tutorial did not mean to
open up. So I'm going to be working with PI
charm for this tutorial. Now if you don't
know what pi charm is, it's an ID. To download
it. All you have to do is just go to the internet.
Type pi charm. And you can go here and click
Download whenever it loads up. Now, if you
guys don't want to use PI charm, that's absolutely
fine. You can do everything using the standard
editor like ideally you can use atom, Muse,
whatever you want. But if you want to follow
exactly what the tutorial I'm going to be
using pi charm. Now the next thing we're going
to need other than it, I guess you don't need
pi charm is we're going to have to install
pi game. Now for 90% of you, the way that
you're going to be able to install pi game
is just by going to command prompt, loading
it up like this and just typing pip install
pi game, and then hitting Enter. Now, if this
doesn't work for you, I'll put a card in the
top right hand corner of the screen right
now, which tells you where you can go to install
pi game. And I have a video explaining you
exactly how to do this. And if this command
doesn't work for you can follow that video,
and I'll explain to you how to do that. So
once we have pygame, then we're ready to actually
start writing a bit of code. So while I launch
up pi charm right here and create a new project,
let me just tell you about, I don't know some
of the things we'll be going through in this
tutorial series. So obviously, we're going
to be working on coding both a client and
a server. And I'm going to explain obviously,
exactly how those things work, and how we
can create them. And then what we're going
to be doing is we're going to be dealing with
a bit of server like administration, if you
want to say that. So actually deploying things
to an external server, stalling in pen, installing
dependencies, working with like a Linux server
to deploy our game to and that will be at
the end of the series that we do that right
now we're just gonna be working with what's
known as local host, which means that we're
just gonna be doing it on our own network.
So right now, the games that we create are
only going to work on our, what do you call
it against people that are on our Wi Fi or
on the same network as us, and then later,
it'll work against anyone in the world that
has that client downloaded? Okay, so let's
just create a new project here, my new project,
I'm just gonna say is tutorial, let's say
network tutorial waters.
And just as a, what do you call it here, just
letting you guys know, I did actually mess
up my thumb a little bit. It's kind of swan.
So if my typing is not the best, that is actually
my excuse for that. So now that I've got a
new project opened, I'm just gonna create
a new Python file. Let's call this tutorial.
One, actually, let's call this client, okay.
And just save that as okay, because that's
all we're going to be coding in this video
is just a very basic client. Okay, so now
we've got client. So what I'm going to start
off by doing is creating a configuration for
my client. And keep in mind, if you guys are
using something else, you don't have to worry
about what I'm doing with this pie chart specifics.
This just the way you have to set up a project
in PI charm. So I'm just gonna set a client,
I'm going to go to script path network game
client. Okay, apply. Okay. Now, quick side
note, all the code that I'm about to write
is available on my website tech with Tim dotnet.
Usually I have as well as that a text based
tutorial version. I'm not sure if I'm gonna
be able to write the text based tutorial.
Well, this first tutorial is out. But you
will see it on there at some point input tutorial
import pi game. But yeah, all the code will
be available on there in case you guys missed
something or something's not working. So we're
going to start by importing pi game and make
sure that that's working. Once that's working,
we're going to create a window. So to do that,
we'll just say, when equals pi game, dot display
dot update, or what am I saying pi game dot
display dot set underscore cap set underscore
mode. Wow, bit tired today guys. And then
in here, which can type width, and height,
and then we're going to create these variables.
So say width equals 500. Height equals 500.
Okay, so there we go with height when and
now we're just gonna set up a few global variables
we're gonna have to use after we create a
caption, so let's just say
login,
dot display, dot set underscore caption. And
then in here, we'll just go to caption, let's
just say,
client. Okay? Alright, so
now let's set up a global variable that we're
gonna use. And what we're gonna do for this
global variables, it's gonna hold the current
like clients, we're gonna say, like client
number. I want to start by making that zero,
but we're going to increment that based on
like, once we connect to the server, which
we'll do later. Okay, so now that we've done
that, there's a few basic things. This is
what we always do for like a PI game project
or whatnot. I'm just gonna define redraw window.
Okay, and in here, all we're going to do is
just pi game dot display dot update, like
that. And we'll also fill the display before
we do that, oops, didn't mean to do that.
With when dot fill, and it will just pick
a color. In this case, I want to do whites
which is 255-250-5255. Okay, now Yeah, I just
realized this is actually gonna be a lot harder
to type than I thought because my thumb so
just excuse me guys, if I'm making a few mistakes
here. Okay, so we got our redraw window now
and what we can do next is We can code our
main loop. So I'm going to say define main.
And then here I'm just going to create a game
loop. And this is going to run continuously
while I program is going and it's just gonna
be what's checking for collision checking
for events can constantly asking the server
for information, and you guys will see how
this works in later videos more. So we're
gonna say run equals true. And then here,
we'll say well run. And we'll just set up
some very basic things that we always do for
pygame. So for event in PI game dot, event,
dot get, okay. And then we're gonna do say,
if event dot type equals equals pi game dot
quit with all capitals, then we'll simply
do pi game dot quit like that. Don't need
a semicolon, I guess we can say run equals
false as well.
Okay, for events, that looks good. And then
what else we'll do in here is we'll just call
that redraw window function. So redraw window
like that. Now, what I'm thinking we should
do next is probably set up a class for our
character, okay, now our character is going
to be just the only object we're working with
right now. And it's just going to represent
like a rectangle that moves like left out
up right around our screen. And I guess we'll
do that all in this video moving that character
around, and that will connect it to the server,
the next one. So let's create a class. And
we'll do that up here. And we'll say, class
player like that. Okay, so we'll give it a
knit function. If you guys don't know much
about object oriented programming, and programming,
and you want to learn, I do have a tutorial
series on my channel that I would recommend
you go through if you don't understand a lot
of the stuff that I'm doing right now. Okay.
So x, y width heights will be what we get
in here, this is just going to represent,
actually, let's give it a color as well, because
it'll be good to have X, Y, width, height,
color. And yeah, this will just represent
kind of our player and what variables they're
gonna have. So we'll pass these values in
when we create an Eclair. So self dot y equals
y. This is very straightforward. self dot
width equals width, and self dot height, equals
height. And finally, self dot color, equals
color. So these are just our initialization
here, this is what we're going to use when
we're drawing the character when we're checking
for collision or stuff like that. And what
I'm also going to do to save us a bit of time
in the future, I'm gonna say self dot rect
equals and then in here, let's do this, okay,
so x,
y,
width, height like that, okay. And this will
just make it a bit faster when we're trying
to draw our character. So the next thing we're
gonna need is define draw. Now, in the draw
method, here, we're going to take a window,
so we'll call that when, and all we're going
to do is just draw a rectangle that represents
our character onto the screen, and obviously
be the appropriate color. So to do that, all
we have to do is just say, when.oh. No, we
don't see that we have to pygame dot draw
dot rect. standing for rectangle, we have
to first give the window so we'll give when
we need the color. So we'll do self dot color.
And then we need a rect, which will be self
dot rect. Okay, and that's actually all we
need to do to draw the rectangle to the screen.
Now we need one more method we're going to
use and it's going to be called move. And
move Actually, I believe, yeah, we don't need
to do anything else in there. Right now as
the argument sorry. So for move, what this
is going to do, is it essentially just gonna
check. What do you call it? If they press
like left key, right key whatnot? How can
we move them around the screen? So the way
that we can do this really, basically, essentially
is just do pygame.
Dot,
what do you call it dot keys, dot get underscore,
pressed, I believe that's it might be key
might be keys, we'll see. We'll see which
one works. So this is essentially going to
give us a list of all of the keys, actually
a dictionary of all the keys. And essentially,
each key is going to have a value of either
zero or one. Now, if one is true, that means
we're currently pressing the key, if zero
is there, that means we're not pressing the
key. So the way that this is useful, as opposed
to doing what we could sometimes do, which
is just check for events. And here is if you're
pressing more than one key at once, it'll
allow you to move like diagonally or whatnot.
Okay, so what we can do in here now is we
can just check if certain keys are pressed,
and then change the x and y values accordingly.
So we'll say if, what do you call it? Oh,
I guess we should probably put this in a variable.
Let's say keys equals pi game dot. Maybe I
feel like it's key, we're gonna go key for
pi game dot key, don't get on a script. So
say if keys and then pi game, dot k underscore
left standing for our left arrow key. And
that's all we need to do for that one. And
then we'll say if keys and then pi game dot
k, underscore is this should this be all capitals,
I think it should be k underscore, right.
And then the next one, if keys, pi game dot
k underscore up, and then our last one obviously
is down. And then we'll change our values
accordingly inside of these if statements,
so pygame dot k underscore. Okay, so left
right up, down. So if we press the left arrow
key, obviously, we have to do a subtract from
our x value. So to do that, we'll just say
self dot x minus equals self dot Val. Now,
Val is something we need to define. So let's
do that up here, self dot Val equals, and
let's do a value of like three for right now.
Okay, so if we're going to write we need to
add to our x, so we'll do this very similar.
So self dot x plus plus equals self dot Val.
Okay, if I could type that correctly, and
then to go up, we're going to subtract from
our y value, so self dot y minus equals self
dot Val. And to go down, we'll do self dot
y plus equals self dot Val. And that's the
way the coordinate system works in pygame,
our coordinates actually at the top left hand
of our player or a screen, so if we want to
go down, we have to add to it and then left
and right is the same in terms of subtracting
and adding, okay, so that should successfully
move our player, we could add like a jump
and stuff in here at another time. But for
right now, that's all we need. I'm trying
to think of anything else that we could do
right? Now, we should probably create a player
object and draw that to the screen just to
make sure everything's working. So to do that,
let's create a player. Should we do it up
here, let's do it right above our main loop
here. Okay. So we're just gonna say, actually,
we'll do it inside the main that this will
work better. We'll say p saying for player
just equals player, and then we'll give it
some values in x, y with high color. So for
x, y, we'll just start them out like 5050.
And then for width, let's just do 100 by 100.
So he's nice and big, and we can see him and
then we'll do a color of green. So that would
be red, green, blue, like that. So 255, for
green. And then what we're going to do actually,
is we're gonna type in here, insert in redraw
window, we're just going to pass p to our
redraw window so that we can draw him. And
before we do that, we'll call p dot move.
And what this will do is move our character
based on what keys we're pressing. So inside
redraw window, let's add a player. What do
you call it? argument attribute, whatever
you want to call that. Sorry, parameter. That's
the correct name. And then we'll just say
player dot draw, like that. And we'll pass
winning here, which probably should be passed
in here as well, because we do use wind quite
a bit. So let's do P. Let's do when and then.
Okay, so let's run this now and see if I made
any mistakes I likely did. Process finished,
oh, we never calling the main function. So
let's call this main function from down here.
So we're actually executing that code that
we wrote. And there we go. So now we have
a little green square. And you can see, Hmm,
interesting, it's not working for me to move
this around. So let's check this one more
time. P dot move, what is move doing get pressed.
Let's just add, I want to add something here
and make sure this is working. So let's, we're
gonna say clock
equals pi game.
dot time, dot clock. Okay. And then in here,
we're just gonna do clock,
dot tick. And we'll do 60 FPS, I just want
to see if this is working. If not, I do know
how to fix this. Okay, so we're not able to
actually move this. Oh, I know why. So very
interesting. We are not updating this rect.
But we are updating. What do you call it like,
up, down, left, right. So at the bottom here,
all we're gonna do is just redefine our rect
by doing self dot x, self dot y, self dot
width, and self dot height. Now I'll really
quickly explain why this error was happening.
Essentially, we're defining rect up here based
on the input parameters when we're creating
our player. So that means we're always just
constantly drawing our rectangle in the same
position, because we're never updating this
rect variable, we're only updating like x,
y, width, height, right. So we just have to
redefine our rect variable every single time
that we're moving, which is fine. And we can
do that. So now let's see. And we can move
our green square around the screen, I actually
quite like the speed this movement. So yeah,
so essentially, in the next video, we'll we're
going to be doing it so I'm wrapping it up
here is we'll add a little bit more to this
client. And then we'll start working with
sockets. So we can connect this up to a server.
And we'll start talking about all the networking
aspects. And then so in this tutorial, we're
going to be working on coding the server.
And then in the next video, we're going to
be connecting this client that we made in
the last one to that server and then sending
information to and from the server. So let's
get started. And let's create a new file that
is going to be our server file. So I'll just
call this one server.pi. And then in here,
we're just gonna have to import a few things.
I'll talk about exactly what they're gonna
do for us once we start using them. So let's
start by importing sockets, our socket, then
we can import underscore thread and We'll
also import OS. Okay, so actually not sorry.
That's why Yes, that's all we need for that.
So what we're going to be doing, like I've
talked about is we're going to be using sockets
and threading, to handle connections to our
server. And essentially, what that means is
we're going to set up a socket, and it's going
to allow for connections to come into our
server on a certain port. So we're gonna start
by just defining server, which is going to
be a string, and port, which is going to be
a number. Now for port, you guys probably
know what ports are, you might have heard
of them before, for example, like a common
port you would use on or common port that
is used on your on your router would be Port
80. And that is for HTTP connections. There's
also a port like 443, there's there's tons
of other ports that have distinct uses. But
there's also a ton of ports that don't have
any uses and that are just left open for programs
like this, or for different things to be used
for. So what port I'm going to use, which
is typically open, it depends on like what
router you're using and your internet connection.
But typically a port that's open is 5555.
So we're going to use this port to connect
to and from and it's just a safe port to use,
as opposed to trying to use another number
that we might not know if it's being used
for something else or not. Okay, so once we've
done that we've created a server and create
a port we're going to do is we're going to
set up what's known as a socket, okay, and
we'll talk about exactly how this works in
a second. But we're just gonna say s equals
socket, dot socket. And then here, we're going
to type something that's probably gonna mean
nothing to you, but I'll talk about what it
means. So we'll say, socket equals AF, underscore,
eye net, okay. And then socket dot sock stream
like that. All right. Now, these are just
the types of connection. So since we're going
to be connecting to a ipv4 address, which,
again, we're gonna keep talking about all
this stuff, as we go through in case you guys
are unfamiliar with networks, this is the
type we're gonna have to use and sock stream
just I believe, represents, like how the server
string comes in. I could be wrong on that.
But this is the type we're gonna use. And
for any kind of applications like this, this
will be what you use for your socket. Okay,
so we're just initializing that. And now the
next thing to do is to bind our server and
our port to the socket. So to do this, we
need to do a try and accept. And the reason
we do this is because like I talked about,
we don't know if this is actually going to
work on initially doing it, there could be
in some instance, this port is already being
used for something. And if that's happening,
that means that this is going to fail. So
we need to try and accept this. So it will
accept, what do you call it? error as he said,
when we say socket dot error, as he will just
print that out to the screen, just so we know
why we're not working there. Otherwise, what
we'll do is we'll say s dot bind, and then
in here, we're going to put server comma ports.
Okay, so we'll bind to whatever IP address
we'll put in here, to this given port. Okay,
so I hope everything's making sense so far.
Essentially, what we're doing when we do sockets,
is we're setting up a connection or we're
using a port on our server on our network,
it's going to look for certain connections.
And then we'll be doing this on the client
side as well will be binding or not enough
will be binding, we'll just be connecting
to a certain server at a port. And then since
we're connecting to that this server script
that we're gonna have running will see that
connection and handle it in some way. Okay,
so now that we've done that, I'm trying to
think what else we have to do. Okay, so what
we're gonna start by doing is we're gonna
start listening for connections. So we're
gonna do s dot Listen, now. So listen, essentially
just opened up the port. So now we can start
connecting to it and having multiple clients
connecting and whatnot. So in here, this actually
takes one argument. Now it's optional. And
if you leave it blank, it means it'll allow
for unlimited connections to happen. Now,
depending on what kind of program you're writing,
is, what you're going to do for this now for
me, I only want two people to be able to connect
to my, what do you call it? Yeah, to my server.
So we're just going to do s dot listen to
Now this might actually be one because it
might be like 01, but I think to maybe the
correct thing, so do s dot listen for now.
And then what we're gonna do is we're going
to print after we've listened, we'll just
say waiting for connection. And we'll say,
server started or something like that. Because
once we get to this point, we are running
the server and everything actually is working
like we're listening for connection, we're
ready to go. Okay, so the next thing we're
going to do is, we're going to define something
known as a threaded function. Okay. And we'll,
I'll talk about again what this means. But
let's just do threaded threaded underscore
client for now. And I'm just putting, you
don't actually have to name it this you can
name it whatever you want. I'm just putting
threaded here just so we know. This is threaded,
and then it's going to take one argument which
is going to be co nn, which stands for action
and let's just pass in there for right now.
So the way that threading works, actually,
let's, let's do the threading. And then we'll
talk about how it works. So they'll probably
make a bit more sense. So let's do a while
true down here. Okay, so once we set up our
server, our port we bind it doing here, we're
starting to listen waiting for connections
starting the server, then we're going to do
is we'll be get put into this while loop.
And what this while loop will do is will continuously
look for connections, okay? Because right
here, we're just listening, like once right
to see if anything's on that server port.
But down here, we want to continually try
to grab connection to see if somebody's connected.
And if it does, then we want to print something
to the screen are we gonna send information
are we gonna start a new thread, which we'll
talk about in a second. So in here, what we're
gonna do is gonna say connection, which co
nn and then ADR equals and then s dot, and
then we'll say accept. And what s dot accept
is going to do is it's going to well accept
any incoming connections. And then it's going
to store the connection and the address. And
the connection is, by the way, an object representing
like, what's connected, the address is going
to be an IP address in these variables. So
if we get a connection, what we'll do is we'll
say, print
connected to Okay, and then ATR. And this
is going to show us what IP address is actually
connecting. So we can have a look at that.
And then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
do start underscore new underscore thread.
And then in here, we're going to do, what
was that name of the function that we had
was threading clients. Okay, and I believe
we do, comma, and that in brackets here, we
do see, like that. Okay, so start new thread.
Is there a reason that's not working? Give
me a second, I want to see why
oh,
that's why. So up here, instead of saying
import thread, we're gonna say from underscore
thread, import star. Okay, and that's just
gonna make it so we can just do start new
thread thing. And you know, what, I don't
know if we're gonna need this S y s, but let's
just leave it there for now. Okay, so let's
talk about what reading is gonna do. So essentially,
the way that you guys are used to programs
working, I'm assuming, unless you have some
familiarity with threading is that say, we're
in this while loop, right, and we were to
call the function thread client.
Well,
before we continue going with this while loop,
we would have to wait until this function
was done running. In other words, we return
back from this function, some value, or, for
example, like he does, like x equals five,
we would have to wait for this x equals five
to execute, and then it would come back in
this while loop and keep going. Now, we don't
want that to happen, because we're going to
be having multiple connections going at once.
So what we want to do is we want to start
what's called a thread and the thread is just
another process that's running in the background.
So that just means when we do start new thread,
and we do threaded client, it's going to run
this function, but it's not going to need
this function to finish executing before it
continues the while loop. So this is going
to be running in the background as like process
two, while process one is still running and
still going. So that means say we connect
to 100 different things, we're going to have
100 different functions running. So 100 different
threaded clients on the stock or like keep
going. And then what we're going to have is
this while loop still continuing to go, what
did I just do, still continuing to run to
look for another possible connection, you
guys will see more how this works, but essentially
just means this will run in the background.
And we don't have to wait for it to finish
executing before we can accept another connection.
That's the basic kind of a way to that works.
So now let's start working with threaded client.
And then we will test the server out and see
if it's working. And then obviously in next
video, we're going to connect to it and do
all the connection stuff. Okay. So in here,
threaded client. So what should happen when
we connect to a client? Well, we're going
to have to do a while up in here. So we're
gonna say well, true. Because we want this
to continually run well, our client is still
connected, okay? Now, what we're also going
to do is, we're just going to say reply equals
blank like that. I'm just copying from my
other screen, because this one is a bit finicky.
I don't want to mess it up. We're going to
put a try in here. And then we're going to
say is we're going to try to receive some
kind of data from our connection. Okay, from
whoever's connected, we want to receive some
kind of data. So what we'll do is we'll say,
I believe it's s con dot receive. That might
be right. Yeah, I think that's right. And
then here, we're gonna put the amount of bits,
okay. Now, if you guys know anything about
computing, you know, like how what bits represents,
but essentially, this is the amount of information
we're trying to receive. Now, if you're getting
an error, when say you'd like do this and
you connect up and you get some error that
says,
What do you call it?
Like object was true answer like you're getting
any errors just increase this size, okay?
And you can just do that by like putting this
like time Ate or something, just note that
the larger the size is, the longer it's going
to take to receive information. And that's
obviously because the more information you're
getting, the longer it takes to send that
over the server. So 2048 bits is not a lot,
it doesn't take very long, it happens almost
instantly. But if you bump this number up
to a ton, then it will take longer to do that.
Okay, so data, then we're gonna say reply
equals, and then we say data
dot,
I think it's actually string dot d coach.
Let's see this data dot decode, because it
will be in that kind of objects for that data
decode. And then here, we're going to do UTF,
eight, comma, eight. Now, the reason we have
to do this is because whenever we're sending
information over a like client server system,
we have to encode the information. And you'll
see that in the next step that we're going
to encode information before we send it back
to the client. But that means that we're receiving
encoded information. So to actually be able
to read it like a human readable string, we
need to decode it first. So it's really easy
to do that we just do dot decode, and we're
just giving the format which is UTF, eight,
okay? So reply equals that. And then we're
going to say address, if not data, we're going
to print disconnected, okay, and then we're
going to break. And this just means if we
try to get some information from the, what
do you call it, the client, but we're not
getting anything, we're gonna disconnect and
we're gonna break. And that likely means that
we've will disconnected from the client or
the clients left or something like that. So
instead of continuing to run this, while we've
been trying to get information from a client
that's disconnected, we're going to break
this just kind of a failsafe to make sure
we don't get into any infinite loops. And
it's also going to show us if we're running
into any issues with like receiving the data
and decoding it, which we'll talk about later.
Okay, so otherwise, so if we are getting information,
all we're going to do is we're going to print
received, is that how you spell received,
maybe? And then we're going to put? What do
you call it? reply, okay. I didn't mean to
that. Let me see if I'm spelling this, right,
I have not received reply. So this just means
we received from the client, this reply, let's
print to the screen, see what it looks like.
And then we're gonna print sending a colon?
And we'll just print reply. Okay. And then
we'll talk about this again, in a second.
Why does this keep happening? Okay, reply.
Next. Now, after this, if not data breakout,
what we'll do down here is we're gonna say
con dot send all and we're going to send str
dot encode, reply. Now, again, remember that
since we're sending information over the server,
we have to encode our information. So all
this is going to do is just encode our string
reply into a bytes object. So that means when
we read it in from the client side, again,
we'll have to decode that information. It's
kind of annoying, but I mean, it's a security
thing, right? So now we're just going to accept,
I guess, what, what kind of error would even
be, I don't even know if there's gonna be
any errors. If we run into anything, let's
just break just to make sure that we're not
you know, getting in that infinite loop, or
we're not gonna ruin the program by doing
that. Okay, so this is actually about it for
our server. Let's see how much time We're
at 30 minutes. Okay, so now what we need to
do is figure out what the server number is,
and then we can actually test it and see if
this is working. So what
we're gonna do now, is we're gonna find the
server number. Now, to do this, we're gonna
be doing this over localhost. Okay, that means
that our, we're only gonna be able to connect
over our local network, meaning that like
anything on our Wi Fi network, that can see
each other, that'll work fine. But as soon
as you're outside that network, it won't work.
So we're going to be using what's known as
local IP addresses. So to find the local IP
address of the machine you're currently on,
you're going to go to command prompt in the
bottom left. And then we're just going to
type IP config. Okay. Now, some of you guys
are probably freaking out, because you can
see my IP address right now, this is a local
IP address. And that means that it is locally
assigned to my network, no one outside of
my network can see this IP address or can
ping it or can DDoS it or anything like that.
Okay. So it's perfectly fine if you guys see
this address, if other people know what this
local addresses, okay, just as a note, so
we're going to do is we're going to take this
ipv4 address, so just copy that. And we're
going to paste that inside of the string here.
Okay. So 10 to 11.2 52. Seven is mine. Now,
yours likely is like 192 dot 168 dot something,
okay. But since I'm on like a massive network,
usually they use 10 dot 10, like as the default
gateway, which is what they're using. So my
IP address starts with the 10. Yours likely
starts with 192 dot 168 dot one, or dot like
five or something like that, and then the
rest of it, okay, so that's the address we're
going to use. And this is going to be our
server address. So whatever machine that you're
going to be running the server script on,
that's the address you want. So say you want
to run this server on your laptop and you
want to run clients on Like your PC, and your
Mac or something like that, then you want
to make sure you get the IP address from your
laptop, and you're putting it in that script.
Okay, and we'll talk about more of this in
the next video when we actually connect to
it. Okay, so now that we've done this, I probably
made a mistake. But let's actually just create
a configuration quickly for server and run
this and just see if we're getting any errors
as of now. But now, it is worth noting that
we're not gonna build to connect anything
yet. So there's not really going to be much
we can see or really do. But for now, let's
just test this out. So let's have server let's
run this. And you can see waiting for connection
server started. So that's actually good. If
you're getting this string of text, everything
is currently working. In the next video, we'll
probably have to debug a little bit once we
start connecting to this. But for now, that
is the main server script. Now briefly, just
talk about before I end this video, how it's
going to work in terms of running the server
script and running the client script. The
server script always has to be running, okay,
so whatever you're trying to connect, you
have to have first run the server script.
And then you can run multiple client scripts
from wherever on the network you want. Now,
the server script has to be running on the
machine that the IP addresses like this little
string here, okay has to be running on that
machine. And you can run a client script on
the same machine that the server scripts running,
and you can run multiple client scripts on
the same machine. So like, for example, what
I'm going to do To test this in the next video
is I'm going to run the server and then I'm
going to run two clients on this machine.
And we'll see that it like is moving back
and forth for them. So what we're gonna be
doing in this video is we're gonna be coding
the kind of client side of this. So connecting
to the server, I know, we already coded a
client, but we're gonna code like the network
aspect of the client so that it can connect
to the server, it's not as much code it's
a bit more straightforward. And then we're
just going to test out sending very basic
information to the server, and hopefully getting
some back, see if that's working. Okay, and
then in the next video, we're going to be
connecting this. So like the little user interface
we created with moving that block around in
the first video, we're gonna be connecting
that. So that we can have multiple clients
running and we can see like different blocks
moving on each screen. Okay, so that will
involve a bit more work. Hopefully, by video
five, we'll have like a fully working kind
of game that's working over the network. Okay,
that's the goal. So with this video, I just
want to start by saying on the server class
here, or sorry, server file, I did actually
forget two lines of code in the last video.
So after this, except break in threaded client,
just need to add this print last connection.
And then connection close. All this is doing
is once we break out of this threaded client,
we're just letting the we're just going to
print this to the console so we can see what
it looks like. And then we're going to close
that connection, so that we can possibly reopen
it in the future. Okay. really straightforward.
That's all you got to add. So just make sure
you add that before moving on. Okay, so next,
what we're gonna do is we're gonna create
a new file, and I'm going to call this network,
okay, now you don't have to put what I'm going
to in the new file, it's just a lot easier.
So that's why I'm going to do that. So let's
do network. And in here, we're going to import
socket.
Now what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to code a class that is going to be responsible
for connecting to our server. And this just
makes it like so I can reuse this class in
the future. And you guys could reuse this
class in the future. It's just a bit cleaner
and nicer. In this way. I like to do things.
So when I say class network, again, call us
whatever you want. And in here, we're just
going to send an initialization function will
take actually as network, do we need anything
in network? No, I think we'll just leave like
that. So we're gonna say self dot clients
equals socket, dot socket. It's gonna be the
exact same arguments as last time. So say
socket dot i f. NET Anka, is that what it
is if underscore net, AF underscore eye net?
Okay, and then we'll do socket dot sock stream
like that. Okay, now we're going to define
the server and the port again. So self dot
server equals self dot port equals 5555. Now
for the server, this again, this number has
to be the same as the one you used in the
server. What do you call it? The server file
here. So no matter what, like no matter where
you actually are, like, what client you're
using, this number is gonna stay the same,
because this is the server you're connecting
to. It's not the clients address. We don't
actually have to define the client address
anywhere. It'll automatically get that for
us. Okay, so what we're gonna do now, we have
client server port, we need to do this self
dot addr equals and we're gonna say, server
so self dot server, and then self dot port
here. Okay? And then self dot. What do you
call it? self.id is going to be equal to self
dot Connect. Okay? Now, you guys, actually
let's just do self connects right now and
we'll talk about why I was going to add this
ID later. Once we add that functionality,
the server, okay. Essentially, I wanted to
have an ID There was returned here, or like
it was stored in this network object, just
because we are going to have to like be sending
an ID to each of our clients. So they know
if they're like player one or player two,
but we'll do that later. Because we don't
really, we can't really do that yet. Okay,
so we've called this Connect method. So we
need to write that now. So let's say define
Connect. OK, and in here, I believe we should
probably be given Actually, it's probably
fine. Just yourself, right? Now, what we can
do is use your self dot clients dot Connect,
okay, and then here, we do self dot addr.
Now we're going to throw this in a try and
accept just in case you know, this isn't working.
So say try, say, accept, and renew socket,
air,
um,
let's say accept. And we'll just pass right
there. Okay, just in case this doesn't work.
So we'll try this, we'll try to connect, accept
pass. Now, once we actually connect, what
we're gonna do is we're going to return, I'm
just looking at the screen right now self
dot client dot receive. And then we'll do
dot decode.
Guess what this is going to do? I'll talk
about this because it might be a little bit
confusing is when we connect, we want to actually
send some kind of information immediately
back to the object that connected to us. So
like, for example, it's going to give me to
close that. Let's go into server here. And
you can see, when we initially Connect, we're
not sending any information until we receive
something, now, that's fine. But when we connect,
we should really send some kind of like validation
token, or like, Id back to our network object
or back to our client. So what I'm going to
do in here, let's say con, dot send, okay?
And then in here, what we're going to type
is, let's see, what should we really type
here, um, str dot encode, then he was connected
like that. Okay? Just so we know that we did
indeed, connect. So that means if we set this
equal to a value, so self dot, I don't know,
let's say ID equals self dot Connect, what'll
happen is, when we connect, we'll return that
string connected. So this will get connected.
And since it's in Kota, we need to decode
it, obviously. So if we want to print actually
in here, self.id, it should say like, connected,
okay, let's see if that works. Okay, so now
that we actually have that, um, let's see
if we can connect to the server, and then
we'll deal with sending information from the
client to the server, as opposed to just getting
it from the server. Okay. And that's a bit
confusing, right now, I'm just trying to figure
out the best way to do this. So let's try
this case. So we're gonna say n equals network,
I will just type this in the bottom of the
script. We won't do this after we'll delete
this just for testing purposes. And then we're
just going to say, actually, that's probably
all we need to do, because it'll just print
our ID. Okay, so let's create a configuration
for network. So new configuration, type network
and here and then select that path. And then
let's test if this is working. So remember
what I said, when we're going to connect right
to our server, what we have to do is first
run that server script. So let's run the server
script here. Waiting for connection server
started. Okay, let's run this network script
now. invalid argument with supplied s dot
listen to. Okay, so I had a quick look here,
I realized the mistake was I was actually
running this server two times. So obviously,
that's not going to work for us. So we can
put two back in this. Listen, I'm not sure
if you guys will see if I left that in the
video or not. But let's go to network. And
we also need to change this to AF instead
of if I don't know why I typed if I literally
said AF when I was typing it, but that's fine.
And we have server, I'm actually running it
right now. So make sure you guys run that.
And then those run now we can see if this
works. Okay, sweet. So I know it doesn't seem
like much. But you can check here if we go
to server says connected to and then it gives
us that address. And it's also printing out
some other thing that I honestly don't know
what that means. And then saying disconnected
and lost connection. Sweet, that's actually
really good. And that means that we're everything's
working. And you can also see that we have
connected being printed here. slot means when
we connect to the server, we're actually getting
the value that descending so we're getting
this connected, and we're printing it out,
decoding and all fine. So that's really awesome.
So now the only next step is to actually send
information to the server and keep like a
loop going like sending receiving, sending,
receiving, sending, receiving. Now let's actually
just test. If I run this again, you can see
again, obviously it's working again. So this
is the server just continually is running,
I don't actually have to stop this unless
you want to make modifications to it. So let's
just keep that running for now. And let's
add something to our network class. So in
our network class, we're going to define a
method that is going to be sent. Now this
method is gonna be very useful later on, because
it's gonna save us a lot of time. So in sandbridge,
can take a string, which is going to be data,
okay. And all we're gonna do here is we're
gonna try to self dot client dot send. And
we'll say data, str actually dot ENCODE data.
And then we're gonna get a reply from that
service, we're going to say return. So exact
same thing that we're doing here, self client
receive 20 48.2 code, and we'll accept. And
I believe this is a socket, err, yet, it's
socket dot air as he and just print E. So
if we get into some error where, you know,
either we're sending or we're receiving, it's
not working, let's just print that arrow to
the screen. So we have a look at what that
really means. So now let's do a test and try
to send information to the server and then
get something back. Okay, now the information
that we're getting back should just be the
same information because that's what we have
in server, we're just going to send exactly
what we got right back,
right. So it doesn't really make sense right
now to do that, but we'll talk about like,
what we can, what valid information we can
send, how to send receive information in the
next video when we connect up the client to
the thing, okay, so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say n dot send, and we'll print
n dot send, okay. And we'll print and send
again, and let's just send like a few bits
of information and see if everything is indeed
working. Okay, so n dot send. And then in
here, let's just type Hello. And we'll type
working Ok, and see if this works. So we have
actually, we should have Yes, server is working,
let's run our client. And you can see we get
connected, hello, working. And if we come
here, it says, received Hello, sending Hello
received working, sending working. So that's
awesome. That means our network class is working,
sending information receiving information
is working, servers working. And now the only
thing that's left to do essentially, is to
connect that up to this. So use this network
class in some meaningful way here, and then
to actually store information on the server,
and then send that information to multiple
clients, which we'll be doing in future videos,
what we're going to be doing is we're going
to be hooking up our graphical client to our
server, so we can send information back and
forth. And ideally, at the end of this video,
what we're gonna have is we're gonna have
two rectangles on each client. So I have like
two clients running. And when you move the
rectangle on one client, it moves on the other,
and vice versa. Okay, so you guys will get
the idea when we go through, but there's a
little bit of work we have to do. And we're
gonna be modifying a few things within a lot
of the files you've already created. So just
make sure you guys are paying attention. And
again, if anything is going wrong, feel free
to download all the code off of tech with
Tim dotnet. It'll be available there. And
it'll be exactly the same code that I'm writing
right now. Okay. So first thing we're going
to do is in this network class, we're just
going to delete a few things. So this testing
stuff, we don't need any more, this print
statement for the self, that ID, we don't
need that.
And we're actually going to change this self.id
to be self dot pause, okay, and you guys will
see why we're doing that in a second. And
we're gonna add one quick method in here.
And then we're just gonna say define, get
pause, okay. And what we're gonna do here
is just return self dot pause. Alright, and
again, we'll, you'll see why we're doing that.
But I don't want to have to come back to this
network class. So we'll do that right now.
Okay, so from inside our client, now, what
we're going to do is we're going to import
this network class, because we're going to
use it in here. So we're gonna say from network,
import network. And then in our main function
down here, what we're going to do is actually
above player, we're going to say, and equals
network, okay, like that. And then what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say, start, pause,
equals and dot get pause. So essentially,
why I'm doing this is because when we first
connect to our server, what I want to happen
is I want it to return to each of our clients,
the starting position of their character,
right or of their cube, okay, because it's
going to depend where they're starting based
on if they're player one, or if they're player
two. So then on the client side, what we're
going to do is when we initially connect to
the server, which is what we're doing, when
we create this network object, we're connecting
to the server, we're going to get that starting
position. And then for creating our own player,
we're going to use that starting position
to determine like where we're starting. So
the position is going to come in as a tupple.
Alright, and we'll be coding all this on the
server side in a second, but it's easier just
to go through each file, rather than going
back and forth. It's going to come through
as a tupple. That looks something like this.
So it'll be like 50 100. Okay. So what we're
going to do is you're going to read this tupple.
And because it's actually going to come in
as a string, like, you'll see how it comes
in. We're going to get the two aspects of
it like the x value and the y value. And then
we're going to use that inside of this player
initialization to like set the initial position.
So that reminds me what we're going to be
doing when we're sending information to the
server is we're Send it using string data,
right. And that's what we're doing in the
last video is we were sending everything with
strings we were sending, like Hello, and then
we were decoding and encoding it. Now, this
is not the only way we can send information,
we can actually send information with objects.
And I'm going to show you the advantage of
doing that in the next video. But for now,
we're just going to send strings. So since
we're going to be sending strings, the strings
that I want to send our positions, okay, I
want to for each client, send the current
clients position to the server, the server
is going to get that position updated on the
server side, and then send the other clients
position back to the client, you guys will
see how it works in a second. Actually, let's
see if I can do a quick drawing to illustrate
this because I'll make things a bit easier.
Okay, let's, I don't know why I had this.
Let's delete that. Okay, so let's do a quick
drawing. So we're gonna have, we're gonna
have client one, and excusing some drawing
this with the mouse and client two, okay,
so it's gonna be one, and this is going to
be too, alright, this will do it as a red
box is going to be our server. And on the
server, what we're going to do is we're going
to store positions, so psych one has positioned
like, one, two, okay, sorry, this is hard
with the most guys. And then client two will
have position like three, and one, OK. So
it can store these positions. So what's going
to happen is when we initially Connect, client
one is going to go to the server, it's going
to connect to it, and then it's going to be
sent back the starting position for the client.
Okay, so it's going to be set. Okay, so your
client one, so that means you're going to
start at position one to client two, it's
going to connect, it's going to say, okay,
we're client two, so I need to send client
twos position. So let's send that back. All
right. Now, let's say we've already connected
client ones, their clients twos there, and
we've set their starting positions, what we're
going to do next is now we're going to continually
call to the client and update the position.
So what we're going to do is say, let's say
we're working with client one, okay? What
it's going to do is it's going to send its
position to the server. So it's going to say,
let's just say pause, okay, it's sending its
current position, let's say that position
is like four, five, so this is really hard
with the mouse, get four or five, what's gonna
happen here is we're gonna say, okay, so you're
updating your position. So then it's going
to go in here, it's going to say, okay, client,
one will update your position to be four,
five, like that, okay. And then what it's
going to do is, instead of sending back the
same position, because we already know what
the position is, it's going to send back the
position of client two. So it's going to send
three one. And then on here, we can draw that
client so that it looks like it's moving,
right? So we're getting we're sending our
information, and then in return receiving
the other clients information. Now the same
thing works here with client two. So client
twos connects, right, and it's sending information,
it's gonna send its position. Let's say it
sends the position one, three, okay, that's
its updated position. So this is going to
change to be one and three. And then what's
going to happen is, it's going to say, Okay,
well, we don't need clients twos position,
we need clients one. So what's client one
position? Well, that is four, five, so let's
send four or five, over to client two. And
then on client two, we can draw four, or five.
So you'll see those simultaneously be moving.
I hope that makes sense. I just want to draw
it out for you. So you guys know what I'm
about to do in this video.
Okay,
perfect. Now, the only thing is we need to
send these positions as strings. So we're
actually going to have to implement two helper
methods so that we can convert those positions
which are going to be topos Industries. And
then we can also read the string into a tupple.
So what we're going to do is we're gonna say
define, and I'd want to remember what I call
this one, we'll say this one is read underscore
position, which means we're going to take
a string value, and we're just going to read
the string and we'll say str equals str dot
split. And we'll split it at a comma. Okay,
and you guys will see how this works in a
second. And then we're going to do is we're
simply going to return the end of string zero.
So str, zero, okay, comma, int, str. One.
So what we're going to do is we're going to
take a string that looks something like this
would be 45, comma 67. Okay, in in string
value, 4567, we're going to split it, which
means we're going to get a list that has the
string 45, and the string 67. And then we're
just going to convert those two ends, and
return them as a tupple. So now we get that
converted something that looks like this,
which is useful information that we can actually
use. Okay, so that's what read pause is gonna
do, but we need to make one more which is
going to convert that position into a string.
So we're gonna say, Make underscore position.
And in here, what we're gonna have is we're
going to take a tupple. So the shape top standard
for tupple. And what we'll do here is we'll
say, let's see here, return, tuck, actually
str of top zero. And then we're going to add
that comma in so sorry, I'm butchering my
typing right now, comma, plus STr of top one.
And I hope that makes sense how we do that.
So that's returning the string value. So we're
reading pause And making pawns. And that's
all we need to do for those helper functions.
Okay, so that means though, that when we get
the position initially from our server, it's
going to come in in that string value, right,
it's going to look like 4567. So we need to
convert that. So what we'll do is we'll say,
read pause, we'll just put that around and
get pods because get returned us that string
position. So we'll read it in. And now what
we're going to do is for our player, we're
going to say start, pause, zero, and start
pause, one, okay. And what this is going to
do is just set it to the initial start position,
we're going to code all the server stuff after
it will start making a lot more sense. Okay.
Now, what we also need to do is we need to
create a second player, because we're gonna
have to draw the first player and the second
player on the screen, right, so we're gonna
say p two equals, and we're literally just
going to copy this, except for start position,
we'll just gonna put it as 00 for right now.
And we'll update that in a second. Okay. So
we have P, P, two M. And for now, that's what
we'll do, actually, let's we can continue
working in here. So that we don't have to
do anything else in here, after we'll just
code the server side. So what we'll do now
is we're going to send our current position
to the server, right, that's like the algorithm
we've developed, essentially, we are, when
we connect, we're going to get the starting
position, we're going to set that starting
position. And then every time after that,
so like every time the frame updates, we're
going to send our position and then get the
other person's position. So we're going to
say is, we're going to say, P to pause is
going to be equal to n dot send, okay? And
we're going to send make position of, and
then we're gonna have to do in here is, it's
a little sketchy, but we're gonna do p dot
x, p dot y. Now, right, because that's the
position of our player, the x and y coordinate,
we're putting it in tabular form, we're sending
it to the function make position, which is
going to turn it into a string, and then we're
sending it to the server, right? Okay, awesome.
So I think that makes sense. And then we're
going to do simply is for p two, we're going
to update is its position. So we'll say p
two dot x is going to be equal to, actually,
and to not sad, but we'll we're gonna have
to put around to your story is make pause,
read pause, because right, it's coming in
as a string, so we need to convert this into
our actual position. So P to pause is going
to be P to position zero, and then P two dot
y is going to be equal to P two, P to pause
one. Okay, now the only thing that's left
to do here is what he called draw p two and
update p twos rectangle. So what we're going
to do now is in the redraw window down here
and put p two, we're going to go to redraw
window, we're going to say player two here.
And then we're going to do
player two dot
draw window, because again, it's going to
be a player object, so that'll be fine. And
then last thing to do is just update the rectangle.
So what I'm going to do is I'm gonna say p
two dot update, and we're going to go to player
object now we're just going to add this one
function, that is define, update. And then,
so you see, I just made the x self dot rect
equals x, y, width, height. And then in here,
I'm just gonna say self
dot
updates, like this. Okay. So I know this might
be getting a bit confusing, but we're almost
finished. Let's go do the server side. And
then we'll recap through everything, what
we've done, explain things, I kind of have
to get this content out. Okay, so define update.
So what we're doing again, here is before,
we just had this line of code here, so we're
just replacing that with an update method.
That's pretty straightforward. I hope that
makes sense to you guys. And that's just again,
so when we change the x, and we change the
y value of p to directly, then we are updating
the rectangles. So when we draw it to the
screen, it's in the correct position. Okay,
so I believe that's all I have to do for the
client side. So now it's time to go to the
server side and server sides pretty straightforward.
Now what the server needs to keep track of
the positions, right, it needs to hold player
ones position and players to position consistently.
So we can decide if we want to store that,
let's say like on a hard drive, or if we want
to store that in memory. Now in our case,
it's not a lot of information. So we're just
going to store it in the memory of the server,
right. So what we'll do for that is we're
going to create a list. And we're going to
say pause equals and just a blank list. And
this list is going to hold the positions of
our players. Now actually, that reminds me,
we're going to put two titles in here. And
these are going to represent sort of the starting
positions of our players. So we'll start with
00. And like 100 100, so player one will start
at 00. Player Two will start at 100 100. Okay,
and that's all we're going to do for that
little list there. And then what we're going
to do down here, while this while loop is
we're going to keep track of how many players
have connected. In our case, we only want
to to connect right. And then we need to keep
track of well those players, so we're going
to say there is a current player equals zero.
Now, this is because when we connect, we're
going to add one to this so that when we go
back into this function, it'll be you guys
will see how it works. But essentially, every
time we create a new connection, so every
time this, we accept a new connection, we're
going to add one to our current player. So
we'll actually do it at the bottom of the
while loop, we'll say current player plus
equals one. This is just to keep track of
which player we're using, so that we know
what position to update what position to send
to that player based on the connection, right?
Okay, so keep track of current player. And
now what we're going to do is when we start
this new thread, so this threaded client,
we're also going to pass another argument,
which is going to be the current player. So
instead of just passing connection, we're
also going to pass player in here, okay? Current
player like that, okay? Because that's gonna
be important information to know. Alright,
so we're actually almost finished, we just
got to update a few things. So let's actually
grab these two methods from our client class
or client file, and throw them onto server
here. So we're just going to put them right
above position, because we're going to need
to use them read pause and make pause. So
now when we initially connect to our player,
right, this is what happens when we initially
Connect, the first thing that sent is this
encoded message that is connected. Now in
our case, what we want to send is we want
to send the starting position. So how do we
do that? Well, we know what player we are,
we're either player zero, or either player
one, right? Because we only have two players.
When we start with player zero after player
zero connects, then we do player one, right?
So what we'll do is we're going to send pause,
player. Now, that won't work, because it's
just a tupple, right, we need to first convert
that to a string, and then encode that string
and send it. So let's actually go back here,
I want to keep the string dot encode. So string
dot encode, and we'll say make underscore,
oh, a pause. And then we'll just put pause
player in here. And what that'll do is it'll
convert it into a string for us, and then
it will send that to the player for us, right.
And then they'll read that string in Kibera
to position and update the position accordingly.
Okay, making sense. I hope so. Okay, so that's
how that works for player. Now, the only thing
we need to change now is what information
we are sending, every time this loop is running,
right, every time we receive something from
the player, we want to send back the other
players position. So to do that, what we're
going to do is we're going to say conduct
receive D code. So we'll get rid of this for
now. And then we're going to say is we're
going to turn this data into, like readable
a readable tupple, right. So to do that, we
are going to use the read position method
that we've already created or function. So
say read pause, conduct receive. And we'll
turn that into from that string like this
right? or whatever it was, like 4567, we'll
turn that into something that looks like this.
So that we can actually use it. Okay, so now
that we have that, it's turned into that,
what we're gonna do is we're going to update
our current players position. So we're gonna
say pause,
player equals data, right? Because this is
the position they sent to us. So let's update
it on the server. So yeah, so it's updated
information. Okay, sweet. So we've done that.
Now, all that's left to do is send the other
players position back to our client. So to
do that, what we can do is simply say, reply,
equals, and we're just going to say, pause,
or actually, let's not do it up here. Let's
do it down here. Okay, we're gonna say, if
player equals equals one, so if we're player
one, we're gonna send player zero position,
right? So as a reply, equals, and then pause,
player or not, pause, not not player zero,
sorry. And then else we're gonna send. So
say reply equals pause one. Okay? So if we're
player one, we send player zero position.
If we're players here, we send players one
position, right, like I was talking about
with that little algorithm we're going to
use, okay, and then instead of saying received,
and sending, actually, yeah, we can say received
reply sending reply, or real estate received
data sending reply, that should work fine.
Okay. Now, what we'll do is we're going to
send all the reply, but the thing is our reply,
we need to first convert into a string. So
to do that, we're going to say make underscore,
pause,
write that
function we've already created. And then that
should actually be about it. Now, I'm probably
made a mistake or two here, but let's just
test this out and see if everything's working.
So let's start by running the server. And
then let's run to clients and see if we can
connect if there's any errors. Okay, so we've
connected with client one, let's run client
two. And let's see what happens. So I'm on
client one, right now, you can see that when
I move my green square, it moves on the other
client,
kids go to the other one.
And when you look at this, when I move it
on here, it moves on the other client. So
we have successfully set up and connected
our two clients together. Now the only thing
I want to change quickly, it's just the color
of these so that we know who is who like which
square am I. So to do this, we're just simply
going to go will actually close the server
class otherwise you're gonna run into an issue
or sir instance, whatever it is, we would
have clients. And instead of having the same
color here, we're just gonna change this to
be 255 for player two. And now I want to show
you what happens, because some of you are
probably gonna be confused with what's about
to happen here. But it's kind of interesting.
So let's run server. Let's run client one,
let's run client two. Now notice that these
colors are inverted. Now Can anyone think
of why that might be? So green, right is going
to be your current player. So right now I'm
on here, I'm on this where my mouse is, and
I'm moving the green square that's near the
middle of the screen, okay. But notice on
the other screen, it's moving the Red Square.
That's because on your client, it's unique
to you. So on your client, you are green,
and red is the other person. Meanwhile, if
I go to this client, and I start moving, see
green is me. And red is the other guy, right,
and he's not currently moving. Now, if I wanted
to move these at the same time, I would just
have to be running these on different computers,
or I would have to change like the arrow keys
to move them. And that's just because obviously,
right, like, if I'm pressing the arrow keys
on here, it's not going to work on this client.
But if I were to load up my laptop and try
doing it on there, this would work fine as
well. There's a quite a few issues that we
may run into when we're doing this. So I've
set this up essentially, to be kind of like
an example program or like an example problem.
To give you guys an idea of the way we go
about doing things in terms of server and
network. But it's really not ideal, the way
that we've coded things so far. Now, I did
plan this for to do what we're about to do.
But essentially, I'm going to redo what we've
just done in a much more elegant and nicer
way that's going to allow for better scalability
of this program. Okay. So what we're going
to do is I'm going to redo it here, I'm going
to show you how we can actually send physical,
not physical, but like send objects to the
server and from the server back to the client
rather than just string data. And then in
the next videos, we're actually going to scrap
all this code that we've written, and we're
going to start fresh and code, like a networking
game, there's going to be a lot more complex
than just a few squares moving around the
screen. So that's my plan for this series,
let me know what you guys think of that. I
know, it might be a little bit frustrating
to get rid of this code. But now that we understand
a lot of this works, it's gonna be really
fast to rewrite it in a much more elegant
way. So what I need to first start by doing
is just taking this player class, okay, and
I'm just gonna copy it into its own file.
So really straightforward, I'm just gonna
go to a new Python file, I'm going to call
this player with lowercase. And then just
copy that player class in there. And just
import pi game up here. Okay, import pi game.
Now I'm just going to go back into client,
we can delete this player class. Now, what
I'm going to do really basically is just from
player import player like that, okay. And
that's the first step. Now, remember, I said,
we're going to send objects. So that actually
means that we're not going to need this read,
pause and make pause thing. And it's kind
of annoying how we've had to, we'll take that
Tableau object, decompose it, turn it into
integers, and then change Object Properties.
And then when we want to send something, we
got to put it into a string, and we got to
send it in just a pain. And we don't want
to have to do that, especially when we're
sending tons of different bits of information,
not just that same positional data, right.
So we're actually going to delete this, I'm
going to delete this client number, I don't
know why I have that there. And we're going
to start just making some modifications in
terms of sending data and receiving data.
So we'll start on the client side, and then
we'll go over the network, the server side
and fix some of that. So wherever we see like
read pause and make pause, we can just get
rid of that for right now. We don't actually
need any of that, we're not going to need
this P two dot x stuff, we don't need p two
dot update, we'll get rid of all this for
right now. You know, actually, let's get rid
of star position. Let's get rid of P and let's
get rid of P two, and we're going to recode
all this. Okay.
So, actually, um, p2p, I can stay there, Peter
move is fun. Okay, so we got rid of all that.
And you can see we've just cleaned up this
file, but and we'll start working with some
more stuff in a second. Now, what I want to
do actually is go to this network file that
we have. And we're gonna start making some
modifications in here as well. So what we're
going to be doing is we're gonna be sending
objects, so that means we're going to send
like an instance of the player class. And
that's actually what we're gonna be sending
instance of a player class to our server,
as opposed to sending like string data and
then updating the object on or then updating
the string data on the server and then sending
it back and then updating the object, it's
just a lot of work, it's a lot easier just
to send the actual object. So we can do that
using something called pickle, okay. Now,
it's a weird module name, but it comes default
with Python. And this allows us to do something
that's called serialized objects. And that
just means we turn it into byte information,
which is like all the zeros and ones, send
it over the, what do you call it, send it
over the network, and then we can decompose
that, turn it back into an object and use
it and it's really easy to do that. So what
we're gonna do here is we're going to modify
a few things. In this in our network class,
so first thing, instead of having self dot
pause, we're gonna say self dot P, okay? Let's
give equal to self dot Connect. And so saying
get position will this do get P, and then
we'll return self dot P, okay. And that's
all we need to modify for that. But now in
the connect in the Send, we're going to change
a few things as well. So since we're going
to be getting object data, what we have to
do in the Connect is we have to decompose
that object data. So to do that you do pickle
dot loves,
okay? Now what this stands for is it stands
for load byte data. Okay. And we'll we'll
talk more about this as we keep going through,
but that's essentially what it means. And
same thing here in send, instead of encoding
this data, what we're going to do, and I guess
decoding as well, is we're going to dump it
into a pickle object and unsend it. So to
do that, we're going to save pickle, pickle,
yep, dot, dot dumps, like that. And we'll
just put data in there. Okay. And then when
we receive, we'll do the same thing as before,
we'll say pickle dot loads, and that will
load that in. So now essentially, what we're
doing is we're going to be receiving an object,
decomposing that object, getting the actual
object, not the bytes form of it, and then
we're sending it, we're going to first like,
what do you call it, encrypt it, like send
it into that byte information, and then on
the server side will decompose that as well.
Okay, so we'll, we'll go through that. But
that's all we need for the network side. So
now let's go to server and start making some
modifications. So same thing here, we no longer
need this read, pause and make pause functions,
we're not going to be using those. And we
don't need this pause list, either, we're
going to change this actually to be players.
And it's going to be equal to two new players.
So notice that we're going to actually store
the player object on the server, as opposed
to on the client side. And this is not only
like safer, because it means that the player
technically can't really mess with the player
objects, they can only like, do commands to
update them. But it's also just like, it's
gonna be a lot easier. And you guys will see
how it works. We're gonna say player, and
we'll do another instance of player. And in
here, what we're gonna do is we're just going
to create two new players. So you say 00 5050,
and we'll give it a color. In this case, the
first color will be red. So we'll say, red,
green, blue, like that. And for the other
player, we'll start them at 100 100, like
before will be 5050. And then we'll make his
color blue. Why not do that? Okay. So now
you notice that we're getting an error for
player here, just because we forgot to import
it just say from player, import player like
that. And that's why I made this new file,
by the way, just so that we'd be able to see
it from the server side and the client side
as well. And then wherever we're doing this,
like send encoding stuff, we're going to change
this. So let's do that. Now, actually. So
instead of conduct send, instead of encoding
some string information, we're just going
to send the player object. So what we'll do
is we'll say, players, like this, and then
player, right, so exact same kind of concept
as before, in that we're going to send the
initial like starting position of the player,
or like the, but in this case, we're just
setting the initial player object, which means
any information that's stored in that player
will be given to the client as opposed to
just the position. Okay. So next, what we'll
do is instead of saying data equals read,
pause and decoding, we're going to get rid
of this dot decode and we're going to put
pickle dot loads, okay? And actually, when
I'm sending this player object, my bad here,
guys, we got to do pickle. dot dumps, okay?
And then we're gonna have to import pickle
up here. So import, pickle, alright, sweet.
So pickle that loads pickle dot dumps, and
then obviously, instead of pause, player equals
data, we're gonna say,
player,
players,
player equals data. And again, same concept
as before, what's gonna happen is the, what
he called the client is going to send us a
player object, we're going to replace the
existing player object with that new player
object. And then we're going to send back
the other player objects like the other clients.
Okay. So now what we're going to do is just
change these pause to be player or players
like that. Okay? Same thing here, players.
And then when we send it back, what we'll
do is we'll just turn it into a object, right?
So we'll just do that pickle dot dumps and
send it back. So say,
pickle dot
dumps, reply, like that.
And that
should actually be about it. So let's go back
or sorry, there's something we need to do
in client. So now what we're going to do is
essentially, we've set up our network class
so that we're going to be able to send that
object data. We've set up the server so we're
gonna be able to receive that object data.
We're gonna Modify the objects we're storing
in the list here, and then we're going to
send back the other ones to the other client.
So in clients, all we have to do now is set
up player one and player two and then send
that data. So really straightforward, it's
very similar to before, what we're going to
do, first of all, just say p one, we're actually
just p i guess is equal to n dot get P. Okay?
Because in the network class, remember, what
we're doing is when we initially Connect,
so let's go back to server, we're just going
to send the initial player object, which is
going to be whatever player it is. So zero
or one. So let's just say that this clients
player object is going to be n duck MP. Okay?
And then we'll say, actually, I think that's
all we have to do for Yeah, that is all we
have to do for that. Inside this while loop.
Now, what we're going to do is every frame,
we're going to send this player object, which
will be updating with P dot move. And we'll
just get the reply and say that that's p two.
So we're going to do is I say p two equals.
And then in this case, we'll just say p.or,
not n dot send, P. And that's all we have
to do. And notice here that we don't have
to do with all this like make, what do you
call it, make pause, read, pause all that
stuff. And I believe this should be working.
If I didn't make any mistakes, let's cross
the fingers. And let's try this out, waiting
for connection. Let's go to client one, run
that, okay, and client two, running that.
And now notice that these rectangles are the
same color. And watch what happens if I move
this red one, see how it's red on the other
screen as well. Now that already shows us
one of the advantages of doing it this way,
is that we can store information like color
as well not just position. And if we wanted
to store maybe like there was a text attribute
on each of these players, we could store that
as well. But we wanted to store more information
in the player like a health or something like
that, it'd be a lot easier to do that by just
sending the actual player object that has
like an unlimited amount of attributes, rather
than just sending a little tupple that has
like five, six, right, which is the position.
So the reason I went through the trouble of
showing you the other way is to show you the
massive advantage of doing it this way. And
just to give you kind of perspective, if you're
making something really simple, and you don't
use any objects, that's you can do it with
string data. But I think this way is a lot
easier. And we've just cleaned up quite a
bit of code, we've gotten rid of a bunch of
functions. And moving forward, this is going
to make things a lot easier for us. I'm pretty
much going to be gutting everything we already
did, we'll keep a little bit of it, but we're
just going to really add to a bunch of that.
And just yeah, we're going to be gutting most
of it. And we're actually gonna be working
to create online Rock paper scissors. Now
I know this sounds like kind of a lame game,
but let me show you because it's actually
pretty complex. And if you can understand
how to make this game, then you're going to
be able to understand how to make any other
kind of online game because the principles
are the same in terms of sending information
waiting for players to go. And there's a lot
of different things that you might not think
about that we actually have to do to code
something like online Rock Paper, scissors.
Okay, so let's This is client number one,
I'm just running another pi game window, or
pi charm window with the server running on
it. And you can see obviously, it's been oversized,
but it says waiting for player. Okay, so I'm
going to launch another client. And then excuse
me, you can see when I launched that it loads
both of them up into the game, and it says
your move opponents, your move opponents,
and currently it's waiting. So I believe this
one's player two, and this one's player one.
So if I make a move here on, let's say rock,
it'll lock in my move and says your move is
rock. And then over here it says, obviously
the opponent's move is locked in because it's
like looking for this guy's move. And now
if he makes a move, like let's say scissors,
then it says you when you last, and then it
just resets and you can keep playing games.
Now I'm also going to be adding more to this,
this is just like the beta version, I'm going
to have wins, ties and losses, keeping track
and top hand corner. And when you load in,
you're going to be brought to a menu screen,
which will allow you to like start a new game
or to leave or we'll we'll add that later
as we go. But this is the main functioning
game. And you can see obviously, it's working
well tie game. And it restarts. This also
allows for unlimited amount of clients to
play. So for example, if I launch another
two windows, you can see these guys now have
their own game going. It's kind of difficult,
because I can't really get four on the screen.
But anyways, if I go like Scissors, paper
that works independently of these games, and
these games can kind of play at their own
time, which is really interesting and really
cool. And if you disconnect one of them, it
automatically disconnects the pair. And that's
just because obviously you can't play against
no one right? So yeah.
Okay, sweet. So that's that. Let's start getting
into the code. Okay, so first thing we're
going to do is we're actually going to code
a game class, okay? And this is just going
to be responsible for holding all the information
for our game that we need. So for example,
did player one go yet to player to go yet?
What move did player one make one move to
player to make are both of them connected
to the server information like that, and you
guys will see how much information we actually
need. It's also going to or things like keeping
track of who won or who lost, how many times
how many wins. So that's what we're going
to do with this game class. So let's start
making it. So class game, I'm doing this in
its own file, by the way, just called game,
you are going to need the end zone file, because
it's going to have to be accessed by both
the client and the server. Okay, we're going
to define our initialization. In here, we're
going to take ID, I'm going to say self dot
p one went equals false. self dot p two went
equals false. And obviously, you guys know
what this is going to do, it's just going
to stand for if player one has made a move
or not, if player two has made a move, we're
gonna do self dot ready, equals false. If
I could type that correctly, we're also going
to add self.id. So self, that ID equals ID,
and this is just going to stand for the current
games ID. So each game we create is going
to have its own unique numeric ID so that
we can determine who is like what clients
are a part of what game and whatnot, we're
gonna do self dot moves, equals, and then
we'll just do none. And none in here, because
currently, the moves are none. But we'll just
store two positions, so we can change that
will say self dot wins, equals and then 00.
Obviously, this one is going to stand for
player one, this one's gonna stand for player
two will say self dot ties equals zero. That's
all we need for the net. So the next one is
going to say get underscore player underscore
move. Now what this is going to do is exactly
what it says is just going to get I don't
know how I added that there, it just going
to get the player move that we asked for.
So we're going to take p, which is going to
be either zero or one. And we're going to
do simply return self dot moves, and P and
just remind ourselves, we'll say that P is
in the range of zero, and one. So we're only
going to take value zero or one and then we're
going to return a move, move here. And let's
just remind ourselves that we have to pass
your one, obviously, zero is going to represent
player one, and one is going to represent
player two. Okay, next one play. So this one's
a bit more complicated, not crazy, we're gonna
take play, we're going to take a player, and
we're gonna take a move. And what this is
going to do is it's simply going to update
our moves list with that players move. Pretty
straightforward. So what we're going to do
here is we're just going to say, if player
equals equals zero, then what we'll do is
we'll say self dot moves, zero equals move.
Oh, actually, you know, let's do this. Sorry,
I'm just looking at my other screen right
now we'll say self dot moves, player equals
move. But now what we have to do is based
on the player, we have to update if p one
went or P two went, Okay, so what we'll do
in here is, if it's player one, obviously,
we'll do p one went equals true, get any to
self before that, and then we'll call it,
we'll just do a little LS here, because it's
not player zero must be player one will say
self.pg. Want, if I could spell once, equals
true. So that'll just keep track of if we've
gone or not. Sweet. Next method, this one's
really easy, it's going to be called connected.
And it's just going to tell us if the two
players are currently connected to the game.
If they are, it will allow us to load in.
And that's how we can determine whether we
should show waiting for player or not on the
screen. Right. So we'll say return self dot
ready. And that's just going to tell us obviously,
if we're ready, and that'll be updated from
the server side, which we'll do later. Next
method define both went, this is just simply
going to return if both of our players left.
So to do that, we're just gonna say self dot
p one once and Why can I not spell that word,
and self dot p two went like that. Okay. Next
one is winner. This one is a bit more complicated,
but it's just gonna keep track of where it's
actually going to tell us who's won the game.
So if we call this method, we're assuming
that both players have gone, we're going to
check their moves, excuse me against one another,
and see if they want. So we're actually going
to have to check nine possible cases, because
there's three moves, each player could do
three times three, nine. So what we'll start
by doing is we'll just say p one equals self
dot moves, zero, dot upper. And then to the
reason we're doing this is because we just
want to get the first letter of the move,
because the move is going to be stored as
Rock paper or scissors, the string, and it's
just gonna be easier for us to type out, for
example, R or s, or what do you call it, or
P to check the moves, as opposed to having
to check the entire word. So we're just going
to get that first letter by doing move zero,
we're going to upper it and then we're going
to take that first letter, we're gonna do
the exact same thing for p two, except obviously,
we're going to need Oh, I don't know what
I did there. We're going to need moves one
dot upper. And now we can start checking to
see who's won. So we're going to stay to start
winner is equal to negative one. Now that's
because There could be no winner that could
be a tie. So if it's tied, we're gonna say
negative one. If player one is the winner
it's gonna be zero. If player two is the winner,
it's gonna be one. Okay? So we're gonna do
is we're gonna say if p one equals equals
R, and P two equals equals scissors, what
we'll do is we'll say winner equals zero because
player one one that will say lF p one equals
equals s, and P two equals equals R, then
we'll say winner equals one believe, do another
lF, and I know this is tedious, but this is
the way you have to check for rock paper scissors.
I don't think there's an easier way to do
it. If you know an easier way let me know.
And p two equals equals R. And if you guys
don't want to type this, you can always copy
it from my website, tech with Tim net. Okay,
so say winner equals paper beats rock solid
B winner equals one or zero sorry, we'll say
lF p one equals equals R, and P two equals
equals p, then winner equals one. And we've
just got two last ones to check here. So we'll
say lF p one equals equals s, and P two equals
equals R. And then P two is the winner. So
winner equals one. believe that's Oh, sorry,
I'm gonna mess this up. This should be P.
Thanks. So P rock, rock, paper, scissors,
paper. Yeah, when r equals zero. Okay, well,
if p one equals equals paper, and P two equals
equals scissors, then when r equals one, and
I believe that should be correct, 123456.
Okay, sweet. And then the other cases, or
if it's a tie, so if none of this is the case,
then they must have tied, and then all we're
going to do is simply return winner like that.
Okay, and one very last method, then we're
actually done with this class, we can move
to something else is the fine, reset, went.
And all this is going to do is say self dot
p one went equals false. And self dot P to
one
equals false.
Pretty straightforward. And this is the game
class. I know it kind of sped through this,
but it's pretty trivial how this works. We
just need to get this out of the way so we
can start coding some other stuff. Okay, sweets,
we've done this class. Next thing I think
we want to work on is network. So network,
actually, you guys are gonna have to modify
yours to look like mine. Now get P. And what
do you call it? So this first half, so a net
and get p are gonna be the same as what we
had previously, the only thing that's changed
is connect and this send. So in Connect, instead
of, what do you call it, like unpicking an
object. So like pickle dot loads, what we're
simply doing is we're going to just connect
to the client like we did before, but instead
of unpicking it, we're just going to decode
it. So we're gonna say self dot client dot
receive 2048 D code would return that value.
And that's because when we initially connect
to the server, what we're going to get from
the server is our player number, which means
we're either player zero, or we're player
one. Now, that's important, because that's
going to determine where on the screen we're
drawing certain things, and how we're sending
information back to the server and updating
player one or player two, right? Because technically,
each player thinks that they're player one,
but each one needs to be assigned either zero
or one by the computer. So we know where to
store information, right? Okay, so that's
how we modify that to decode instead of pickling.
Sending, I believe is the same except what
we're going to do is, instead of picking an
object to send, we're simply going to send
a string, and we're going to load an object.
So that means we're going to send a string
data to the server, and we're going to receive
back object data. So when we receive something,
we have to pick it out, loads it in, but when
we're sending it, we just have to encode the
string. Okay, so just make sure it looks like
this, I don't think I need to go through this.
We've already done this for the past two,
three videos. And that's the network class.
So game and network are done. The next thing
is to do our server and client. Now server
and client are a bit more complicated. So
inside of server, I guess we could do this
first because it doesn't really depend on
the client to work or the client kind of depends
on the server. We're gonna change a bunch
of things. So this is what mine looks like.
Now I've kind of gutted the entire threaded
client, I got rid of most of the stuff like
most of the other stuff, just left this beginning
thing so that the server IP, the port, the
socket, connecting, listening, waiting for
connection. So by the way, some of you were
saying you're having issues with F s dot Listen,
you can just make this zero doesn't really
matter. What's in here. And some of you are
saying like you're having issues just you
can just delete it and type it in again. And
apparently that works. That's when someone
said so. I don't know. Don't ask me about
that. But if you're running into issues, do
that. Okay, so what we're going to do now,
is we want to make it so you can have unlimited
connections at once. Now that means we're
going to have to have unlimited games running
at the same time. So before what we were doing,
when we had those players moving around the
screen, we were just storing, like player
one, player two, and we just had a list that
had two entries. That's what we were doing
that, what we're gonna do now, is we're gonna
have a list that contains a bunch of different
games. And those games actually, you're sorry,
it's gonna be a dictionary, those games will
be accessed by their ID, and use, we'll see
how this works. It's a bit complicated, but
just follow along. And yeah, so I got to just
open up my other file, so don't make any mistakes
here. Guess what we're gonna do is we're gonna
do connected equals set, we're going to define
some variables, we'll talk about these do
games equals a blank dictionary, and Id count
equals zero. So the reason we're adding these
is games, this dictionary is going to store
our games. So it's gonna have an ID as a key,
and the game as like a game object like this,
okay, as the value, this connected is just
going to store the IP addresses of the connected
clients, we're struggling to set just so it's
easier to access later. I don't actually know
if we use this, we might. But we'll see. Id
count, obviously, it's just gonna keep track
of our current ID. So that means what game
we should recreate. So we don't override games
and say like two games have the same ID because
obviously, we can't have that happening. Okay,
so that's fine. for that. We're not going
to deal with anything threaded client right,
now, we're going to go down to our while loop.
And this is where we're going to create new
games based on new people joining or possibly
delete games, actually will delete games from
threaded client.
So we're going to do right now is when someone
connects this, this runs, right, and we run
a new so like, once we accept a connection,
everything after this runs, so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say ID count, plus
equals one, if you noticed me looking away,
I'm just looking at my other screen to make
sure don't make any mistakes on this. Now,
what Id count plus equals one is going to
do obviously, it's going to keep track of
how many people are connected to the, the
server at once. Because obviously, right like,
once this happened, we can accept, then we
go down the while loop, we start a new thread,
and then we wait for another connection. So
we're just gonna keep track of that, what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say P equals
zero, just standing for the current player,
we're gonna say game ID, equals, and this
is gonna be weird, but just follow along with
me. We call it ID count, minus one, integer
division two. Now, what this is going to do
is essentially, every two people that connect
to the server, we're going to increment game
ID by one, and what game ID is going to be,
or we will say, it's, yeah, we'll add it by
one, what game ID is going to do is keep track
of what Id or game is going to be. So like,
for example, if we have 10 people connected
to the server, we're gonna have five games,
right? So that's what this line of code is
doing. For us, it's keeping track of how many
games or if we need to add a new game, because
obviously, if we have like six people connected,
all of them are gonna be playing each other
a seventh person connects, well, it doesn't
have a game to join, we have to create a new
game for it to join. Hopefully, that makes
sense. Okay, so what we'll do next and say
if Id count, modulus two, equals equals one.
And what this is going to stand for, is if
you're going to be player one, or player two,
and if this happens is actually we need to
create a new game, because this means that
we don't have a pair for our new player. So
for example, like, say this numbers three,
that means two people already playing. So
that's one person just connected. So we need
to create a new game. That's what this module
is to is getting. Okay, so to do that, we're
going to say games. Game ID equals game. Game
ID. Okay. And I believe it's actually speed
capital. So obviously, start at the beginning
of this, I forgot to mention I import a game.
So from game import game, that is important.
And yeah, essentially, what we're doing is
we're just going to say that game ID, which
is that key in our dictionary is now equal
to a new game, so we can access that and add
players to it and whatnot. Sweet. So that
works, let's actually print out a message
here and just say, creating a new game, dot
dot dot, just so that in our server, we get
some kind of output, and we can have a look
at that if something's going wrong. So otherwise,
if there, we don't need to create a new game,
meaning we have, let's say, three people are
connected. So that second game already exists,
and another person connects, well, that person
has to be a part of this new game. So what
we're gonna do then is we're gonna say games,
game ID dot ready, equals true. Now, what
this means is that the second player connected,
so there's two players now connected to our
game. So now we can say that that game is
ready to start playing because both the players
are connected. So that means that they can
will obviously play against each other, right?
So that's what we'll do, we'll set that dot
ready equal to true. And obviously, we're
storing all the games on the server side,
as opposed to on the client side. And then
what we're going to say is we're gonna say
P equals one and what this means is putting
Error equals one. And you'll see why we need
to do this in a second. Okay, so now we're
going to do start new thread. Now notice insert
new thread, I added two new parameters, P
and game ID. So this means the current player,
so it's either player zero or player one.
And the game ID and game ID is going to stand
for which game in this games dictionary, are
we playing in this thread client, like, which
one of our clients that's connected here is
playing which game, that's why we need that.
So let's pass that information. So we're gonna
pass p, which is either going to be zero or
one like we have there. And we're going to
pass game ID. And then we'll have that up
here. And just remember that threaded client,
one of these functions is continuously running
for every single one of our clients. So if
we have 100 clients, we have 100 different
functions of this running in the background
at the same time. Okay. Awesome. So that's
how that's working inside our threaded client
now.
Excuse me shut to take a break there. inside
of our threaded client, we now need to add
some things. So the first thing we're going
to add is ID count we're going to global ID
count, because if someone leaves our game
or disconnects, we're gonna need to subtract
from that. So we can keep track of accordingly,
like, how many people are connected, how many
games are running, and all that stuff. Okay?
Now, the first thing we're going to do, when
someone connects to our, what do you call
it, our server is we're going to send them
what player there. Remember what I was saying
in the scheme class, or in this network class,
sorry, then when we connect, we're initially
just going to decode a string, that's either
going to be zero or one to tell us what player
we are. Okay, so what we're going to do is
we're going to send con dot send str dot encode
P. And I believe it should be actually string
P. Like that, so that we know for player zero
or for player one, that's the first step.
Next, we're gonna say reply equals a blank
string, want to say while true. And this is
where we're going to start doing some more
serious stuff in here. So the way that it's
going to work in terms of sending string data
from a client to our server, is we're going
to send one of three different options we're
going to send yet we're going to send reset,
or we are going to send a move, and the move
is going to be like rock paper or scissors.
So if we send get what that means is we want
to get the game from the server. So we're
going to send that every frame, we're going
to send get a string get, and then the server
is going to look, it's going to say okay,
what are you sending you're sending get, Alright,
we'll send you back the game. That's how that's
gonna work. Or another option is reset. Reset
means reset the game, the game is finished,
both players played, reset, and that's going
to be sent from the client side, because the
client knows when we want to reset, right.
The last one is a move, same thing when the
client makes a move. So like rock, paper,
scissors, if they are allowed to make that
move, which will check on the client side,
we'll send that move to the server, the server
will update the game accordingly. And then
it will send back the game to the client.
And that's how that's gonna work. Sweet. So
what we'll do now is say, well, true, let's
say data equals con, dot receive. And then
we're gonna say 4096. And here instead of
2048, which you're using for D code, reason
we're doing this is just in case, we're sending
too much information that is more than 2048
bits, we want to just double this number so
we can get more if you run into any issues
that say like pickle data was true onst or
like ran out a input, just increase this number,
okay, you can literally just do multiply by
two in here. And that should hopefully fix
the error. If it doesn't work, you can like
multiply by four, multiply by eight. And that
should hopefully fix your air for you. Okay,
so now what we're going to say is gonna say
if game ID in games. Now I'll talk about why
we're doing this in a second, we're gonna
say they're gonna say game equals games. Game
ID. So essentially, every time we run this
while loop, we're gonna check if the game
still exists. And that's what we're doing
right? So in this games dictionary, we're
seeing if this game ID, which is the key to
access, the game is still there. Now, why
would we check that? Well, if one of our clients
disconnects from the game, we're actually
going to delete that game from the we call
it the games thing. Now, what that's doing
for us, excuse me is not only like keeping
track of our memory, which means that we're
not going to just continually keep creating
games. So like Sarah server ran for weeks,
and we never deleted any games, then we probably
run run out of memory on our computer, right?
If we're playing a lot of games, but it's
also going to tell the other client that was
connected to that game that, hey, this game
no longer exists. That means the other person
must have disconnected from it. So we have
to do something accordingly. Go back to the
menu screen right. Do something like that.
Okay, so let's we'll do there. And then we're
going to say, in here, as I say, if not
data,
we're gonna break this similar to before.
So I'll go through it a bit quicker. We're
gonna say else. And now we're gonna check
the three different things that could have
been set. Right? So we've received the data.
So we're going to check if we got reset and
get or if we got a move, first thing we'll
check, we'll save data equals equals reset.
Okay, then we're gonna say if data does not
equal, get, and then else. Sorry, this should
be an lF Alec data does not equal get else
we'll do something else. actually do anything
else? No, we don't. Okay, so if data equals
reset, what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say game, dot reset, right, because we already
have the game. And if we look in here, what
resets doing is essentially it's resetting
both players one so we can play another game.
really straightforward for that. Next one,
if data equals get, what we're going to do
is say, gain. Or if data does not equal get
sorry. So if it didn't equal read, reset,
and it does not equal get, well, then it must
be a move. So it means we're either getting
Rock Paper, scissors, so we're going to send
that move to the game to update it. So to
do that, we're gonna say game dot play. And
then we're gonna do with the current player
number, which is P, and then the move, and
the move is going to be whatever this data
is, right? So it'll be data. Okay, and then
otherwise, so I guess after that, what should
we do here? We'll say, reply equals game.
And that what we're going to do is we're gonna
do con dot send all we're gonna say pickle
dot dumps,
and not
reply. Okay. And what this is going to do,
let me just make sure I didn't run into any
errors here is simply going to package up
our game into that nice sendible form, we're
going to send it over to our clients, clients
going to receive it on Piglet, and then use
it to obviously make moves and do different
things and draw to the screen and all that.
Okay. Alright, so I think that makes sense.
We can go through it really quickly. What
time we got 25 minutes. All right. So we'll
go through really quickly, essentially, what's
happening. When you connect, we're going to
check if we have an even amount of players
or an automatic players, if it's an automatic
players, when you connect, that means we need
to create a new game. So we create a new game.
If it's not, that means we need to assign
you to a game. So what we're going to do is
make the current game that only has one player
in it ready, we're going to assign you to
that and start a new thread. When we start
the new thread, what's going to happen is
we're going to send to the client what player
they are either player zero or player one.
And then what we're going to do is we're going
to constantly receive string data from the
client. If the game still exists, then what
we'll do is we'll check if they're sending
us reset, get or remove, they're sending us
a move, we'll make that move the sending us
reset, we'll apply that reset to the game.
And then we're just going to constantly send
back to them the game object. And now what
we need to do is just really quickly add some
statements in here. So that if some of this
stuff doesn't happen, we have like a catch
for it. Okay. So what we'll do here is we're
just going to simply say else break. Okay,
that should be lined up here. And we're just
gonna add a try and accept up here. So we're
gonna say try, and we're gonna indent all
this by just highlighting and pressing tab,
let's say accept, and then pass. I think that
Yeah, no, not pass or accept and then break,
just in case you know, something goes wrong
with this data dot receive, we want to make
sure the server keeps running. So we have
that try and accept. And then underneath this
accept, in line with the main function indentation,
what we'll do is if we break out of this while
loop, we need to close the game and delete
it. So to do that, is actually we're going
to print some on my ROM file here. We're going
to print last connection. And then we're going
to print What do you call it? closing game.
Okay, actually, we can print that game ID
to see what game ID we're closing. So say
last connection, closing game game ID, okay.
And then we're gonna try to
delete games.
Game ID. Otherwise, we will accept
and pass.
Okay, and then underneath here, last thing
we're gonna do is gonna say ID count minus
equals one. And we're going to say connection
dot close. Now that actually think about it,
we should probably put this closing game only
in this try after we delete, just so that
we don't we only close the game once we don't
say we're closing the game twice. Okay, so
what we're doing down here essentially, is
if we break out of this while loop so for
example, if the game no longer exists, we're
going to break if something goes wrong with
this getting data so like the player disconnected,
we're gonna break we're gonna say lost connection.
We're gonna try to delete that game. The reason
we have this try here is because if both players
just can At the same time, one player will
delete the game before the other. So if we
try to delete a key that doesn't exist, we're
gonna run into an issue. So we try that. If
that works, we will say print closing game,
and then we'll say that game ID, otherwise
we're gonna pass, we're gonna subtract from
the ID count, and we're gonna close the connection.
Sweet. So we're rolling, we're going pretty
fast here. Now all we got to do is code the
client. Now, this is probably the most amount
of code, I think it's about 100. lines, it
just is a lot of drawing stuff. Okay. So I'm
into your break, we'll be back in one second,
and then we're going to code the client. Alright,
so I'm back out and we've got about 150 lines
to write for this file. It's pretty tedious,
because a lot of the stuff has to do with
the drawing, like we need those buttons to
be working. We need, like all that text to
be showing up. So that's like 90%, or not
90%. But like 70% of the code are about to
write is just going to be cosmetic stuff.
But I mean, what do want me to tell you, that's
what we need to do if we're going to make
an online graphical game, right? So let's
start by just coding a class. And this is
going to be a button class, just that when
we have those three buttons, you know, it
just makes things easier. So we're gonna do
our net. What do we need the niche, we're
gonna go for
text.
Sorry, coding in the wrong file, text x, y,
and color. And we're just gonna say that the
width and the height will be uniform in here.
And we'll just make it the same for all of
our buttons. So we're gonna say self dot,
text equals text. self dot x equals x. self
dot y equals y. And self dot color equals
color. Okay, sweet. We'll also add a width
and a height here. So we'll say self dot width
equals 150,
self dot
height equals 100. And feel free to play with
these numbers. That's just what I decided.
By the way, guys, I just really want to say
this. I'm not focusing on how good this game
looks. I know it looks like crap. But you
guys I know can go through and tweak the colors
and tweak the positions and all that. I still
want to focus on that because I want to get
the hard stuff out of the way in the tutorial.
Okay, so let's do a draw method in here. Pretty
straightforward. We're just gonna do pygame
dot draw, dot rect. And then for the rectangle,
we're gonna take window, which is a parameter
for the draw, and then we're gonna do, what
should we do color, so self dot, self dot
color, and then we're gonna need that rectangle
position, which is going to be self dot x,
self dot y, self dot width, and self dot height
like that. Okay, and then I guess, let's see
if there's anything else we need to add to
that, no, that's fine. We're going to find
a font. So we actually need to make sure you
just add this to the top pygame.font.net.
Okay, make sure you get on that. And we're
gonna do font equals pi game,
dot font
dot s, s y s fonts should help you spell font
correctly. And then here, you're gonna pick
your favorite fonts. I like Comic Sans. I'm
gonna make this. How big should this be? Let's
make it 40. And then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna render some fonts, we're gonna
say text equals plot dot render. And we're
gonna put self dot text, we're gonna do one,
and we're gonna do the color, which will be
I guess, in this case, black or white. 255-250-5255.
Okay, next, we're going to draw this on the
screen. Now we want this to be centered on
the button. So I'm going to do some like,
decently complicated math. It's not really
that crazy, but we're gonna say window, Blitz
text, and then we're gonna say, self dot x
minus is it minus notes plus self dot x plus
in brackets, and we're gonna round in these
brackets. I know this is confusing, or any
self doubt with over two, minus round. And
we're gonna say txt dot get underscore width,
over two. Now what this is doing essentially,
is we're starting at our exposition, but obviously,
we want our text to be centered. So to center
our text, we need to know not only the width
of the container of the button, but the width
of our text. So we're going to get the width
of our text or our button, we're going to
subtract that from the width of what do you
call it our text. So that way, it should add
like 20 or 30 pixels from the left side to
our text center. Okay, for the why we'll do
a similar thing. So inside makes you don't
mess up these brackets inside here. We're
just gonna actually copy this. And we're gonna
paste it right after comma. And we're simply
gonna say self dot y, plus round self dot
height.
Okay, plus text dot get underscore heights,
or minus txa. gunners get height over two,
and that should center our button. Yeah. Okay,
next, we're gonna say define,
click,
we're going to add a position here. This is
just going to tell us if we clicked on the
button or not. So it's a really basic if statement
here, so we're just gonna say x one equals
pa zero and y one
equals paused one.
Now we're gonna say we're gonna say if self
dot x is less than or equal to x one less
than or equal to self dot x plus self dot
width. And self dot y is less than or equal
to y one less than or equal to self dot y
plus self dot height. I believe that's correct.
Let me just check this. Yep, that's correct,
then what we'll simply do is we'll return
true, indicating that we did press the button,
otherwise, we will return false. Now, I know
I'm speeding through this, but it just because
it's really basic pygame stuff, and we're
doing online games. So make sure I change
that. So I don't want to focus too much on
the cosmetics. But essentially, what this
is doing is it's checking if the coordinate
which we're going to pass in here, which is
going to be a tupple of x, and why of our
mouse position is actually in the button.
And the way we're doing that is we're saying,
well, we go on the x, right, we check if it's
greater than the x, we check if it's less
than the x plus the width. So like if it's
in between the little box, and then for the
y value, we do the same thing. But we're checking
vertically to see if it's in that box. If
you don't understand that I have pygame tutorials
where I go through like collusion and how
all that works. I'm not really going to talk
about that right now. Okay, sweet. So we got
that working. Now what we're going to do is
actually, let's see what I want to code now.
Let's code the main function, and then we'll
get into Redrow window. So the first thing
we're going to do is we're gonna define those
three buttons that we're gonna have at the
bottom of our screen. So Rock, paper, scissors,
do that we're gonna say buttons equals, and
we're just gonna make three buttons. First
button will be rock, and say rock, we're gonna
start it at 5500. And then we're just going
to go and give it a color of 000. Okay, we're
gonna create another button. Let's say button.
And then we'll say, scissors. We'll give it
a, me just check here. 250 as next 250 as
an X 500 as a why, and for the color. For
that, I gotta check what color I made this.
I believe that I made that red. Okay, so the
255 00. And then one more button. Can anyone
guess what this one is going to be? It's going
to be paper, we're going to put this out of
position of 457 go here for 5500. And we will
simply make it blue, or green. Sorry, 02 55
zero, so red, green, blue. Okay, sweet. So
that should be at for our buttons. And now
we'll get into the main function and start
coding some stuff, the first thing we're going
to need to do is we're gonna need to say run
is equal to false or equal to true, I'll just
do that. We're gonna say clock equals pi game
dot time, dot clock. Capital, see here, my
bad. Okay, next, we're gonna say n equals
network. Right, because we're importing network
up here, we're gonna do a very similar thing
to what we did before in the previous tutorials
where we just connect initially by doing that
initialization, and then we're going to say,
P equals, actually player equals and dot get
P, right? And you should already have that
method. It's just returning that, like, connect
what we connected to, right, so when we connect,
we get the player number, which is either
zero or one. So we need that. Now it reminds
me, it's going to be number, so we got to
put an inch around this so that we can compare
it with other integers. Okay, and last, we're
going to just print just so we have this you
our Player, Player. Now this just indicates
to us like when we initially run, if we know
where zero or one just to make sure everything's
working fine. Now we're gonna make a while
loop running, say, sir main game loop, we're
gonna say well run. And then in here, we're
gonna do clock dot tick 60. Very similar to
what we've done before, guys, I'm gonna start
adding some new stuff in a second. Okay, so
now that we've done this, it's time to start
actually connecting and asking the server
for information. So what we should be doing
here is every frame, we should be asking the
server to send us the game, especially at
the beginning of this loop, because right
now, we haven't actually created a game class,
right? We need to get that from the server.
So we're connected now, we know what player
we are. So now what we can do is we can try
to get that from the server. So to do that,
we're gonna say game equals n dot send. Get
and that's literally as easy as it is. We
just need to do an accept. And then we'll
just when you call it will say run equals
false, and also print
couldn't get game. Okay? And the reason we're
doing this and we're gonna break as well,
is because when we if we Send this and we
don't get a response from the server, that
means the game doesn't exist. And what what
if that happens? Well, then what we should
do is we should exit out of this game, we
should print saying we couldn't get the game.
And then we should try to reconnect or start
a new game with someone else. So this main
function is going to be like the actual game
running. But once we exit of this main function,
we're going to go to a main menu. And the
main menu will allow us to choose like we
want to play against, and a bunch of other
stuff as well. Okay, you guys will see that
later. Okay, so let's do that. Next, what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say, if game
dot both went. Now, what we're going to do
here is if both players went, well, we're
not waiting for anything. Now, we need to
see which one one. So what we're going to
do here is going to check which player one
and we're going to display that message accordingly
on the screen. So what we're going to do,
initially, we're going to redraw the window.
The reason we do this right away, is because
we want to make sure that if both players
went, we're updating the window and on the
window, it'll check like if both players have
gone like in this redraw window, and it'll
draw the player moves for us. So you guys
will see how that works in a second, we're
going to do a delay when we pygame dot time
dot delay 200. And now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna try game, sorry, game equals
n dot send, reset. Now, why we're doing this,
obviously, is because, well, if both players
went, we need to tell the server to reset
those player moves. Right. So inside of game,
if we call reset went, we're just gonna reset
it so that we were able to play the next round
after,
okay, we're going to accept
except, of course, I can't spell that. We're
gonna say run equals false, we're gonna do
the same thing as before, we're gonna print
couldn't get game. Couldn't get game, and
we're gonna break. Okay? Now under this, so
after we send that reset, now what we want
to do is want to display a message on the
screen indicating whether player one one or
player two one or like if you want, or if
the other player one. So the way we're gonna
do this, and it's actually a decent amount
of lines is we have to like render font and
then we get to determine where we're gonna
draw the font and what's going to be on the
font. So we're first just gonna start by defining
thoughts. We'll say font equals pi game, dot
font dot s, why is font Okay, in here, we'll
say, Comic Sans, font size, let's go 90 for
this one. Now we're going to say if game dot
winner, and remember if we go to game winner
is going to respond to us with either a zero,
a one or negative one. So you have to check
if winner is one and player. So whenever our
current player is one, then we're gonna say
you won. If winner is one, but the current
player is zero, we're gonna say you lost,
right? So that's how we can check this. So
to do that, we're gonna say if game dot winner
equals equals one, and Claire eagles, Eagles
one, and remember, we got that player from
the server. So we know if we're either player
zero or player one on the client side.
And
is actually doing an end. Oh, sorry, or that's
what we need to do. Or game dot winner equals
equals zero, and player equals equals zero.
So essentially, what we're going to do here
is going to check if this player one, so we
know what player we are. And we know what
player one so if that coincide, like what
player we are and the player that one, then
we'll print out and we'll say, or we'll put
on the screen you want, right telling that
client they want. So we'll say text equals
font dot render. And then here we simply say,
you one exclamation point, and then we can
just do one, and then a color and obviously
color we just do like red like that. Okay,
on the screen. Okay, so else, actually, l
if, and now we're gonna check if they last
washy, I think we can do this easier. We're
gonna say l if game dot winner equals equals
negative one. So if we type, what we'll do
here, is we'll say text equals font dot render.
And we'll just say tie game. exclamation point
one. Again, we'll put that in red. Okay, and
now else, so if we didn't win, and we didn't
tie we must have lost so we can literally
just copy this and it will just say you lost
as the text. Okay, so you lost that. Sweet.
And now what we're going to do is just render
that font, put it on the screen, so or not
render it just put on the screen so say wind
up lit text. And now we're gonna do the exact
same thing that we did before. To get it in
the middle of the screen just be a little
bit easier. So we're just gonna say, I believe
to any another bracket, so I don't think so
we'll say width over two and that's the width
of the actual screen. Minus text dot get underscore
width,
we need those brackets over to do comma. And
now we'll just do the same thing with height.
So we'll say height over two minus text dot
get underscore height over two. Okay, so that's
going to put it in the middle of screen, we're
going to update the display, game dot display,
dot update, and we're going to delay, so pi
game dot time dot delay, and I'm going to
put 2000 for two seconds, you guys can put
whatever you want in here. Okay, so let's
break this down really quickly. If both players
went, that means now we're going to check
who won. So we're going to do is we're going
to redraw the window, we're going to what
do you call it, apply a small delay of 0.2
seconds, just so that we can see what both
players did before it immediately pops up
who won and who lost. So actually, let's make
this delay half a second, we're going to send
to the server reset, we're going to reset
both players once the next time that we start
playing we can both players are allowed to
move, we're gonna say run equals false. If
this doesn't happen, if this doesn't work,
we're gonna print couldn't get a game we're
gonna break. Now otherwise. So like, if this
worked, we set the game, we're going to create
a font, we're going to check who won. So either
we won, we tied it, we lost, we then display
that to the screen, ran delay for two seconds,
and then we're going to play the game again
after. Okay, awesome. So we're almost done.
We're just gonna add this pretty actually
complex for loop in here. So we're gonna do
now we're going to say for event in PI games
dot event, dot gets very standard for pagi
probably seen this before, we're gonna say
if event dot type equals equals pi game dot
quit, then what we're gonna do is gonna say,
run equals false. And we're gonna say pi game
dot quit. So this just means that they hit
the little X button on top of this corner.
Now we're going to check if they actually
pressed their mouse button down. So this is
how we're going to check if they pressed a
button. That's where we're gonna do now, let's
say if event dot type equals pi game, dot
mouse button.
down,
then what we'll do is we'll get the mouse
position to do the hovering so if we're gonna
say pi game dot pause, pi game dot mouse,
dot get underscore pause. So what we're doing
here is we're checking if they press right
mineral or left mouse button, if they do,
let's get the most position. Now, for every
single button, we're going to check if we
click that button. If we did, we're gonna
do something accordingly. Okay, so we're gonna
do now I'm gonna say for button in btn. Remember,
we defined buttons up here, then what we're
gonna say is, if btn dot click, pause. Now,
if they did click the position, there's a
few things we need to check. Oh, and also,
we can check this sir. And game dot connected.
Sorry. So what this game connections doing
is just making sure that it's not going to
let us press like Rock Paper, scissors, unless
we both players are on. So just so that we
don't run into an issue where we can make
a move before the other player connects. Okay,
so just add this end game connected. What
we'll do now is we're gonna check what our
current player is, because this is gonna determine
how we send a move. So we're gonna do now
is gonna say if Claire equals equals zero,
if not, game dot, what do you call it P one
went, then we'll do something otherwise, so
we'll just put Alice here. And we'll check
if not, p two game.pt one. Okay, so what we're
doing now, and I haven't coded the rest of
it yet, is we're just going to check if we
press one of the buttons. So remember, we
have that click method in our button that
tells us if we clicked on it. So if we do
click on it, and we're connected to the game,
what we're going to do is we're going to check
if our current player is your one. Now, what
we're doing is if we're player zero, we're
going to check if players here has gone yet,
if they've gone, obviously, we're not going
to let them make a move, right, because they've
already made that move, they can't change
their move once they made it. Same thing with
player two. So if we're not player zero, we're
player one clearly. So that means we're gonna
check if player two has gone yet. And if they
haven't gone, we'll allow them to move. Okay,
so all we're doing here now is we're going
to make a move. Now to make a move, remember,
we just need to send to the network our move.
So we're just gonna say n dot send origin
server, sorry. And all we're gonna do is we're
just gonna send the text of the button. Now
the text of the button will be Rock paper
or scissors, right? And that's precisely the
move that we're gonna make, depending on what
button we're clicking. So it's a really nice
dynamic way to do that. Now, once we've done
that, right, so if we go to server, what happens
here is if we send that we're going to play
that move, and we're going to update it on
the game, so that the other client when it
gets that game board again, we'll have the
updated move. You guys will see how this works
out. Okay, so that's working well, now all
we need to do is just add in line with this,
right here is a redraw window, we're gonna
give it when we're gonna give it, what else
do I need to give it a game, and p, which
stands for current player. And that's actually
it for and make sure you just call our calling
main down here at the end of climb. That's
actually it for this main function. So now
all we need to do is do redraw window. And
we're really close to done. So we got another
like 20 lines. And then once we do that, we're
actually finished this game. And then we can
start testing it out and talking about some
more things we can add to it. Okay. So what
we're going to do now is, it's actually quite
a bit of work is we're going to draw all the
stuff on the screen now. So we've done all
the logic aspect of it down here in this main
function. Now we need to draw everything so
it's more tedious and it is difficult. Or
we're just going to first start by checking
if not gamed connected. Now, this just means
if we have not yet had the other player Connect,
then all we're going to do is we're just gonna
print on the screen waiting for player and
we're not going to show anything else. So
to do that, we're gonna say font equals pi
game, dot font dot s y as Font Name, obviously,
it's Comic Sans. And then the, how big should
it be? Let's make it 80. Okay, and then we're
gonna say text equals font, dot render in
here, we're gonna say, waiting for player,
dot dot dot, one color, let's do a nice red.
And let's actually add true here for bold,
okay? Okay, so we're going to put this on
the screen. So to do this, we'll say wind
dot lit. And we're going to do again, that
same I know a tedious thing to get in the
middle of the screen. So we're just gonna
say with over two minus Tex dot get underscore
width. And then we're gonna say height over
two minus text dot get underscore height.
And actually, we need to make sure we're dividing
both the width and the height by two. So let's
do that.
Okay, that's it for that. Now else. So this
means if we actually are connected, both players
are in now it's time to start drawing the
real stuff on the screen. So we need to draw
that. What was it? So actually, let me pop
up client for you guys. So you can see what
it looks like. Let's run the server. Right
and client client. Great. So if we want to
see the client, what we should do is we need
to draw this, this, this, this and then the
three buttons. Okay, so we're gonna have to
do these four texts. And the thing is, these
text needs to change on like, they're gonna
be different depending on what player is looking
at it, right. So for example, here, it's showing
us what our move is. But notice, it just says
locked in for opponents. It doesn't tell us
what our move is, or what the other players
move is, right? So we need to do that as well.
Okay, so to do that, let's start. We're gonna
make another font, I'm gonna say font equals
pi game, dot font dot s, why is font, Comic
Sans size of this font, let's make it 60.
And then what we're going to do is I say text
equals font dot render. And we're going to
do your move. So we're going to start by just
doing your move and like opponent move, because
those aren't going to change, they're going
to stay the same no matter what. And for that,
we're gonna do one and the color I had there
was a nice cyan, I think, right? So we'll
do this, to feel free to change the color.
I know, it probably doesn't look the best.
And let's just put this at a static position
on the screen. So we'll say text. And let's
go at 200. Okay. All right, next. So actually
still in this else statement, we're going
to copy this. Just sorry, what am I doing?
Just this text and this wind part. And we're
going to put it down here. And so your move,
we're going to say, opponent opponents move.
Is that a spell that? Let's change that to
opponents. And actually, let's just get rid
of moves and be too big opponents. And same
color, except we're just going to change the
x value, so that we draw it at Will you call
it 380. Like that, okay. So that's it for
your moving opponents. Next, what we need
to do is a bit more complicated, because now
we have to draw what the actual moves are.
So remember, we're obviously we don't want
to show the other player what one of the players
moves is, unless both of them have gone like
we want to know what our move is, but we can't
know what the other players movers until we
both made a move. So to do this, we're gonna
do, we're gonna start by just getting ballplayer
moves, we're gonna say game, dot get underscore
player underscore move, we're gonna get move
zero. And we'll actually we'll copy this and
just do move to and change this to one. So
let's start by getting the moves. And then
now we're going to check if we should show
those moves, if we should show waiting or
if we should show locked in. Okay, so to do
this, we're gonna say if Game dot both went,
Okay, like that we're gonna say is gonna say
text one equals font dot render. And we're
just gonna use the same font as before. And
what is going to be is move one, comma, one,
comma, and we'll make this black. So 000.
Okay, and we'll copy this. And we'll do the
same thing except text two, is going to be
equal to move two. So essentially, this is
saying, If both of the players have gone,
well, we can show their moves, because they
both made them. So let's do that. And it's
just rendering that font, and we'll display
the font after, you'll see how that works.
So now, otherwise, if both players have not
gone, what we need to do is we need to actually,
let me just check something for a second is
we need to determine if we're going to show
locked in meaning the other player actually
has gone but we're not going to show their
move, or if we're going to show waiting, which
means the other player hasn't gone. So to
do this, we're gonna say if game dot p one
went, and P equals equals zero. So this is
saying, if we have gone, and that's our current,
like, we are the player, we're player one.
So player one's gone, and we are player one,
what we're going to do is we say text one
equals font, dot render, move on, which is
the move we've done, which is fine if we see
that, and then we're gonna say one, and color
000. Okay, lF game dot p two went, and is
this one, it is actually sorry, game dot p
one went, you guys will see how this works
in a second. We're gonna say this a text two
equals the same thing. Now, this might be
confusing, but essentially what this is doing
is it's saying if player one is gone, and
we are player one, we're gonna say,
if I spell render correctly, render, like
that. Render, sorry, I got interrupted there.
Okay, so if player one is gone, and we are
player one, then we want to show underneath
like your move what our move is. Otherwise,
what we want to show is we want to show that,
like locked in, so we're gonna change this
to locked in, underneath opponents move because
it means player one went, but it's not us.
So it's not our move. So that means we want
to show it under opponent's moves, you'll
see how this works. We're gonna say, locked
in like that. Okay? All right, now we're just
gonna do else. So this actually just stands
for, if game dot p one hasn't, like if they
haven't moved yet. We're gonna it's gonna
say txt two equals waiting. So we'll say waiting.
I believe that's correct. I'm actually sorry,
these all need to be text one by one. Okay?
All right, IOC is confusing, but we'll go
through it after. All right, so we're gonna
actually copy this, and we're just gonna change
everything to two. So this is going to be
P two, this is going to be one, this is going
to be two, it's going to be two, and it's
going to be two, and this is going to be two
as well. And we just make sure that I did
that correctly. I believe I did. Okay, sweet.
And now we're going to actually show these,
we're going to split these on the screen,
and we're actually really close to French
guys. So to do this, we're gonna say if P
equals equals one, so if we're clear one,
we'll do is say wind up lit. And we'll say
text two, and then we're going to show it,
we're gonna show it at 103 50. Okay, now we'll
copy this, so Ctrl D, and we'll blit one,
except instead of at 100, we're gonna change
this to 400. Now we're just going to put an
else so if we're not player one, clearly,
we must be player zero. So we're just going
to reverse these player one, player two. Now,
the reason we're doing this is because this
is going to be where like player one and player
two's moves are shown on the screen. So we
want it to make so that for each of our clients,
rather than saying like player one, player
two, and having one of the clients have their
move on the right side, and one of them have
it on the left side, we want it to be the
same for each client. You guys will see how
this works when we actually run the thing.
So let's actually just, let's add in drawing
the buttons. So to draw the buttons, we could
we could draw them in this L statement. Actually,
I might be better. Yeah, let's do it inside
of this, this else, okay, we're gonna say
for btn. In buttons, we're just gonna say
btn dot draw, and give it a win. And I think
that's actually all we need to do. And lastly,
we're just going to update the display. So
probably game dot display dot update. Now,
assuming I didn't make any critical errors,
this should actually be working. So I know
this has been a lot of code and a lot of writing
but I think I've kept it to just about an
hour now actually. And that's actually pretty
decent time for creating a game like this.
So you guys will see how this works out. Okay,
so let's try running our server and see if
we got any errors First of all, okay, server
waiting for connection server started. Good
sign so far. Okay, clients, let's try running
it. Client client. Oh name P is not defined
when game P. Okay, so what we're gonna do
for client, this is a really easy fix just
change this to player.
And I might have to change. Oh yeah, up here
but I do redraw game window as well we got
to do win.
Game and player. Okay, so fix that. Alright
client run waiting for player. all right good
sign. Let's run another one. And what do you
look at that okay they both launching now
so you saw that waiting for player showed
up but as soon as we are ready, now both of
them are showing up. Okay, so this should
be player one, this should be player zero
or Player, Player One player two, right? Okay,
so let's try this now. Rock ran out input
self client received 2048. Okay, so let's
have a quick look at why this might be. So
I think I might have finally found the issue.
I'm actually I don't know if this is the issue
Exactly. But we do need to fix this, where
I do game dot reset inside of server here
it actually needs to be reset went cuz that's
what I called it inside here. Reset went so
we should make sure we do that. Okay guys,
so really silly error here actually on the
issue was on the server side here. I'm calling
play, right, like game dot play. And so actually,
to get rid of six, I was just printing out
the exception so I can see what it was. But
essentially, play doesn't actually exist because
I misspelled something on game, I misspelled
it, and misspelled player should be play.
So that was the issue I was running into.
It just was very difficult to see because
it was just accepting it and not like not
printing any Oh, just continuing to run the
server. So I couldn't find it. But essentially,
if we run the server and run the two clients
now we should have everything working. I haven't
actually tested it. So let's pray. I go paper.
Sweet. So it goes paper here. We're not getting
locked in over here. So that might be an issue.
But let's see if we make something here. That
is since you lost and you won. Because we
have a slight issue, but it's pretty easy
fix. Let's just go up to client, just look
through, we're just probably messing something
up in the drawing code here. So Oh, that would
make sense. Well, we're not actually end up
drawing. Yeah. So this, if P equals equals
one, this just needs to top back one, one
indentation level. And now we should everything
actually working fine. So let's try this now
client client. And let's go rock. Okay, so
that works. But it's not doing the locked
in for some reason. So let's check this this
locked in portion, close that server and make
sure that this is actually working. So that
needs to be P two went. And oh, if this one
should be working, that was what's confusing.
Okay, so actually, so that would just need
to be P two went game dot p two went. Let's
try this server. And let's go client. And
let's run it again. And we'll scissors locked
in sweet. So that's actually working and the
game is pretty well finished. All we got to
do is out of menu screen and we're gonna be
done. So let's go scissors. This is a scissors,
scissors. That's not correct. We got to fix
that as well. Okay. I thought I had everything
working guys. I really thought so. Okay, so
actually I do I do know the issue it was it's
pretty straightforward. So in main here when
we check the let's see here the winners where
do we check winners? If it equals equals one,
because it goes negative one? Ah, okay. So
again, no winner needs brackets? Of course
it does. So we add that so obviously just
subsidiaries guys. So servers running right
now, let's run these clients see if everything
is indeed working as as it's supposed to be
now. Okay, so let's try this paper blocked
in scissors. You lost you won. Yeah. Okay,
everything's working. Okay, paper, paper,
die games. Sweet. Okay, so you guys can really
mess around with the timing, you can see how
this is working. So the only last thing to
do now is watch this. If I disconnect, disconnect
both of them. So what we're going to want
to do now, if that happens is instead of just
completely like exiting the game, we're going
to want to bring them to a menu screen where
they can just click to reconnect. And this
is a really, it's actually really easy to
do. So what we're going to do is we're just
gonna define another function. I'm gonna call
this menu underscore screen. Okay, and in
here, all we're going to do is have a really
basic while loop that just checks if you click
something, and all it's going to do there
is click the Run that mean functions we're
gonna do is gonna say run equals true. Or
say well run. Okay, and then in here, we're
gonna say for event in PI game, dot event
dot get, and then obviously, we're gonna check
if they click Exit. So if event dot type equals
equals pi game dot quit, then we will do is
just do pi game dot quit, Ron equals false.
Otherwise, if they click any key, so we'll
say if event dot type e Calls equals pi game
dot, I will just say, most button down, so
I should just get it, click the mouse button,
then what we'll do is we'll simply say, run
equals false. And at the bottom of run equals
false, what we're going to do is we're just
going to call main. So all this is going to
do and we'll call menu underscore screen here.
Say while true. Comma, menu screen. Okay,
I'll go through this in a second. We say while
true menu screen, okay, so what we're going
to do is in menu screen, if they click something,
we're going to call the main function, which
is simply going to what do you call it do
all of this stuff in here. And then if they
exit out of the main function, so if you say
like run equals false, because they disconnected,
it'll just rerun the menu screen, which means
that there'll be prompted to reconnect to
new game. Awesome. Well, we'll do it here.
It's one o'clock as well. So say clock equals
pygame dot time dot clock, give it a tick.
So clock dot tick 60. We'll do we'll just
draw something in here. We don't need to use
the redraw window function will just do font
equals pygame dot font. dot. That's why as
font in here, we'll go Comic Sans will go
60. And then we're going to render some texts,
we'll say text
equals font dot render.
In here, we'll simply say click to connect,
our click to play, exclamation point, one,
some nice red text. And we can just continually
Actually, we can just window fill. So wind
fill, and we'll just fill it with white 00.
Or what I say gray, actually 128 128. And
we should just Where's when do I define it
up here somewhere? Yes, I do. So that's sweet
winds up there. So what we could do is just
fill the window, run into this while loop,
put some text on the screen. We may actually
have to fill this every frame. Let's get rid
of one of those brackets I created. So let's
fill this every frame actually. Okay, so we'll
fill it. We will blit this font. So let's
say when dot Blitz
text,
and you don't for right now, I don't want
to do it. We'll just do it. statically let's
do like 150. So tonight at the top of the
screen, actually, let's go 100 200 Okay, pygame
dot display dot update. Like that. Then if
they click something, what should happen is
that you break this loop, they should be brought
to the main thing. And yeah, that should hopefully
be working for us. So let's try this. Client.
Click to play. Okay, little little sketchy
on the click to play but let's see if we click
the play. Okay, waiting for player. So this
is what actually what I wanted. So it says
waiting for player. We're gonna wait for someone
else to connect. Okay, boom, connected. Sweet.
So now we're ready. So let's just run a game.
Let's go rock scissors. Now let's just see
what happens if we click x. This one goes
to the menu screen where it says click to
play. And it can be what do you call it play
against someone else, right and that's exactly
what we want it. We may also want to have
like a back button to go back. But I'll leave
that to you guys. So guys, I'm gonna leave
the tutorial here. If you guys have any questions
or run into any bugs or anything, please let
me know this is by no means like a full complete
game. There's still obviously a lot of things
that could be added to this. I hope that you
guys learned how to make an online game. I
find this stuff really freakin cool and really
interesting how you can have like a ton of
different clients connecting together. And
that being said, I'll see you guys in another
video.